I welcome those who have just joined we
would be starting within more 10 minutes
let's wait for everyone to join as
well
I welcome all those those who have just
joined we would be starting in more 5
minutes thank you for
joining
hello everyone I welcome you all to omx
research Symposium this two-day event is
designed to bring students researchers
faculty and Industry together to discuss
recent advances in omx data Technologies
and Analysis in this Symposium we will
discuss the changing role of
bioinformatics we will learn about
exciting projects in Academia and
industry such as clinical Pharma biotech
research and even agriculture as a
result you will learn about exciting
projects in Academia and Industry where
data analysis skills and solutions are
urgently needed the Symposium discussion
will be accompanied by a poster session
and competition awarding prizes and
giving a stage to students faculty and
research teams to present their work and
get expert Fe feedback you will also get
a glimpse of the International Community
working together to advance
bioinformatics education around the
world to make this field more accessible
to anyone it has become increasingly
clear that there is a huge demand in
bioinformatics training which has led to
the establishment of omx logic
bioinformatics training programs with
thousands of participants tens of
University programs and local chapters
in Asia Africa and the America where
dedicated teams interact with students
and faculty we will also hear from these
teams about their achievements and
vision as the program continues to grow
as the pandemic continues to keep us
safely at home we hope that we can make
the most from this virtual experience I
am sure there will be some technical
glitches and the interaction will be
very different from attend in person
that is why I would like to start by
addressing some common questions at the
start of this program you will find all
of the important information about the
speakers their talks and schedule on a
symposium link the same website contains
other information on poster competition
Zoom links and panels where we will be
able to ask experts about their thoughts
on the topics we discussed today use the
the chat box at the bottom right corner
of the screen to submit your questions
for panelists or get in touch with our
team for any other questions you might
have we also invite you to review and
share the content you will see here on
social media you can connect with us on
LinkedIn slack or Facebook you can also
find us on other social media platforms
where we will be sharing updates
insights from the Symposium and
introduce
speakers but let us Focus now on the
reason we are all here this first day of
the Symposium is dedicated to the
changing role of bioinformatics in the
research industry and education to get
us started I would like to invite Dr
Mohit
mazumdar Dr Mohit mazumdar is the
Director of Business Development at Pine
biotch previously he has completed his
PhD in computational biology at jnu in
New Delhi and has had a successful
career working both in academic research
and Industry now he is an in charge of
Partnerships and project mentorship with
pine biotech over to you Dr
Mohit okay thank you sonalika for the
introduction and it's great to see you
all here today with us I'm excited to
hear all the speakers and learn about
their prospective on the topic that is
dear to me I've been a student of
bioinformatics all of my life so I'm
excited that I'm working with many of
you here today on making this discipline
more accessible it is also great uh to
see as much as broader app appreciation
of data in the life science domain as
well as great excitement about the
potential impact of bioinformatics on
areas touching the lives of everyone
such as medicine vaccine design genomic
surveillance and even space
travel so let me take this opportunity
to briefly introduce myself our team
since 20 2019 we have launched the omix
logic in India with initial
collaborations at several universities
where we piloted our training worked
with fa to develop programs that
addresses the major Gap in
bioinformatics
education so uh we saw that with the
evident evident of many uh breakthroughs
in molecular biology advances of
advancements in Precision medicine uh
biotechnology and agriculture new
technologies were adopted in the
industry and research that uh research
that simplifies generation of accurate
and in-depth data however a lack of
analytical power uh and a lack of anal
analytical power and appropriate skills
amongst researchers and students uh
researchers and students created a huge
gap between data and information that is
needed in this field so the technical
demand prevents that for happening so uh
uh and that that limitation that
limiting ability to rely on techniques
such as RNA sequencing genomic
sequencing but after working with many
students at universities in India we
discovered even more interesting
insights that were relevant
today so after many programs
coordinating with universities and
thousands of students across India we
saw that there is a gap in the skills
that help students effectively integrate
uh these studies into their research
projects thinking critically about data
and applying appropriate analysis
methods to the right
data so in most of these uh case studies
in and in most of these cases that meant
students were able uh were able to learn
develop independent research project in
a short period of time and get excited
about the opportunity and apply
bionformatics in domains like oncology
neuroscience infe diseases and
agriculture so this overwhelming
majority of students were surveyed uh
pointed uh uh to their interest to
recommend such trainings and integrate
them into their
curriculum and this is why I think all
of this makes sense and this is why we
are here today to discuss what can our
education system do about this Gap how
do schools colleges and universities
prepare students for the future of
biotechnology Life Sciences in general
where bio biology is acquiring the
characteristics of data science so how
we manage to do this and uh how we are
going to overcome this is very important
so this Symposium is extremely important
for us and hope you all are excited as
we are to hear about these challenges
not from just us from our team but from
experts who have spend their entire
lives struggling to learn about these
challenges and more importantly come up
with great
Solutions so to tell you more about the
Symposium so in the next two days we
will hear uh these speakers address
these topics we can all relate to so how
to stand out from a crowd when you apply
for an academic program or a career in
bioinformatics what can universities do
to equip their students with relevant
skills and
experiences what is the future of this
field where will you find Cutting Edge
uh challenges that you can contribute
to so we separated these topics into two
days uh the first day is about the
challenging role of bioinformatics in
research industry and education and the
second day is on how you can get
involved and make an impact
finally after the speakers present their
insights to us uh in the form of short
20 minute long presentations we will
have a chance to ask them about the
prospective on the future of
bioinformatics in India and if you have
any questions and I'm asking all of you
here uh to ask your questions uh that
you would want to get answers uh ahead
of the ahead and you can go ahead with
the Symposium page and can submit your
questions there as well as well as you
can put them in the chat I will ask our
support team to monitor our submissions
and prepare them for the panel
discussion so the panel discussion will
start at 4:45 p.m. uh IST so that would
be uh almost 50 minutes from now after
we have the sessions uh from the
mentors so now I will ask uh Dr harprit
uh to introduce our first Speaker
Professor GPS ragawa so over to you Dr
harprit thank you Dr M let me share my
screen I'm honored to introduce our
first Speaker Professor GPS ragab
Professor ragab is currently professor
at and head at Department of
computational bosi at triple it New
Delhi before joining triple it in 2017
he was working as a chief scientist at
bioinformatic Center CSR Institute of
micro technology chandigar in India he
has received his PhD in bioinformatics
in 1996 from CSR mtech and Punjab
University chandigar he worked as a
postd doctoral fellow at Oxford
University he also worked as a
bioinformatic specialist
at at UAMS USA in 2002 2003 and 2006
where he established bioinformatic
infrastructure he also worked as a
visiting professor at Post South Korea
in
2004 Professor rav's research group
developed more than 2ou 250
bioinformatic web servers and biological
databases and published more than 300
original research articles with nearly
19,000 citation and H index
70 he has received a number of
scientific awards from different
scientific bodies which includes Shanti
subu bat nagar award in biological
science National bioscience award for
carer development JC W National
Fellowship from DST
India and he is a fellow of National
Academy of the science and he's also a
fellow of National Academy of Science in
bengalore in 2014 and 2015 Professor
Raga was awarded by Thompson rter for
the research Excellence award and ranked
him among top 20 bioinformatic
bioinformatics impactful scientist till
date Professor ragav has mentored over
40 PhD students and I am privil
privileged to be one of his PhD students
now I would like to in invite Professor
ragab to speak about the future
bioinformatics opportunity for
datadriven biological research in India
so over to you
R thank you very much for nice
introduction and I'm thankful to the
organizers for inviting me to for this
stop uh please allow me to share the my
slides okay yeah it's allowing
me
I hope my screen is
visible yes can you conf yes sir so
maybe you can just slideshow yes
okay okay so it's difficult person that
what is the future of
bioinformatics but I will discuss here a
few
points uh regarding the recent
developments in the field and in future
possible future uh
prospects uh Frankly Speaking I'm
working in this area from long time
still I find it's challenging why it's
so because it's changing too fast
whatever was important earlier now new
fields are coming which are more
important than the other fields actually
which we developed long time
back
so let's say first we have to understand
the
facts that we are going in the fourth
Paradigm of science initial science was
based only on the observation orental
science then theoretical science come
into the picture which contribute like
Newton's law Max
equations you have the theoretical
base white then the computer simulations
come like you are to do the modeling
simulations or maybe let's say you want
to send the satellite in the orbit so
it's not possible without the computer
simulations so that next third ER
basically dedicated to more about
this comput Parts in and recently the
major emphasis is towards the data
intensive research where data is
important from the data itself we are
generating theories driving the rules
and then we are using different type of
predictions we have nowadays like
Facebook which is
generating data in pentab bytes same is
true with the Twitter
Google the these are the
general sites but same is true for the
genomic data proix data metagenomic data
lot of data we are generating every day
question is how you manage this data how
you maintain this data and how you
effectively retrieve the that's a one
challenge another challenge is data is
fine but what you will do with the data
most important part is how to drive the
rules from
this this is a important part and now we
have to shift our thinking ear lot of
people I have seen in the bioinformatics
they are mainly focused very simple job
protein structure
prediction docking some
simulations and then they are doing some
drug Discovery so most of the biotics
were there earlier for the simply drug
identify the drug Target then predicting
the drug binding pockets and then exing
the different type of
drugs uh that is not sufficient for
today's time lot of data is there we
have to also
change uh as per the requirement
of because I will tell you one
thing in field of B you should to be
more Dynamic rather
than that's important if you want to
make your career in the field of biotics
you have to learn a new thing you cannot
stay with your old things actually maybe
you are expert in particular area but
not necessary tomorrow it will be
important so you have to change with the
time and one major part one major point
in Bion you cannot do anything as a Bion
medicine if sufficient data is not there
because we are using the data which is
generated by the
biologist if data is not there what
we'll do it's important you have to see
the
data and you should to learn the
techniques how to mine the
data if you use Simple traditional
techniques some let's say curve fitting
techniques or something they are not
going to work on the big
data you know very well this slide was
made by harit as you know harp is one of
my PhD student he has done a lot of work
particularly contribution in the field
of cancer genome protx lot of work has
been done when she was in the group and
she created this slide to me
actually so we have to understand the
different terminology we know all that
cell have the nucleus nucleus have the
chromosomes basically genome and it
is B with the histon basically so The
Binding of the genome with the his is a
study of f genomics
basically this is this field is called
epigenomics right so
similarly similarly if we have the whole
genome sequenc then this is called
genomics
okay
and if you take the all copies of mRNA
in a Cell then we call transcriptomics
if you consider all proteins
in cell that need called proix similarly
we have the non-coding RNA glycom miix
if it is modified glycosylated okay same
way you have the
lipidomic these are the different
different
areas we
have
so now I will talk about the uh the
growth in the biological data I'm
particularly focusing on
the genom oriented data or genome data
I'm not saying that this is the only
data there is a large number of othera
but I have the major Focus here today is
towards the genome or proteum
metagenome sort
of
so major emphasis in this side so it
very well qualify in the category of Big
Data whatever we are calling noway big
data so it qualify in the Big Data
because volume is there lot of genes
have been discovered so volume is there
vity is there because NGS uh due to the
NGS Technique we are able to
prod sequence uh the genomes at the fast
rate so lot of data is coming
daily then we have the variety all type
of data we have the mutations copy
number variations snps so all varieties
there so all three are there available
in the Big Data that's the definition so
I can give you one example though I cre
this slide few years back actually but
you see this is a protein Data Bank
protein Data Bank maintain all the
structures of
proteins okay so this database grow over
the time this is in the log actually so
it is nearly noways it ler nearly 1.5
lakhs actually
okay
150,000 uh but you see the gene Bank
where the Gen it's growing with the high
rate but see this sort of data that he
called wgs whole genome sequencing whole
sequen start quite late but it is
growing very fast actually it cross the
gene bank which is original main data
from the beginning actually
so message I want to convey here to you
that data is growing with the
exponen and it is very difficult even to
maintain it and then we have to drive
the
RO
then next part is now I will talk about
the some resources created by our group
in the field of cancer
research in the bu of
cancer so let's say for
example we have created the database
called cancer Dr that is a basically
cancer drug resistance where we have
maintained the data from the literature
or published data of th nearly thousand
cells their expression their copy number
variation their mutations as well as
each cell inhibition by
more than 600 drugs of
this by different modules I values are
there so we maintain This Heart
resistance accepted antibody which is
registered noway in number of CAS
patients so we maintain all the data
related
to similarly other databas like G
databases
so
I think he got disconnected for a moment
and let's wait a few second so that he
can reach
on in the meantime maybe you can post
again the links to the slag group it
seems like a lot of people are trying to
join so whoever has those links can
share
those yes thank you so much Elia I'm
sharing the slack Channel Link in the
chat box please join us slack channel to
stay updated with all the
schedule thank you so much
NAIA hello everyone yes thank you
sonalika and uh meanwhile if you have
any questions that you can thought of
that comes around while going through
the presentation please feel free to put
them in the chat box and we will be able
to uh have them answered uh towards the
end of the
presentation
okay so in the meantime while Dr GPS
Raga is joining I think it would be
great to interact with you all and know
more about your uh research background
your research interest and your field so
feel free to tell us more about yourself
in the chat
box
hi Ashish I think we will be able to
help you out with the slack group so if
you can share your email address here we
will send you an
invite and to those who are joining now
uh we were just having a session we just
have a technical glitch so uh Dr ragawa
would be joining back again uh so just
uh uh thank you for your patience we'll
be starting in uh in a few
minutes thank you J Krishna for sharing
and raka for sharing and Niha for
telling us about your research ideas uh
our research project so early detection
of breast cancer that's great we already
have a few projects on breast answer uh
which you can uh take a look at omix
logic learn
portal so I think we have Dr GPS Raga
back so we just make you the co-host and
you may begin thank you so
much
thank you sakshi and ton Moya for
sharing these are really interesting
projects that you guys are writing about
and we are really exciting to know about
them and uh we are also recording uh the
chats so we will be also letting you
know if we have any important resources
associated with these topics that can
help you maybe Explore More in the term
of big data and uh repositories and
information that you can get to improve
uh your research or maybe
hypothesis thank thank you reard uh for
letting us know about your interest and
uh in especially in infectious diseases
and you're from Ghana and we uh kind of
have a program in Ghana uh with naguchi
Memorial Research Institute uh on
infectious diseases where we have worked
on several projects and many of the
participants have submitted their uh
abstract and posters and they will be
showcased uh in the later part of uh the
of the Symposium so it'll be great if
you can take a look at some of those
abstracts and posters and video
presentations submitted from our program
in
Ghana and we also will be having
a upcoming talk
by um by Dr um Anita and team in Africa
so looking forward to that thank you for
joining
everyone so Niha uh yeah uh we do have
uh some projects I think maybe we will
be able to share a few links uh of those
projects with
you and meanwhile I'm also available
here for your questions so if you have
questions related to your project or
whatever you're doing and if you need
any further insights about some of the
topics please feel free to put them here
so me and our team here can help you
with some of those questions and getting
answers to those questions from
experts thank you sagur and disha and
ashwaria for sharing your email
addresses
we also have a next uh upcoming session
so if the technical glitch is not solved
uh we will be moving to the next session
very
soon so Sanju uh to answer your
questions what are the possible research
topics related to NGS
so uh we have been working on different
specialization areas and tracks using
the NGS uh Next Generation sequencing or
high throughput sequencing information
so these specialization tracks varies
from uh infectious diseases which I
already mentioned Precision medicine and
precision oncology then we have uh Agri
biotechnology where Agriculture and is
used for precision Agriculture and other
other technology IES have been applied
and other than that we also are working
on um specific diseases uh uh we are
working on uh neuros Neuroscience
related neurod degenerative diseases as
well as well as we are working with a
group on the effect and learning about
uh the space biology uh using NGS
information that is being recorded Now
by NASA and uh many other research labs
that involves like creating a
microgravity condition so I mean this
this is like a very uh important aspect
to learn about the kind of data that is
available with all of the topics that
you are just like you know writing about
so uh basically we sometimes are not
even aware of the information that is
out there because it's scattered around
and again um if you uh look and if you
start searching and do a literature
review and that's the best process to to
you know get to that PL uh get to that
uh part where you will be able to design
your project properly and we also have a
course on this so um that you will also
find on learn omix logic so maybe uh we
will be able to show that to you as
well
hello Dr Rakesh um it's really nice to
meet
you so you're from The Faculty of
biostatistics that's great prianka thank
you for letting us know about your
interest in NGS research topics so there
are so many research topics that
actually covers like almost all the life
sciences areas nowadays and especially
in biomedical research so I mean it's
fascinating at the same
time so um I mean uh if you are asking
about uh doing a project and utilizing
the resources and using our cloud-based
platform which is the TB info platform
um then yes there's a subscription
licensing system for that but yeah
obviously you can work on these projects
because the data is uh freely available
in all these depositories that you can
uh that you can access and download data
and then start looking at the Met
metadata to understand and design those
projects or integrate to an ongoing
project of
yours if there is so much interest in
projects uh meanwhile we have the next
panelist
uh uh ready maybe we can show you the uh
resources where you can see these
different projects that I'm talking
about uh so it's good to meet you Dr
pradep that you have it's great that you
have interest in clinical and om miix
data and we have an amazing talk coming
up by by Dr Shamir from astrazenica so
he will be also talking about how to how
do industry utilize this data and apply
this and integrate this clinical
information plus the genetic and omix
information for
uh outcome or for um some um
research it's great to see you uh
Professor
Dr uh suduk kumaran uh thank you for
sharing your email address and uh it's
it's it's amazing to know that you're
looking into the science of metabolic
engineering and that's pretty
fascinating to
know
all right so let me share my screen with
you
all and show you some of the
projects Shri Prasad okay thank you
you're Master student student in Germany
and you're also uh interested in
learning bioinformatics as well as uh
getting involved in ongoing projects so
we have a session specially for that
coming up on Research Fellowship so we
look forward to uh that that session
that describes the independent Project
work however um let me just take you
from the very
beginning to the portal so that we all
can do this together so if you're using
your browser please use this link and
let's go to this this portal learnis
logic.com
I'll paste it in the
chat infectious disease and
bioinformatics Isha you are a computer
science graduate that's pretty cool so
we have some courses for you to look at
also some projects on RN python so this
is the place uh and once you have create
a free login so registration is free you
can do the login here and then you can
look at at some of the projects that are
kind of uh taken from the these
different data sets that are published
and uh that you can work on uh further
also so we also have projects from the
students who have finished their
internships and fellowship programs and
some of the other omix logic training
programs and they have submitted these
projects that you can see here um that
the analysis what kind of analysis what
kind of applications that are there uh
working on different uh data sets on
different uh research problems so
there's a complete description of how
this projects have been conceptualized
and how they have been prepared so
there's a like there is always like when
you do research you have an overview of
what what this research is all about
starting with the data sets that have
been involved in this study and then
about the study itself like what the
study is all about the abstract and then
the introduction and then methods and
discussion conclusion and
acknowledgement this is a project done
by one of our research fellow R takur
similarly you'll find different projects
in this
part sorry it looks like Professor R is
back okay okay thank you for letting me
know sorry it was a discon
connection disconnected so I'm again
back all right so I will start my
presentation
can you confirm that my presentation is
visible yes sir yes
sir so we are talking about the
different type of resources these are
the some of the resources we created at
our department that's only few actually
if you see overall resources in the
world lot of resources have been
developed
so lot of data is available that's a
message same way we have the different
type of services for predicting the
different type of biomarkers some are
for the therapeutic purpose some are for
the prognostic biomarkers or predictive
biomarkers or disease Diagnostics Bally
so I'm not going in the detail
uh I'm presenting few Works actually
one of the work very interesting
work we done about the prior of drug
because it's not practically possible by
seeing the Genome of a person and then
you say you will discover the drug
that's not practically possible the one
possible way is that there are number of
anti-cancer drugs which are approved by
FD so can you prioritize the drug based
on the genome
or or epigenomics of a
person so in this paper we make ATT
where we have taken the different type
of
information mutation expression copy
number variation and the drug profile is
there we learn we use the machine
learning techniques we learn it and we
develop the
method and this is a just the example
which one side we have the name of the
drug another side we have the name of
type of cancer actually so you can see
that some of the canc drugs are
effective on all the cancer some are EIC
to the particular type of cancer Bas and
based on this part we develop the
prediction
method and we have used the mutation as
a input feature variation expression it
is interesting to knowe that our
variation information give
better
accuracy this is basically in the term
of the correlation then the mutation
variation give the better than the uh
variation give the better accuracy than
the mutation because normally it is
believed that mutation which is
basically rare is more useful but in
case of the predicting the which drug
will be
effective this varation work better but
best uh feature was expression of the
Gen the copy number VAR give okay
results but then we the Hybrid models
and based on this uh we developed model
where predicted an actual ic50 value of
uh cancer cell lines is have a
correlation 0.78 though it's not a great
accuracy ideally it should be one but
it's a basically ATT one of the
limitation of this stud is that this is
study is based on the uh cancer cell
lines rather than the cancer patients
basically so in future we will have the
more this type of uh
work uh because that's a future that
let's say a lot of people are suffering
from cancer they want to know which drug
will be best drug for me based on my
genomic sequence or maybe genome
expression data or whatever data
so that's uh
basically uh prediction biomarkers you
require one of the interesting part here
this is a work I'm presenting of
harit
so major problem is we have the gene
expression data or transcrip data from
the different platform it may be f
matric it may be Illumina or maybe RNA
SE data the question is basically
whether we can develop a method which is
plateform independent it doesn't matter
whether you
have get the transcript data from the F
Matrix Orum it should be able to predict
the cancer and non-cancer patient Bally
and she has done this work lot of data
is involved so the message here is when
in future you have to handle or manage a
large database that's a important
message same way this is another example
where uh we have in skin cancer we have
identified the HLA because HLA or it
called MSC actually major complex in
case of the human it is called H human
luite enen
So based on the genome sequencing now
you can do the H mapping as well okay so
H typing is practically possible so
first do the H typing and based on that
you can say the the survival what will
be the survival of the patient so we
have tried to predict the survival of
the paid person or risk prediction based
on the uh HL typ which we got from the
genomic sequence data so same way it can
be checked whether the particular vacine
will work or not work because H is
important
molecule which decide the type of immune
response
these are the some examples
recently we got the invitation from this
briefing in fun genomics and Har and
team they write the review on the
computer resources for identification of
cancer biomarkers so idea was that if
you are working in the field of
cancer or maybe disorder ass what type
of data is required how you will handle
it so we have provided review this is a
recent revieww in 2001 itself
actually so most important part data is
basically genomics whether you are
handling the gene expression data
or sequence data then you have the
epigenomic
transcriptomic proteomic and meta Mi I
think time is over how much time I can
take
can you
confirm yes sir so we have five more
minutes five more minutes okay so I will
go fast actually so this is a example I
will jump basically so the major
question is how to manage the big data
so here is the examples nowadays most of
the data is unstructured data it's
difficult to manage the traditional
techniques so there is a need to use the
no type of Technology where it's uh
using document based Graphics based or
column based basically so these are the
example mongod is one of the database
you can use it AP Hado is a very
important database management system
where you can manage the data and there
is a technology called map ruce
technology which can help you to
maintain the large data as well as
mining the large data okay so in machine
learn technique when there is large data
we have to use some specific softwares
like mahobat and others basically very
powerful softwares which are applicable
for the large data because they have to
work on
the distributed data so another
challenge is nowadays because the
machine learning techniques whatever you
call support Vector machine or neural
network or KNN they are designed for the
small data set okay not designed for the
large data so there is a need to
understand that how to scale these
machine uh learning technique or the
large scale basically so you have to do
the parameter optimization I'm giving
the example of decision Tree in case of
decision tree it's very difficult to
handle the large data so then map reduce
technology I was just discussing is a
important part basically okay and now
there is another part of the problems
drug resistance is another problem so
lot of data is there and
particularly Genome of the most of the
resent ex is available
available so you should to know how to
mine the data and find out whether the
particular population will be drug rent
or not so accordingly you can treat with
the different
drugs okay the another part is basically
now virus that if you see go to the
let's say ncba side so there is a 63,000
virus have been already sequenced okay
the data is available question is how
you manage it and how you extract the
important information can you predict in
advance which virus is going to affect
our population basically so lot of data
is there information is there major
challeng is how to take this data or
information in the future you can mind
the important information from this
data okay so this is the data for the
Corona virus and there is a need to
develop this sort of sites or databases
where you can predict the vaccine
candidate drug candidate biomarkers for
the given bi Mar we this is a site for
the j virus this is for the Corona virus
recently because we are facing this
problem so the other exp biologist can
take this data for their use actually
all right thank you very much due to
time I'm sorry that there some
disturbance
and we are not able to complete all
right thank you sir we have some
questions and I hope uh you will able to
address them so first uh first question
that I have so as we know there are
number of the repositories which
maintain paent data as well as their
metadata and omix data for uh from the
different parts of the globe but when we
looking at IND uh India so despite we
have such a large population and of
course a good medical system as well so
why still there is not a single
repository where you can find patient
data om uh their omix data as well and
what do you think how we can fill this
Gap so that B informatician can use that
data particularly to address health
concerns in India at least so what's
your though at the time of covid they
are trying actually to make some data
available through the gis and but you
are right other data like cancer data is
not available so far
actually it's a difficult question
difficult for me to answer actually
because I number of agencies and then we
raised this question number of times
they promise a lot but they are not
delivering
that so what do you think what policies
needs to be made at least to make this
possible maybe from government side or
maybe from Indian scientist
side government side it's not a problem
because I'm sitting in most of the
Committees DBT icmr and all committees
we make the rules but the intention of
the persons is a important part even if
you see y only some groups are there in
India who are providing the softes and
data and other resources normally they
don't prefer it they want to sit down on
the that knowledge or resources because
the lack
of or say insecurity is one of the
problem they feel that whatever
knowledge they have gain they don't want
to share with others actually so that
culture should change but at least in
this field actually bioinformatics
there's a lot of change in India but
this part what you are talking is
still okay so then I think Dr moit also
have some questions so yeah over to you
Dr
M thank you for this wonderful talk sir
it was really amazing and great to know
all of your contribution and we've been
following in India you for quite some
time and uh all the web servers that
have been developed and the resources
that have been put together is actually
helping the scientific Society a lot and
I just also wanted to tell you ask you
about this that um some of the
challenges that you have faced as uh you
know uh maybe collecting this
information together and then
benchmarking some of the methods that
would work with a certain kind of data
so for students I mean how can they
start like this is like a proper uh
maybe a long-term research but to get
them quickly acquainted with this how
can they start their Journey uh learning
about uh where to find it and how should
they start uh this entire process of
doing some uh quality
research first thing they should have
the question in their mind what problem
they want to address and then next
basically they should go to the pet or
any research resource where they can
read about the recent papers and then
they have to look what type of papers
have been published which resources they
have used actually and based on that
they have they should try and if
possible they should if they are not
exposed with this field they should take
some training from some uh agencies or
whatever the training programs are there
so that they will be have some knowledge
of okay sir thank you thank you for that
advice and I think everyone here also
have a few questions that uh they would
wanted to ask so if there are some
questions that are highlighted so
sonalika please you can ask sir also
about it and also sir I just wanted to
ask another question that uh I saw that
many students are now more uh you know
getting un an understanding of the what
what this field is so you have been here
for so long and you started back almost
30 35 years ago so you saw all the
changes that had happened to this field
and where we are now so what do you
think about bioinformatics as a field uh
to do research and for new people to
come in and people who have a background
in biotechnology
and Life Sciences to come up and do
something in bioinformatics or to
utilize and apply bioinformatics so what
are
your um for me uh major challeng is
basically inhibition in
the any life science student can do the
programming that's not a problem at
that's a good example from my group
itself actually most of my students they
are from geology life science
biotechnology all background and
whatever the website you are seeing
actually on my website developed by by
man why because there is inhib they feel
they cannot do it actually some first
thing they should have the confence in
their mind that you can do everything
actually because programming is not a
big deal at all actually only thing
there is inhibition they feel that they
are away from the computer they are they
have not touch any mathematics that's
not required actually nowadays you have
the Fantastic libraries actually you can
Implement any machine learning deep
learning all sort of things so this is a
fortunate part actually time where lot
of data lot of information is available
only thing you should remove the
inhibition from their mind that's the
most important part they can do it
there's no
problem yes rightly put and I think
that's a great thought and all of us
here should I mean uh maybe apply this
and start exploring in more and finding
more information because there's a ton
of information that we need to use uh
because it's out there all of us have a
responsibility also as a citizen
scientist to do this so thank you so
much sir for this session and uh there
are some questions and uh that many of
the participant would wanted to ask but
uh if I can request that if we can email
you those questions and uh we can then
uh send them back the
answers yeah sure
okay sir thank you so much okay bye
thank you
sir now I would like to invite our next
speaker Professor Palo Rana Professor
Rana is currently professor at
University of Hyderabad and director at
Aspire and execute president at fava
Hyderabad he has been working for the
past 30 years in the area of
inflammation and cancer he his paper on
lucrin synthesis along with Professor E
Cory who is a novel laat and the
discovery of a new pathway for the
conversion of Lucine C4 to Lucine F4 are
the significant contributions he's
involved in setting up of TBI and won
Nest incubation Center and founder
member of the Federation of Asian
biotech Association that is FAA as well
as participating in promoting in
Innovations and uh entrepreneurship
activities in the campus Professor Rana
will be talking about industry driven
education in health uh Health Care in
India so over to you Professor
Rana thank you Dr harit let me first
thank Dr moit and the P bio team for
inviting me to this special Workshop a
symposium so Dr Mohit has asked me to
talk on higher educational institutions
in
India let me first
share my
presentation thank you sir it's a
pleasure to have you uh
are you able to see my
screen uh yes sir but not in the
presentation
mod
yeah are you able to hear
properly uh yes sir
okay so what I thought was let me just
give a brief background about Indian
educational system in the higher
education and the then what India has
contributed to India as well as to the
global
community and what are the challenges
in utilizing the talent from higher
educational
institutions by Indian
industry and always we hear the
complaint
that the student Community coming out of
the colleges or higher education
institutions they are not having the
right skills to be
employed in the
industry
and uh so that is that's the
major complaint and how how actually we
could overcome that kind
of deficit that is present in the Indian
educational system what is the way
forward so that's how I have have
structured my talk let me just give the
global scenario of higher educational
institutions so in general higher
education is viewed as part of the
national agenda in transforming the
nation into knowledge based economy so
any kind of investment that you put in
higher education is going to give you
back and contribute to the economy of
the country also globally if you say
there are
30,000 universities or higher
educational institutions around the
world nearly 600 million students at
universities across all
disciplines four levels of Education
generally associate bachelor's Masters
and doctoral degrees these are all
different grades that are there nearly
50% of the student population are going
to higher education in developed
countries but not in other countries if
you see the kind of talent that is being
used by developed countries like us and
Europe you can see in USA there are 1
million plus people students from
various countries going there and then
contributing to their
growth similarly uk5 million china.
million Canada point so the talent
wherever it is that is being exploited
by these developed
countries and higher
educational institutions Indian scenario
if you see there are about 9 uh 144
universities which includes the state
Central private universities deed to
universities and among this 54 of the
central
universities and there are 388 private
universities 558 medical
colleges the most important
institutions all light institutions are
Indian Institute of Technologies there
are 23 of them and they are the major
contributors for Innovation and
Entrepreneurship not only in India but
across the world and very recently the
government of India has started Indian
Institute of scientific educ ation and
research isers isers are similar to
iits for science if iits are for
engineering isers are for Science and
Technology and there are 150 plus
Standalone research institutes are there
established by the
national funding agencies like Council
of scientific Industrial Research
Department of science and technology
department of by technology Indian
Council of medical research like that
and
3,500 Plus Engineering colleges are
there
both run by the state governments run by
the private
universities
and there are
3,400 Po
technices and
architectural colleges
so you can see the structure either
engineering or medical or
pharmaceutical these are the
professional kind of um courses that are
being run and on the other side the
conventional or universities are there
with all
multidisciplinary
structure and so this the number of
students that are enrolled into all
these educational institutions it's
really
uh large in number and in that way India
can boast that we are generating large
Manpower not only for India but to the
global community so India is the second
largest source of internationally mobile
students around the world so our
students will go
to undergraduate courses or postgraduate
courses or to the higher post doal
programs to various other countries
nearly 300,000 Indian
students in universities and colleges
abroad every year so that is the kind of
know not only they are getting trained
with in the educational system that is
there in the country but they are also
going out and
then contributions of um
uh if you see the contributions of
higher educational
institutions
sorry in 2019
42.6% of the workforce in India was
employed in
agriculture while the other half was
almost evenly distributed among the two
other sectors industry and services so
most of the of course the kind of
Workforce what we are talking in
agriculture is not may not be educated
but the other kind of Workforce but the
uh the talent that is coming out of
higher educational institutions are
going into either service sector or
industry sector India has seen a rapid
expansion in higher educational sector
since 2001 but the number employed in
the industry is very low the top eight
sectors offering employment or the
Consumer Electronics manufacturing
commercial real estate food industry
tourism textile mining banking sector
automobile these are the top that means
the Pharma biotech and other things come
much
later
and uh at what level they are employed
undergraduate is around 8% of the total
employment so uh poly Technic courses I
I 3% poly Technic
3% postgraduate are equalent kind of
degrees
133% management
equivalent courses
177% the graduates
with
either graduates in arts or Commerce or
science 177% Engineers 31% so most of
the emplo Employments are the for the
engineers which is followed by the
management equivalent or other kind of
things so so that is the scenario status
of Industry employment in India if you
see as I was mentioning earlier
41% uh in employed in the agriculture it
and service sector 22% fora
12% and Manufacturing
15% others are around the five fast
growing Industries are healthcare
industry food industry digital industry
infrastructure
industry so these are all the various
sectors what India has contributed to
High um the higher educational
institutions have contributed to the
global if you see our talent is employed
everywhere India's highly qualified
Human Services in abroad are highly
varied and have entered almost all
fields of economy especially it and
healthare
sectors if you
see that 21 of Indian origin star
executives are heading the global
companies that
means this the the products coming up
out of higher educational institutions
it is not good to say that they are not
well trained but these are the people
who are heading the Global
institutions you have examples which
were given Sund Pai
sat aay Paul Singh and Sanu
Narayan and so a number of people are
heading not only just being
employed in the global companies but
also at very key positions also so that
means the Indian educational system has
contributed a lot to the growth of the
global uh industry or global
economy but why Indian industry is not
able to tap that kind of talent why they
are allowing them to go and ser in other
if let us see the scenario
what how it is in India fora industry it
is very Innovative in reverse
engineering and in fact they are
the leaders in generics and supplying
the medicines at much cheaper
prices uh around the world and in fact
they have contributed a lot to the
healthare industry around the world
specifically in developing countries
which cannot afford the medicine it is
the Indian industry which has come
forward and then supplied at much
cheaper price
for diseases like HIV and many other
disorders so but they are mostly
concentrated on
generic when the new IPR resign came we
thought probably our Pharma industry
will enter into Innovation but that
didn't happen because of the generic
opportunity and now they all the Pharma
Industries they are also global leaders
but they are thriving on the generic
opportunity new drug Discovery is still
a challenge in the fora industry let us
see botch industry botch
industry so initially it all started
with the first recombinant hepatitis B
vaccine that was shanok developed by
Santa botch because of the contributions
of two main persons Dr guka from Santa
biotic and the
manager managed by
drad and establishment of many other
biotech
Industries and today the covid vaccines
are being
developed uh and distributed around the
world so the industry again has for
botch industry has also come up similar
to PHA industry but again
uh biosimilars not Innovative
products very recently you know Indian
companies also have just come up with uh
the inov
to vaccine for
covid-19 by bat botch and Jes cadila
also has come up for the first time DNA
[Music]
vaccine so the bio bio simuls have given
the opportunity for the B biotch
industry and and biopharmaceutical
segment accounted for the largest share
of the Biotech Industry with 64% of the
total revenues and the they are also
following the biogeneric route as I said
biosimilars vaccines and biosimilars
contribute to the largest
component and in the entire Biotech
Industry there not many Innovative
products which were
introduced so what is the next phase for
the father by a Pharma
industry Discovery route is the only way
to to become the global leaders and then
come up with Blockbuster
products challenges it is really highly
risky time consuming require huge
Investments but the Pharma and biotic
industry in the
country have that kind of capabilities
to introduce the products but they are
not coming forward what is the Way
Forward new models have to be
adopted so any kind of Innovations
around the world have come from academic
institutions it is the academic
institutions which have come up with the
Innovations which the
global Industries have taken up
exploited and then taken to the later
development so that is the model which
India also has to adopt Academy in the
Forefront and Industry at latest stages
of development so that high risk is
mitigated in the academic institutions
which are supported by the government
whereas the later development could be
taken by the industry and to promote
Academy industry
interactions specifically if you want to
impart the right skills required for the
Manpower uh for the
industry there should be continue
dialogue between industry and Academy
and that can happen with the push from
academic
institutions for
collaboration with the industry and the
pull from whatever the ideas Innovations
coming out of the academic institutions
have to be exploited by the industry so
these models may be thought of push from
the owners of Ip that is from academic
institutions and the pull from foran bch
Industries
and these models have to be uh adopted
which will help U uh for the growth of
the industry so adoption of
innovation is the success that is the
that that's the uh Innovation is the
GameChanger in the global companies
companies founded on scientific
discoveries or meaningful engineering
Innovation or the leaders
if Indian industry has to become the
global leaders it is the only Mantra ISM
to focus on innovations that means
engage with the academic institutions
and then promote the Innovation
discoveries in the academic in
institutions and so if you see the the
various areas where see the field is
rapidly changing unless you adapt to the
new technologies that are coming up are
emerging you will not be able to survive
and then come up with Innovative
products so so that's where know you
need to be in a position to adopt the
Technologies like artificial int
intelligence machine learning data
mining so a number of such kind of
innovation
Technologies or tools that are emerging
they need to be uh adopted and that is
possible only when you have continued
interaction with the industry you need
industry has to be continuously engaged
with the academic institutions and the
academic institutions also should have
continued what are the kind of skill set
that is required in the industry and how
to introduce them into the curriculum
these are all the
things
and the expanding pool of Professionals
in India is set to become one of the
largest talent pool in the world by
2027 so in every each and every sector
so there will be lot of talent that will
be available and that
Talent the right skills that are
required have to be imported into the
curriculum of the educational
Institution
and
so if you see the forecast five things
to know about India by 20130 it will be
second largest
economy even ahead of us that is the
kind of projections more than 1 billion
internet users 77% of the population
under the age of 44 80% of the
population is middle class and 5.7
trillion consumer spending so that kind
of Market you will not get in any other
country so that is why it is going to be
India is going to be the global focus in
the years to come Industries need to
exploit the talent from these higher
educational institutions and involve
them in Innovative discoveries with
initial so initial reskilling
you able to hear
me some background noise is
coming
yes uh Professor Pana you need to
unmute yeah thank you so much yeah yeah
so so far India has been recognized as a
manufacturing
Hub so it is a global manufacturing
center for either vaccines or by for the
Pharma products but the question is will
they
graduate when they are going to graduate
so there is enormous scope for Indian
Industries to come up with Innovative
products so the
advantages for India is sixth largest
consumer Market in the world 31% of
urban population 49% Workforce
participation attracted more than 49
billion investments in 2009 so the
government is also providing all kind of
incentives for industry to come up but
the industry has to focus on Innovation
on Innovative project products then only
they will be global leaders in every
sector that they are taking so the
Pharma and biofarma sectors specifically
supplying the products around the world
but the time to focus on Innovation it
has come up
so what is the way forward here deepen
Academy industry relations adoption of
immersion
technology that is whatever the new
tools that are coming up a ML and other
iot team all have to be adopted by so
that you're up to dat and then only you
will be in the race otherwise you will
be left out innovation entrepreneurship
track introducing new curriculum track
aimed at to equip
future scientists at higher education
institutions with business fundamentals
and familiarity with entrepreneurship so
academic institution should also start
such kind of innovation and
Entrepreneurship
activities and more important skill
development clusters have to be
developed organizing organizations
bringing together Academia and in
Industry an open Innovation platform to
provide skills training to freshers and
reskilling experienced employees so that
is the one which will promote Innovative
industry the
thing and um so India has come up
with new educational policy
and it
emphasizes on holistic multidisciplinary
education for future Nations
stakeholders so keeping in mind of the
skill set that is coming out of the
Indian educational institutions the new
educational policy is has come up with a
lot of
um changes revamping the entire system
internationalization of of higher
education that is very soon in academic
institutions there will be stud not only
students but even the faculty will be
recruited wherever the best talent
that digitalization of the is another
important thing that is now today in
every discipline every segment of the
industry also the data science is the
one which is playing an important role
so you need to
um you you need to empower the students
with the
digital Technologies digital
infrastructure digital content and
capacity building of institutes in
technology for
Education a l accreditation system also
has been going to be introduced so that
the the universities and institutions
can could be ranked basing on the type
of skills that they are
importing and also the kind of the
contributions that they have made to the
industry or to the academy not only to
uh training the students but even the
teaching faculty also need to be um
empowered with reskilling and upskilling
of the professionals that is
also so it all aimed at making India
self-reliant and making India to boost
the economy and to meet sustainable
goals of India so that's the
way so industry driven education system
must be is the focus establishing links
with industry and Academy is crucial
higher education institution to import
the right skill set required in the
industry and promoting Innovation and
Entrepreneurship ecosystem in the
campuses push from the academic MC
institutions and pull from the
industries so this is with reference
to yeah so in
summary India with the largest world's
largest population of 500 million in the
age of 5 24
years and the largest network of higher
educational institutions in the world
played an important role in every sector
not only in India but even around the
world however there is still lot of
potential for further development
provided the right skills are imported
by the educational
institutions and this requires continued
interaction of the educational
institutions with the industries to
understand the dynamic skill set
required with changing
times and Industry
should come up with res skill of the
professionals and potential employees in
collaboration with the academic
institution the skill at the academic
institutions and the res skill at the
industries level both are required to
make them employable which is being
adapted by the global Industries so the
push from academic institutions and the
pull from the industries are required to
generate industri Manpower in every
industry segment including the healthare
so that is what I thought but in this
connection I also wanted to introduce
the Federation of Asian biotech
associations which we started in 2004 to
provide a platform for the Academy
industry and government to come together
so this is a nonprofit organization
providing such kind of platform for the
Academy industry to come together and
interact and we also
has we are making sure that to promote
Innovation through Innovation awards for
scientists and young minds at the school
level itself and we are in the process
of uh having a global Innovation
clusters
meet and Hyderabad Innovation cluster
meet is also being planned so there and
very recently we have started fa Academy
and this Academy is mainly to train the
students um
in helping the students in their career
building and also skill development
activities so it is not only the
responsibility of the academic
institutions and the industries but the
organizations like FBA have been do
doing so we are identifying what are the
right skills required in the industry
and then
incorporating them into our workshops
and then importing to the student
community and in this connection we also
have collaborated with pan bio in this
effort let me also tell you briefly
University of Hyderabad one among the
top five universities in the country
with the 12 schools of study in this the
chemistry physics Life Sciences are the
the leading Science and Technology the
schools School of Life Sciences is one
of the
largest Life Science school in
the country with almost 75 faculty
members in One
roof and received the best university
award award at op great very recently it
was recognized as Institute of eminence
under which there are special grants
which were given so with that I stop and
I'll be happy happy to take any
questions thank
you uh thank you Professor Rana for the
insights so we have a few questions and
also some reviews already so we really
appreciate uh your presentation today
and so much information that we got to
know for the first time so I was uh
pretty much engaged throughout this
presentation going learn learning so
many new things about the ongoing effort
and especially what are the changes that
uh the government and the industry is
going through to accommodate the
transformation so um to summarize this
entire two sessions before I maybe uh go
to some of the questions that have been
asked so I just wanted to summarize for
everyone that um it was great to First
listen to Dr GPS ragua where we learned
leared about the application of
bioinformatics and what the importance
of data is now uh by Professor sana's
talk we got to know about the
opportunity so the opportunity also
involves U data Science Education and
biotechnology and health in this
healthcare industry so one of the aspect
that uh we kind of wanted to discuss is
that uh uh one thing that was coming out
of this entire uh presentation and the
way we have been presenting ourselves as
um the future of bioinformatics in India
is that how do we uh do it in here in
India uh by working with uh government
uh by by working with industry by
connecting to Industry and being able to
do and generate and have these soft
skills and skill sets that are the
future so uh with that uh I would wanted
to ask some of the questions that are
there put together uh so one of the
question that came in in the chat is
uh by Shri Prasad josi so Shri Prasad
josi is saying Dr Rana thanks for the
amazing talk I sincerely feel that HEI
from uh India uh uh except IIT and iser
plus some Elite Institute the Academia
is not providing enough experience from
the Practical side to the graduating
student so I feel like it is a must to
get a large number of pass outs both
with a degree as well as profound
knowledge in at least their research
interest I would like to know that what
do you think about this thanks
again yeah I I think this is the
scenario um in most of most Parts part
of parts of the
country um the students
see the skill set is a dynamic one it is
ever
changing but at the same
Pace the so infrastructural facilities
or the in terms of the faculty strength
or faculty expertise is not changing
that is where we need to have continued
engagement with the industry every
institution has to engage with the IND
but that is not
happening
and but despite that
our our work our student you know the
products coming out of the academic
institutions are able to gain knowledge
from the so maybe they need some kind of
bridge courses and those kind of bridge
courses are the ones which are the which
are being offered outside either us or
Europe somebody does MSC here and then
go for
PhD or somebody has done even PhD also
and then go to us or Europe or some
other countries and then work for a
couple of years learn those kind of
skill set and then they are the ones
which are leading which are being
employed by the industry either either
they come back to India and join the
Industries or they are working there
there itself but there are opportunities
if they are not available at your
colleges or universities but if you go
around and then tap the resources see
today there are so many Central
universities isers iats the students who
could
not get the proper skill set or Hands-On
training they can go for
internships they can write to the
faculty at universities Central
universities or there are National
Laboratories which I said
BST or CSR or DBT labs are there you
could always write and then go do
internships that's where you learn some
of the skill set if one has that kind of
willingness to go out and then learn
there are enough opportunities in the
country and it is not good always
complaining that no they are not being
provided and to the population that we
have it is impossible to provide such
kind of you cannot have IIT isets
Central universities in each and every
corner but those who are not having they
should tap the other resources that are
available in the
country so that's my advice to the
students okay sir thank you thank you
for answering that question so we also
have Dr herit as a panelist so if she
has a question Dr yes um thank you Dr M
thank you Dr Rana for such a wonderful
talk so I have a question like we all
want uh Industrial oriented research in
India but I have one question whether
Industries are sponsoring doctoral
degree for the PhD students so one of
the research Fellowship that I am
familiar with where actually industrial
part partners are also involved that is
PM Fellowship Prim Minister Fellowship
so apart from that uh do you have some
idea like from where or what are the
industries that sponsoring PhD for uh
Indian students so that they actually
develop such kind of skills at their
doctor level
yeah thank you yeah I think PM PM prime
minister's doctoral Fellowship is really
very good one where Industries are
involved but it all depends upon the
educational institutions for example at
University of Hyderabad we collaborated
with Santa bch Shanta bch gave the
fellowships for PhD program and the
scientists at chanta biotch could also
work for PhD
collaboration with the faculty at
University of Hyderabad Dr Red's
Laboratories also the scientist from
there could so I was a co- guide for um
the students from Dr red so that those
kind of opportunities are there but it
all depends upon how exactly the
academic institutions are exploiting it
is not just somebody no industry will
come and give you the ship but it all
depends upon how one interacts and then
gets
the so another question that I have as
you I mean indicated Dr ready and other
labs are offering uh sponsorship so
whether the students who are acquiring
that degree or going to acquire those
degrees whether they also need to clear
some like exams like CSI CSI research
fellowship or ugc research Fellowship
kind of exams before applying for those
kind of
scholarship it's not see University is
the one which decides the eligible
criteria for PhD either the entrance
examination or the Cs exam it varies
from one University to another
University no if they have a policy that
they will admit through the entrance
exam conducted by them then you have to
pass that exam otherwise if CSR
Fellowship see for example Ias will not
just rely on CS or icmr DBT
fellowships awards that they get but
they internally conduct their own exam
and then take so the policy
varies okay so another question like how
many fellowships they offer in an in one
year for example we know that like 100
to 200 students are uh sponsored by csir
for their doctoral degree and nearly uh
two to 300 or something like that are
sponsored by ugc for their Dr lii so how
many I mean in terms of a number for
every year these companies sponsor the
PSD
student the number is
not number number is not something that
you need to
negotiate is is
not uh uniform thing see for example
Shanta bch gave the fellowships to all
the MSC students
so when we were about 12 to around 15 to
20 they were all given the fellowship
and then two or three it depends upon
industry is not a fixed which they
announce and then
give okay thank you thank you
drana thank you once again and it was a
pleasure interacting with the students
also okay okay you sir
bye-bye thank you everyone uh this was
great to hear and I hope all uh learned
a lot from these speakers I would now uh
pass it on to our partners in Africa
where edun Edo will introduce the
speakers and the omix logic program in
Nigeria Ghana and the vision to elevate
bionformatics across the African
continent over to you
edle
so for the last session if there are
questions I saw there are many questions
uh we will be reaching out to uh
Professor Rana so some of the questions
from Shivali we will be letting you know
about that thank you for posting and if
you have more questions please uh put
that in the chat and we will be reaching
out to our uh to the to the
speaker SOA I think you need to make the
co-host so that he can share his screen
and mute
himself hello can you hear
me
yes yeah good afternoon everyone good
morning
depending on the part of the world you
are
in um I will be sharing my screen
shortly
okay
please can you see my
screen yes Ed only we can see your
screen thank
you okay great thank you very
much so I I would start now I want to
welcome um everyone once again to the
omix um research syposium that is
starting today and also
tomorrow um and so today we are looking
at the changing role of bioinformatics
in research industry and
education and um my single horor um this
afternoon is to speak to us about om
logic training in Africa and um share a
12 month um findings
report all right so um once again I
welcome us all um on board to this um
Rich um Symposium my name
is I'm a faculty with lead City
University here in Nigeria and also an
associate of the medical laboratory
science Council of Nigeria um similarly
I'm a mentor and facilitator Pine biotch
Incorporated USA um and um I'm
privileged to also double as the program
director of the H logic Africa um
program in partnership with urea and so
in this section I will be sharing with
us all um the increasing role of
bioinformatics and you know data science
in biological research with the effort
to present the impact of omix logic B
informatics training in closing the gaps
for resource limited settings and um so
um looking at the 12 month performance
report from inception I'm privileged to
quor this um this report with my other
members of the team which I want to
acknowledge Mr son Hamza M and Dr enu Dr
abor
Mr and
D all right so simply put um we want to
look at the 12 month performance of
these um you know of this um training
here in Africa um it is no longer news
that the completion of the Human Genome
Project in year 2003 has sped in a new
era
in genomics and application across
scientific Feats so what's interesting
to know today is um how computational
tools are increasingly being relevant um
you know in dealing with large and
complex uh biological data sets for
requisite analysis and also
interpretation to provide us with you
know meaningful application that across
several aspect of human life um
Endeavor okay and so um scientific
updating methods and mechanisms you know
actually ushered in by the the Next
Generation sequencing and related
Technologies know together with B
informatic tools for computational and
Analysis of captured biological data
sets has been a major D the scientific
advancement that we see in in the
research scientific research and
translational application space
today okay and though the African
continent is regarded as of mod humans
and also the African genomes you know
being discovered to contain more genetic
variation than those from any other
continent yet only fraction of these
genetic diversity among African
individuals has been studied um to date
okay this is enlarged partly due to the
gaps in capacity in terms of appropriate
expertise and training and this is
besides the primary challenges of inure
which of course is being is is beginning
to change especially following the
covid-19 pandemic and I like to cite an
example for Nigeria as an example uh you
know preco 19 we we we have I think just
about um two or three molecular um
diagnostic laboratory in the country but
I'm I'm I'm proud to say that you know
um into the covid-19 and um you know to
date we we now have close to 60
molecular Laboratories so these are of
the Silver Lining that the 19 actually
you know presents so um one of such gaps
however that needs to be closed is
building the capacity that is needed for
bi informatics and computational
Analysis Skys sets to utilize the huge
biological data um that is generated
today okay and um then I like us to look
at um you know B
informatics as an essential driver as I
mentioned earlier on the need for
analysis of a marging genomic um
sequence data and the completion of
Human Genome Project you know back in
2003 as I earlier mentioned of course um
has resulted in a landmark achievement
for bionformatics as bioinformatics has
become an indispensable tool for
management of the hugely generated data
in in in Modern Biology in medicine and
other you know scientific related
feeds however in contrast to other
regions of the world there exist gaps in
resource Limited set such as Africa and
Nigeria in particular when it comes to
harnessing the inter
interdisciplinary field of B informatics
to attain its full potential for
application in medicine in population
studies in Agricultural Science bi
technology among others so these T us um
you know the need to you know to to to
mainstream bi informatics into most of
our research um studies and um training
institutions across the continent so
what are the key drawbacks to
bioinformatics um you know uh in Africa
I like to point out one is the lack of
vibrant and dynamic bioinformatics
Community you know according to a
published report by thank God eor in
2019 one drawback is that many African
countries Nigeria inclusive um lacks B
informatics Community vibrancy and
dynamis as you know compared to other
part of the of the globe you know and
this is due to limit convening of these
Community populations of bat
informaticians um similarly there is
also a lack of bioinformatics
expertise is Keys set and training which
is why these you know Symposium we are
here today discussing to look at B
informatics in in Africa and um I think
there will be a panel session shortly
after now that we you know look further
into that to discuss how to move forward
from here okay so as a matter of fact
just as in many um other um countries of
of the world of of of African continent
B informatics here to reach it full
potential including in Nigeria a report
by fat in 2014 you know alluded to this
and also you know in their study in 2018
you know mentioned the fact that b
informatics despite some of the you know
advancements and um you know um I would
say Improvement we've seen lately in in
the genome science and
sequency you know aspect of research
there's still a huge gap when it comes
to um capacity um building for for for
African continent as it touches by
informatics all right so um I like to uh
at this point um I'd like us to look at
some critical questions then that that
has you know arose from several of these
Works um you know across across time and
space on on the issue of bioinformatics
and its role in in in in Africa so to to
develop the bioinformatics and ensure
that the African continent you know is
actually benefiting from this genomic
Revolution there's need to build
scientific capacity of African
scientists um as as already um you know
argued by you know several experts in
the genomic science space and so some of
those critical question includes how do
we ensure okay do we how do we make
knowledge of B informatics and Big Data
analysis you know accessible to everyone
including those that are new to the feed
all right another gerain question is how
do we ensure a sustainable vibrant and
dynamic B informatics community in
Nigeria and also in other African
countries you know at large and also
another question I like us to look into
is how do we bring the bioinformatics
community together and you know through
that drive scientific collaborations and
breakthroughs using these you know these
NOA computational analysis and skills
all right so that would take me to um
you know look straight off into what we
have been doing in you know with omix
logic Africa um in terms of
bioinformatics training tools and
resources that we have provided over the
course of the past 12 months okay these
need gaps as informed by those questions
earlier raised you know we have
identified in logic Africa urea and we
are inventively exploring closing those
gaps with the logic sets of B
informatics and Big Data analysis
training programs okay thankfully this
is um you know brought brought to be by
P botch inor USA um the focus of which
is to build capacity among students
young professionals researchers and and
you know faculties across the African
continent our postulation at hologic
Africa is actually that by increasing
you know the advancing um you know by
increasingly advancing the knowledge of
bionformatics and its use in obtaining
scientific Insight from these sequence
data there will be a significant growth
and development of the bioinformatics
community in Africa and also there will
be a considerable implications for um
you know translational science from
understanding gen functions as well as
its role in biology and medicine for
addressing the challenges that are
peculiar to the population within the
the African continent and so the hologic
group by which the H logic Africa is
guided includes want to provide training
in B informatics as well as enabling um
independent researcher um research
Guided by mentors and PE examples we
also are looking at you know working
with the goal of developing a growing e
um Community with a shared passion for
datadriven research and appreciation of
Citizen science and likewise um the
third goal is um to enable um students
clinicians faculty of all backgrounds to
develop novel and independent research
using latest technology in life and data
sciences and um over the course of the
past 12
month ly programs you know attempts
attempted to you know introduce and
participants to Big Data and NGS B
informatics training which is designed
for everyone interested to learn and
apply data science set on biological
data set and so theology programs
actually boost of everything a partip
needs to get started and grow in in bi
informatics and Big Data analysis space
for scientific research and practice I
would want to quickly I mean show to R
some of the um you know programs we''ve
conducted in the past 12 months um in
line with our goal over the course of
the last um 11 to 12 months we've
experimented with idea of bringing B
informatics training with project and
guided learning and resources to a cross
session of participant that ranges from
beginners and students many of whom uh
you know need to BU informatics um to
postgraduates researchers and faculties
wanting to also develop skill set and
research capacity in order to explore
the world of omic Sciences using B
informatics and Big Data analysis
knowledge and tools okay and so some of
the high impact training programs
conducted over the course of the last
one year includes B informatics for
genomic medicines these are some of the
things we we we we focused on during
that program how can B informatics helps
us diagnose and treat infectious disease
we focus on the you know sasc 2 outbreak
and we looked at yes genomic M the era
of covid-19 among other things and also
we we we also went into some trainings
that included basic logic training um as
well as om logic metag genomics and um
data science for biologists these are
programs we've organized in the past few
months which I will be sharing the
report um you know with us um
shortly equally um we we we able to also
look at introduction to B informatics
for you know um a cross session of
participant which includes both um
students professionals as well as
postgraduates and um faculties like I
mentioned and we also um recently
concluded B informatic at computational
um biology um you know as part of the
program so far um this is besides um you
know some other programs that we have
our participants you know joining the um
the global um report and so I'd like to
share here um some of the results we've
seen okay with hologic training in
Africa you know during the past um you
know um months why the total registered
um you know um interest in om logic
Africa programs to dat stands at
2,298 um results from our program shows
an average of about 175 participation in
our free um bioinformatics webinar all
right of course the the the the the
lowest um attendance was 56 and we have
in a single session where we had up to
317 participant joining one of our free
webinars all right and um a total of 280
participants you know with
61% of them um averagely 62% being male
and 38% female par participant has you
know participated in our um in the N
cohort I I initially mentioned to R Us
of the various programs we have
conducted and in in in each cohort we
have an average of about 31 participants
you know attending um I'm I'm glad to
also mention that over the the course of
this trainings and we've also given back
to the community to develop the
community um we've awarded about a total
of 26 um you know um scholarship you
know representing um 99.3% of the whole
participant we have over the course of
these um trainings all right and um out
of this we we glad to share that it's um
on a 50/50% um um you know um you know
percentage across the gender all right
both male and female and we've equally
um you know offered um you know two um f
Sorry Seven full scholarship um you know
to enable participants you know have
this knowledge of B informatics and
thanks to the Pine botch incorporation
um for for for those scholarships and
noteworthy is um like I mentioned 50%
gender parity among the scholarship that
has been offered um while 92.8% of total
participants are from Nigeria um we'
also seen participants from other
African countries including Ghana Egypt
um Sudan um Tanzania Zimbabwe and
Republic of Ben okay and South Africa
inclusive and we've had a lot of
interest from the
20298 number I mentioned earlier on
coming from the you know northern part
of the continent however there are
certain challenges particularly when it
comes to being able to maybe pay their
way into some of those um trainings and
and that is due to some of the economic
policies in those in those countries
however moving forward we are actively
researching into how we can mitigate and
ensure most of those participants from
that part of the continent benefit
richly from our um program all right and
so um it is pertinent to know that most
of the interest we've been getting for
our programs comes from the
undergraduate students with 53 you know
um 53.6% there about in indicating um
that they are interested in these in
this um H logic training in the
bioinformatics training however um what
we've discovered is most times
postgraduate students and University
faculties you know um which represent
22.2% and
24.2% interest respectively uh gets to
be the one that eventually converts to
join the program so meaning we have
about
67.5% in total of our cohort um you know
coh parp has been trained the course of
this past 11 month being postgraduate
students
and this is due to the fact that they
find this um training very applicable to
their um you know their their research
and ongoing studies in their various
University however we like I mentioned
we have a number of um undergraduate
students participating in these
trainings and um equally we have um um
we have um faculties as well joining
some of these in fact in each of the
trainings we have um facul we can see
the distribution here on the on the
slide apologies for this graph is too I
mean seems quite small all right so um
I'd like to quickly then share some of
the reviews we've gotten from previous
participants um you know you know
participa in our program here is Odin
Kinsley OA he's a medical laboratory
scientist and state here in Nigeria he
said um it's my first time learning B
informatics and I enjoy the course a lot
looking forward to more opportunities to
to learn more um also we have um
Umi um who who is a microbiologist um
from State here in Nigeria um she said
everything was new to me of course many
of them and this is um you know a key
take away I like to bring here many of
the participants are new to there's some
of them going through already I mean
having concluded their BC or even in
their postgraduate Studies have little
or no opportunity to be supposed to B
informatics you know and theic Sciences
generally all right so said she said
everything was new to me however it was
easy to understand that is one key thing
that you know hologic programs you know
boost of ab to make these things you
know really simple and accessible to our
um
participants all right few other reviews
um this is kashim from the northern part
of Nigeria say next Generation
sequencing was totally new to me in this
course work we were excited to learn by
following the syllable
I got to understand the principles
behind molecular medicine and the future
of modern medicine as a whole and um
last but not the least of course many of
these um you know reviews came from
Nigerian participant like I said
92.8% of our participants so far come
from this um you know from Nigeria um so
it was a great opportunity to gain an
experience I'm glad to have I canot some
information that amount that the amount
I paid for the program isn't commenor to
it was eye opening period I would be
glad to recommend my friends to
experience continue the good work so um
with this um you know as effort
continues to to to contribute to
building capacity of um prospective
participant across the African continent
we like Al we like to also share about
our next training program this September
on B forat and B informatics for
biomedical drug Discovery and so for
questions and in queries please uh I
would um appreciate you drop us you know
um you reach out through the chat okay
so in conclusion I I like to say that
just as the generation of B data has WI
a um you know interpretation of the
process data now presents a challenge to
one and all okay because it requires
multiple steps informatics tools andity
that is required to generate a final
results from the raw data that are being
generated and so in conclusion why
growing interest in bioinformatics you
know is um growing across um the
continent only about 10% of our
participants that is of the intending
participant rather being able to
actually join the um the training
according to our reports um majority of
the trained participant um sorry
majority of the participants would need
to be provided access you know to to to
be able to um come in and um learn as
they actually desired and so far like we
showed from our report majority of the
TR participants have been and
postgraduate students or professionals
so far um we are however convinced that
you know with University partner on um
hands on Mentor driven and globally
proven um training methods and resources
into the undergraduate trainings in
universities across um you know the
continent um you know as a complimentary
training to whatever they have in house
for for for their life sciences students
and all others who are interested there
will be a significant participation from
undergraduate students and that will
actually be representing you know an
opportunity to actually develop the
community and have you know participant
gain the reite btics skills do scaling
the growth and capacity of B informatics
Community within the African continent
um I would want to stop there now to um
welcome questions from us thank you for
listening all right um can you hear me
please
hello hello there can you hear
me yes yes we can hear you oh great
thank you so um I would want to I don't
know if Mr your is in the house to
Anchor the question
and I mean the QE session however I'm
available to take one or two questions
or you know um comments from us um
before we move into the next session
there are some questions that are going
the first one is it is great to hear
from you I have gone through several
articles and research modules
specifically to know how bioinformatics
work is in specifying enzyme characters
and their activities though it gives a
huge platform to solve almost many cases
in Modern Biology but still what are the
major fields which are still to be
improvised in bioinformatics and
computational biology to track drug
ingredients and metabolic pathways how
Industries can implement it better to
make more use of this field and create
more opportunities thank
you please kindly just um summarize the
last part of that question so that okay
I think the the main question is whether
you can highlight some of the ways
bioinformatics can be used to understand
drug
metabolism uh and uh use that
information to develop new treatments or
potentially repurpose drugs to address
pressing medical
needs all right thank you very much yes
so um bi informatics is um really
changing the landscape um of um
scientific research generally and um
that includes the biomedical drug
discovery
protocol and process so um your question
is how B informatics and computational
biology can be used to track ingredients
and metabolic pathways um yes like I
said in fact from um recent um you know
number of recent studies do outside of
um the continent that have come across
um you see um you know um a lot of
effort going into drug repurposing and
umics and computational tools is
actually you know key in um C to um you
know making some of those inal um you
know studies and so um moving forward of
course um there would be room for um you
know B informaticians people with these
um required and requisite Skys um to
also you know step up and um um you know
draw up um know um various um study
projects line and um in terms of um
monitoring the um the entire process of
our draw development process so
bioinformatics is really going to play a
key role but like I said I'm pointing
out also from this um study you
discovered that most um scientists in
the continent you know lacks this you
know capacity as it is do not get me
wrong we have notable scientists from
the continent who are doing explor but
of course um you know the the Gap is
still I mean the gaps in terms of um
research capacity and um you know the
the SK CS is still very much um you know
huge and these are the things um that
informs the need for building the
community of B informaticians across the
across the continent so um we look
forward to um you know being able to um
you know um partf find some of these um
tracking of drug ingredients and
metabolic pathways in the process of
development like you said particularly
here on the continent you know in the
near future and and thankfully our
platform also provides a research um
opportunity we have a research um
license for those who might want to also
join you know p tech and logic to be
able to explore these
opportunities thank you thank you so
much Eddie kle so uh we have a question
uh by ogona he's asking as an individual
who is new to bioinformatics area please
how do I have the access to the
introduction to bioinformatics lecture
so OG let me just answer this we have
the introduction to bioin bioinformatics
lectures on our om logic portal we have
a proper course on that which is free
for everyone so you simply need to sign
up on learn and go ahead with that
course and uh also we have a question by
pradep he's asking if some of us have to
get involved in community efforts in
Africa research and education what would
be the level of Engagement required what
are the different Avenues and
opportunities so if edle can you please
mail out the details to prep for uh the
engagement required and what are the
different Avenues and opportunities uh
prip can you please share your main ID
we would be now moving ahead with uh a
talk by Dr Anita gansha so your um
question would be answered by the maid I
hope that works for you thank you so
much yes thank you for that hopefully P
discussion some perspectives also will
be provided to that question thank you
Yes actually we have been uh our
schedule is such that we have got uh
accommodated a lot of great speaker
talks and we would be taking in the
questions and we don't miss out we don't
want to like give a short answers uh we
want to tell you your defined answers to
your questions so please fill out the
form which oasi had shared let me just
share the form again with you all please
uh fill the form here with your question
and we'll answer your question in detail
by this form thank you so
much
okay
so good morning and good afternoon to
you wherever you are um my name is Anita
gansa and I'm a senior research fellow
at the nuchi Memorial Institute for
medical research of the University of
Ghana um today I'm going to talk to you
about bioinformatics of infectious
diseases and the relevance to Public
Health um I'll first of all introduce my
Institute to you and tell you the steps
we are taking to try to incorporate
genomics and bioinformatics into
infectious disease research and the
public health relevance of
bioinformatics in the work that we do
and I'll use malaria as a case study at
some
point so the nuchi Memorial Institute
for medical research is a biomedical
research of the University of Ghana and
our core mandate is to conduct res into
diseases of Public Health importance to
train postgraduate students in
biomedical sciences and support the
public health programs of the ministry
Ministry of Health and the Ghana Health
Service we do this specifically through
conducting Research into communicable
and
non-communicable diseases we provide
training support to in biomedical
research for undergraduate and
postgraduate students and provide
highend laboratory Diagnostics and
monitoring and surveillance Services as
well so for public health um in order to
support
the six um pillars of Public Health that
is Health protection surveillance
prevention Health assessment health
promotion and emergency preparedness we
use um we support with
diagnosis and then sampling for
surveillance we are interested in
knowing the circulating pathogens in our
populations and what this means to
Public Health and then we also
interested in environmental samples so
that we know what is circulating in our
water bodies Our Food and what this
means to Public Health so for instance
if there is an
outbreak what we do is to conduct um
surveillance for
cases and these surveillances could be
either active or passive so we will
actively go into the communities and
Fish Out people who have sympt
and then we test them and then treat
them or passively if they have the
symptoms they come to the health post or
the clinics and they are tested and
treated so the um biological specimen
that we take are used for molecular
epidemiology studies to support the
diagnosis and potentially to look at the
relatedness of the cases and then the
fied
epidemiology bits will will suggest the
transmission pattern of the
infection now there are limitations to
these traditional methods the genotyping
that we do in the molecular epidemiology
may only tell you the clusters of cases
that are present without much
information on the order or the
direction of the transmission and the
size and grouping of the
Clusters um will depend on the
resolution of the genotyping method and
to a large extent what we are using is
just PCR amplification and restriction
fragment length polymorphism which is
very low resolution so we rely heavily
on epidemiological
Investigation to sort of Link the cases
in order to understand the transmission
patterns and this for the most part is
very little information that we have we
don't have sufficient EP information to
to track the
transmission and the diagnosis becomes
very time um consuming it's
subjective um you get variable
performances or results and so we end up
not diagnosing most of the infections
and the phenotyping obviously will be
very slow and the surveillance with low
resolution
genotyping is what um relies on very
high-ended epidemiological data which we
do not have enough of so we think that
pathogen
genomics can help us solve some of these
um limitations with the current way that
we um diagnose or
we phenotype or we do our surveillance
so we think this is the way forward for
us so comparative genomics analysis by
high resolution or high trut whole
genome sequencing offers that high
resolution for epidemiological
investigations of infectious diseases
and this approach we know has
revolutionized outbreak detection
monitoring of transmission dynamics of
infection infectious agent and
antimicrobial resistance across
humans um animals and the
environment so what are some of the ways
that we can use um pathogen genomics
to study public health and diseases or
outbreaks or pathogens of Public Health
importance one is understanding the
Dynamics of epidemics so what you do is
to sequence and Assemble the genomes of
a pathogen of
interest from an epidemic you build your
phogy to identify the various plates or
subclones and plot the prevalence of
subclones across space and time to
understand why or how the epidemic is
happening the second way is to discover
brand new pathogens so if there is a
brand new pathogen what we can do is to
do met genomics on samples from a
patient with this unknown disease and
then you blast the reads against the
database of all known organisms look at
a set of reads that didn't match to any
known organism and you know that this is
the new pathogen so your sequencing will
focus on this um and matching
organisms
and after sequencing you you can
assemble the Genome of this novel
pathogen build your philogen and see how
it relates to other members of its genus
and do comparative genomics to identify
genes or elements that are present or
absent in this new pathogen relative to
the other species and this will give you
an idea
of exactly how this new pathogen looks
like now we also interested in
understanding the drivers and evolution
of within host and population level
evolution of resistance so at the
population level we tend to look at look
for signatures of selection it could be
a recent occurrence so selective sweeps
within the genome of um
pathogens that are linked with
resistance and at the within the host we
look at heterogenity within an
individual with respect to the
population so if there is um higher
heterogenity in the individual compared
to the population it may be interesting
this U may be associated with either
resistance within the Clones that the
individual is
carrying now we can also date the time
of viral infection or any other
infection with a sequence data from
viruses in a patient we build a phenetic
tree where Branch length correspond to
the calendar time and identify the time
to the most common um
ancestor and this is the time of the
infection and this is normally a
coalescent model and there are different
cois models that are used
to they determine the time since the
most common um ancestor or the time of
the
infection the next thing we can do is
therapeutic monitoring of drug
resistance so for instance if somebody
is taking
anti-al um it's on anti-al treatment if
you sequence the viruses in this patient
multiple times and scan the sequences
for known mutations that confer
resistance to um
the drag then you can change the
treatment regimen if you find that that
individual with time is um harboring
resistant um viruses to the drugs so
moving from green to a resistant red and
then changing the drugs so that the new
um variants are now sensitive to the
current
drug
now we can also use pathogen genomics to
understand um the population structure
of pathogens so here we see a cluster
but different cles within this cluster
of MRSA in the
UK these are the two gray cles and then
Germany represented by Berlin in the
white cluster and then um the dark gray
representing Portugal and in the second
panel we are using um the tree to
understand how the gene
flow
from Britain through um Berlin to spread
to other parts of
Germany now we can also use pathogen
genomics to understand or to predict
resistance so first of all you can ask
what is resistance
you can look at mutations versus um
compensatory um
polymorphisms and then you can use it to
understand the effect of rare variance
on resistant phenotyping you want to see
what that a rare variant is now um
increasing in the population is it also
conferring resistance now to um a drag
or not now you may you must also be
interested in what information is in the
database and how this database is being
maintained and you must make sure that
your sequences if uploaded onto the
database
um um your sequences should be either
new or comparative to what is in a
database and then we are also interested
in the quality scores that we will use
to identify what is resistance
in different modes and levels of gene
expression so quality sces when we are
measuring um resistance using gene
expression um data now diagnosis we can
also sequence pathogens and look for
genes that signify diagnosis or markers
for diagnosis here the sensitivity in
the
sequencing directly from Clinical
samples become very important do we have
enough quality to give us sensitive um
enough um diagnostic
tools then for clinical
metagenomics um you want to identify
which is the pathogen or who is a
commensal and which is a um contaminant
and then again we need to build capacity
in order to achieve all these for
epidemiology there are certain questions
that you would want to clarify how can
we infer transmission from genomics data
alone how can we infer transmission when
it's not just a strain but a
transcriptor that is moving in the
population do we have enough special
temporal coverage of annotated genomes
to make um proper inferences about the
population dynamics of an infection so
yes you can have genomic data but the
data should be enough to give you actual
influences about the population now
let's shift to what we do with malaria
these are practical things that we are
interested in so for malarial control
the talk in the malarial community is to
eliminate
malaria by
2030 I think that's where we are now and
the goal to do this is to um come up
with Discovery
efforts at new vaccines drugs and to
maintain the elimination
targets of um zero prevalence of malaria
parasites in our populations and to do
this you need tools for accurate
diagnosis because if transmission is
reduced considerably you will need very
sensitive tools to diagnose um
malaria and this we can only use genomic
approaches very sensitive um deep
sequencing to pick very low um
infections and we need effective
prevention and treatment regimen and we
need to stop transmission and prevent
reintroduction of parasites in areas
where we have achieved zero um
prevalence during
elimination now what do we currently
have we have vector control
interventions like indoor residual
spraying of homes and then the use of
bed nets and this is targeted at the
mosquito vectors and we have preventive
therapies for pregnant women and
children who are living in um seasonal
transmission areas and even for
populations with seasonal malaria
Transmission in certain parts of Africa
and we have diagnostic testing with the
rapid
diagnostic um kit and then microscopy is
our gold standard and we have very good
treatment with arisin combination
therapies and then we have a very strong
malaria surveillance and one vaccine
that is at a Pilot implementation stage
in three countries in Africa these are
Ghana Malawi and Kenya but the challenge
with malaria control and elimination is
the complexity of the the malaria
parasite so the parasite is so
diverse in its nature because it has to
surmount the
mosquito host and then when bitten and
release into the body has to surmount
the liver stage even moving from the
peripheral blood to the liver stage it
has to surmount the host immune system
and then the red blood cell when the
liver
stage um evades invades the red blood
cell
so it does this with very extensive
genetic diversity it it diversifies at
various stages and this makes the whole
process very complex in controlling or
eliminating the parasite and as a result
we have resistant to the atomising
combination therapy it has emerged and
is spreading in the greater makon sub
region around Cambodia Mayar Thailand
Vietnam LA and now in Africa we have
Rwanda and Tanzania experiencing at
resistance on a very small scale so it
is spreading and then there is
insecticide resistant mosquito vectors
also a major problem and for our
diagnostic kids um there are deletions
in the genes that were used to develop
this diagnostic kit and so there are
about 10 or 15% of people with this dels
across Africa and therefore we are not
diagnosing malaria
properly but technology is advancing so
we are using um nucleic acid
amplification techniques for genotyping
we are using panel of
um molecular bar codes we started with
24 a panel of 24 now there are some bar
codes that are about
150 for genotyping microarray technology
whole genome sequence and whole
transcript sequencing and the gene drive
and then we have a huge database of
genetic or genomics data and these
resources are very helpful this is a
list of some of the resources available
for malaria um
genomics
now
specifically we are doing um highly
Multiplex targeted sequencing and whole
genome sequencing our objective is to
develop optimal strategies that we can
use to um look for markets that will
help us understand importation because
when we are eliminating malaria we want
to see which Market are coming into the
population and these are also being used
to track any the effect of various
interventions so if it is um a drug or
vector control intervention or a vaccine
we are using these special temporal
monitoring of resistance and parasite
population to assertain the efficacy of
these interventions we are assessing
human human variation and parasite
variation so we are interested in
understanding how antigens are
presented
hello hello can you hear
me
hello was I timed
out oh sorry welcome back Dr gansa you
can continue please sorry about that and
yeah I guess it's
Network
okay yeah so I was talking about how we
were using um highly Multiplex targeted
sequencing um to answer specific
questions of Public Health importance we
are interested in modeling and
statistical analysis to help us deal
with polyclonal infections and large
scale temporal and genetic data
sets we want to preemptively surveil the
African malaria parasite for genetic
markers of resistance we don't want a
situation where we are overwhelmed with
highly resistant parasites so we are
constantly surveilling for um resistant
parasites and so we also looking for new
tools for drugs vaccine insecticides and
diagnosis using inal designs that we
hope to take through for laboratory
validation if we
succeed um we also interested in genetic
mapping by linkage or genomewide
Association studies to select genomic
regions and strong selection um these
specifically candidates for drag
resistance and then we are interested in
causal variance for and highly VAR vent
malaria or severe
malaria we are also interested in
mapping studies that can help determine
differential expression patterns across
the plasmodium um life cycle to enable
identify new drugs and vaccines Anita
sorry your screen is not shared your
presentation is not shared for
screen sorry about that yeah
so these are some of
the few studies we have conducted in
Ghana
to determine the prevalence of previous
drugs like chloroquin resistance in
Ghana and it is through these studies
that we're able to advise the malarial
control program to change the policy
from the use of chloroquin to the
current currently used um first line
atment combination therapy these are
molecular epidemiology studies we
conducted at our Institute we are
tracking the we are still tracking these
molecular markers of drag resistance of
these previously used drugs like
chloroquine sulod doxin peramine because
we are expecting sensitive parasite to
emerge after removal of the drug
pressure and the idea is to advise in
the future on either reuse of some of
these drugs in combination with other
drugs or for prevention of um malaria we
are also tracking
the frequency of the deletion in the um
rapid diagnostic kits Gene in our
population and and we are looking for
new genes for um
diagnosis and then this is an example of
a study that is monitoring the effect of
um a vector control intervention that is
the spraying indor residual spraying in
Northern Ghana and its effect on the
resistance of the malarial parasites
after the a period of
spraying and we are interested in the
genetic diversity of
the vaccine
antigen this red and blue
um cycle I'm showing here is the vaccine
strain the current malaria vaccine which
is made from the circum SPID protein
this is the vaccine strain so it means
that all the other strains that we find
in these two regions in Ghana
will not
um work with a vaccine so you see how
important understanding the diversity of
the malarial parasitis this means that
we either have to develop a new vaccine
or incorporate a lot of these trins
because the cross immunity that was
expected filed on the
field we have also tried to
incorporate Next Generation targeted
Next Generation sequencing in our
um estimation of um drug resistance in
our population and we recognize that
this is a very expensive Endeavor so we
have come up with Innovative tools that
will still help us use um Next
Generation sequencing by pulling samples
from sides we have succeeded in pulling
samples from one site so we carry to our
Central lab two samples but a pool of
100 each we isolate DNA prepare our
libraries and then we sequence and apply
all the bioinformatic tools to determine
the prevalence of these um resistant
markers and we obtain as high as 99 or
98% Concordance
when these same samples were sequenced
individually so for population level
studies with think that we can cut cost
and still apply um Next Generation
sequencing to monitor drug resistance
across Ghana lately we are also working
with pine biotech
to understand the not just the extent of
diversity but the effect of these
variants in our population on the
protein structure and its function and
this is one gene the plasmodium fum
epical membrane antigen which is
involved in the invasion of the red
blood cell we want to see how um the
diverse strains in the
population is affecting its interaction
with another protein the PF Ron two that
helps with the invasion of the um red
blood
cells so in summary what I'm saying is
that if we conduct our clinical studies
or any field study after diagnosing of
an infectious disease and we have our
epidemology studies and laboratory
procedures we should we can go ahead and
sequence and use
bioinformatics um in comparative
genomics phenetics analysis to help with
um clinical genotyping as well
ultimately
to bring about public health action on
infection control and prevention and
individual
treatment I think I will end here and
acknowledge all our collaborators thank
you very much for your
time yeah thank you very much uh
Dr uh
Anita uh we have a few questions for you
uh can you hear me yes I can okay um
first question
is about
um is about
um
okay yeah so the first question is uh is
can you share how you analyze data
but I guess I guess you you you
mentioned
that yeah so um basically if you um
sequence your
pathogen um you align it to the
reference genome and look for um any
variant within your sequence and then so
for us if you're doing drug resistance
after your alignment you come up with um
the regions of Interest where your
resistant markets are and then you
estimate the frequency of um your Market
of interest and this is more statistical
at this stage but it is
the bioinformatic the complexity of the
bioinformatics involved in attaining um
good quality sequences
and trimming your sequences and doing
the alignment and um coming up with your
variance of
interest that
we We There is a gap in doing that but
um we know we know exactly what to do a
few people in my group are able to
analyze this data yeah and after getting
your frequencies then you apply any
statistics based on the epidemiological
question that you you you or the epid
data that you have you attach it and
then you um do your statistical
analysis yeah thank you very much for
that answer uh there is another question
and uh it touches um it touches how one
can track
resistance I mean uh like can we track
resistance applying genomic studies yeah
that was the question yeah you answered
that but uh I guess you want to still
add add few things to
that yes I think we have to track
resistance it is very important if we
want to be in the past when you were
using a drug like chloro we were not
tracking resistance and we were just
overwhelmed with highly resistant
malaria and parasites and people we had
a lot more debt in um Ghana I can say
that so with these new drugs we want to
um track resistance
and
um control it or if we find it in a
particular Hotpot in Ghana we want to
track it and then manage it at that
Hotpot before it spread how can we do
that surveillance is now a tool for
tracking resistance so in Ghana we have
now 30 Sentinel sites by the Ghana
Health Service or the malaria control
program where we go the um other moments
annually in this um drug efficacy
studies you conduct a study take people
who come with malaria and then you take
samples from them we test for these
molecular markers of resistance to these
drugs yes at missing we are still
discovering what the markers will be but
any marker that has been found we are
testing and um you also do
invitro testing of resistance in their
labs and then the clinical testing of
resistance and with the pulling of our
samples we think we can do deep
sequencing so that um we will pull some
PS from these 30 sides and we want to do
this monthly do the Deep sequencing so
that you'll be able to pick a resistant
parasite as soon as it emerges so when
it emerges in a particular region then
we will focus on that region and do a
more extensive study so it is doable
it's very doable
yeah yeah thank you very much for that
answer so uh like she has said it is
very possible to track
resistance yeah I used to remember that
uh as a microbiologist once before I I I
moved I mean I became a molecular
biologist we still we use we used our
microbiological ways to also track R
resistance now uh we have molecular
approaches to that yeah so the next
question uh we have here is that uh is
that uh good to see your expertise on
bioinformatics in genomics and the
question goes like this he says that uh
of course we we took I mean we we get we
get help from software technology to get
relevant information and to analyze some
things you know things about pathogens
but uh the question is how much is this
uh I mean how much specific is this um
is this technology are they error free
um uh have you been able to to detect
how I mean the best way to analyze
studies that is I mean that is in this
um in this in this
sphere yes so thank you very much um
like all our traditional methods
microscopy is very subjective it depends
on the microscopist doing it microscopy
misses a lot of low frequency or low
prevalence infections so with PCR we are
able to account for the errors from
microscopy now PCR also has got its own
error
rating with um High to put sequencing
you get more depth it's is not error
free but the depth of information you're
able to pick the most um let's say
um just the first few um resistant
parasite or whatever phenotype you're
interested in as it emerges so you weigh
the the benefits with the
um um you want to see whether the
benefits outweigh the risk or the
disadvantages of the method so there are
advantages but definitely these
molecular techniques are far more
sensitive than the standard microscopy
or restriction fragment Le polymorphism
analysis that you were using
traditionally wow wow that's that's uh
that's uh something and uh I know uh in
I mean after a while we would uh we
would uh get to that level of perfection
um before I go to the question relating
to ethics of research um I guess I would
love to uh to take this next question it
says that how do we obtain statistical
information from the public on
infectious disease I believe that this
this uh this person is trying to ask
about the sphere of Citizen science and
its application to your
research did you say statistical
information can you repeat the
question yeah so the question is how do
you do you do you uh obtain statis
statistical information from the public
I mean uh do you go in collaboration
with the people do you I mean uh what
what public health uh method do you use
to get to get those your samples and you
know information about resistance and
and some of these things all right so
for every study whether it is the malal
control program involved or it is a
purely research study you you enter the
community and you have to um it's called
the community entry you educate the
community about the project and you see
whether they will buy into the project
you have to make sure that they
understand the project that you are
conducting and then you seek their
consent so if it is a clinical a study
for children you need parental parental
consent If the child is over 12 years
you need in addition to the parental
consent you need the accent of that
child and it is a voluntary thing
ethically they are not under any
pressure to be part of the study we tell
them if you don't take part in the study
doesn't mean you're not going to be
treated so and there are so many
communities that we've worked with and
we have built so much trust so they work
with us in collaboration we make them
part of our study design or um we we go
to them and ask them what they think we
should be doing for them as a community
so they they are part of our study and
therefore we able to collect
um the epidemological data from them and
that helps with our statistical analysis
yeah wow thank you very much uh it's
very very enlightening um I believe that
our researchers in the house are taking
cues from this um uh like uh okay um for
those that are just joining us we're on
to uh Dr Anita ganza our research
includes building capacity in the in the
use of of uh of
P perum that's a a a parasite and uh and
uh she uses genetic data to describe the
extent of the genetic diversity of the
parasite uh you know and discovery of
new Gene and Snipes are that has been
biologically I mean that is biologically
important to to research and uh she also
has been able to adapt um
bioinformatic um advances to to to
further research uh uh the last question
I will be asking um from you uh
concerning this as we close on this note
is the question of Ethics uh yeah you
mention it but I would love you to to
specify uh in the course of your of your
studies uh What uh what major ethical
concerns are of arising or or as the
likelihood of arising uh and and how do
you do you go around to solve some of
these ethical issues that that that
relat to your your your research
work yeah so um as I
mentioned
um some of the key concerns that we have
with study participants are that
sometimes there is misinformation people
think that um you're giving them a drug
that may affect them in different ways
there was a whole BH about the
introduction of the
vaccine the malaria vaccine in Ghana and
um we had to do a lot of community
engagement public education for people
to understand the importance of um the
signs behind the vaccine and to
understand that it was not going to harm
them and there are issues about um the
risk involved in doing some of these
studies normally the kind of samples we
draw are very low risk we tell them um
this is low risk but if anybody is
affected in the course of the study that
person there are arrangements for care
for that person and
um um so in terms of the risk to
participants we take care of them we
work with clinicians and
so but to a large extent we work on very
lowrisk um studies just either a finger
prick sample from an
individual that has not really hurt them
yeah and we we we make sure that we do
not coers participants
into taking we respect um participants
confidentiality we try to go by the
ethical rules for the conduct of
research and we make the we give so much
information and our contact so that
participants can call you we the
principal investigator or the leaders on
the project for any um explanation and
they are free to withdraw from the
studies at any points of the study yeah
thank
you uh thank you very much uh Dr Anita I
I guess that I will be reaching out to
you more uh in the nearest Future um uh
on this note I would uh I would be
sharing my screen now uh thank you very
much
thank
you um if you have other questions uh I
would love that you you write them down
or you reach out to the uh to your to
your program director or your um your
community your community engagement
manager because uh because it is going
to I mean it's it's something that that
we would uh we would love love to to
answer in the long run
um I guess on this
note on this note I would love I would
love us to go to the next session uh
today is still day one I want to ask can
you see my
screen yes we can see okay thank you
very much yeah so on this note uh I
would love to to welcome those that are
just joining us again um you welcome
again uh this is day one the omix
research Symposium uh has been focused
in changing the role of bioinformatics
in research in industry and in education
um the Symposium uh is not only
providing a platform for discussion it's
also provide I mean it's also providing
a platform for for you to to to get more
information about researching uh and and
how you can you you can apply some of
this information in and knowledge to to
Industry and education um
we will also love to see see how you
also get involved in this and for those
wondering that okay who speaking with us
my name
is alabu um I'm part of the omix logic
program for Africa team I am the
community engagement manager uh for omix
logic Africa and urea I'm a molecular
biology and genetic uh and genetics
expert from Penza State University I am
an African and uh I have a special bias
for U for population genetics and uh I'm
faculty member of rosom Academia in pen
State I am a
certified um bloodborn pathogen uh um
expert and uh I'm I'm an Enthusiast of
data analytics data science big data and
everything data here on this note I
would love to know if uh if Mr ad is
ready I would love us to to get set we
will be having a panel session we will
be having a panel session uh Mr de are
you
ready yes please I am ready thank you
very much okay over to you Mr de all
right so I will be sharing my screen
[Music]
um all
right minute please
okay
good once again I want to um greet
everyone good morning good afternoon
depending on the region of the world you
are located um and I want to welcome us
um once again to the OM research um
Symposium
2021 um this Symposium has been put
together to bring together students
researchers faculty and Industry to
discuss relevant and recent advances in
omix data and bioinformatics and so some
of the focus of these scientific
Gathering includes learning about B
informatics and um The Cutting Edge
research and applications there in to
also get informed about undergraduate
Masters and PHD programs in
bioinformatics to learn about career
guidance and Industry internships and
jobs and also opportunities for b
informaticians um that um is exist in um
you know in these various um applicable
feeds and likewise to equally look at
opportunity at um discussing how um
resources for training and education can
be made effective and so um as part of
this um during this session would and
under theologic Africa segment um we be
looking further into the changing role
of bioinformatics in um research
industry and um education
and in doing that we will be um moving
into the panel discussion where I have
some experts in house um um to help um
you know provide perspectives to um you
know topical questions we would be
looking um at um this afternoon I have
with me on this panel um Dr Anita gansa
who just um finished speaking with us um
she is a fellow of um she's a fellow at
the nush Memorial Institute for medical
research Ghana and I have um her a
pleasure of having her on set to yet um
you know benefit from her weight of
experience um Dr you're
welcome thank you for having me great
thank you very much also I have with me
um Dr V to um she is the chief executive
officer biology support service Nigeria
and um she's the founder
of of the organization and she's
actually very passionate about
biosciences um capacity building in
biotech as well as the business of
biotechnology and how to harness um the
untapped opportunities especially in the
Nigerian bio economy Dr to you're
welcome on
set hello Dr to are you
there yes good afternoon thank you so
much good afternoon we are happy happy
to have you um I have also with me ham
um Mr Hamas um he is a data scientist
and fellow of the medical laboratory
science Council of Nigeria and um he is
a data science Enthusiast with Keen
interest in using bioinformatics
research to answer biological questions
around blood parasite um infections um
um um I like to also mention that Mr
Hamza currently serves as a quality head
safety and environment executive for
afloat limited which is an aviation
company in Nigeria Mr Hamza we are
pleased to have you are you on
set definitely good afternoon it's nice
being on ground thank you very much okay
um last but not the least um we have
also on set um Dr Adrian ler um Dr
Adrian ler is a researcher a lecturer
and a business development um expert in
NGS and biotechnology from um the South
um Africa um um she's also honored um
you know sorry she's also a say
professional and Commercial lead for
Illumina in 12 countries of the Santa um
South Africa I'm sure we we know
Illumina a lot um it's um one of the
platform that is very I mean reputable
for you know what we are here talking
about when we talk about NGS that n um
generation sequencing all right so Adan
is also an independent non-executive
member of omix Data Solutions um you
know Pro limited and um she is a
freelance scientific editor medicine
with Cactus Communications Incorporated
and also she is the founder and
co-director of contemporary Africans
mentoring in not for profit and
mentoring company we are very pleased to
have um Dr Adrian L with us Dr Adrian L
are you
there yes I am thank you very much for
having me great great thank you all for
for being here myself I'm like I
introduced before I'm the program
director foric African faculty um with
lead City University here in Nigeria um
I'm a principal partner at urea and also
the program director for logic Africa
and I'm privileged to lead two head Tech
startup as e f and CEO um they are Prett
young and screen and I'm also a faculty
with um you know Lead City University
Nigeria so it's my pleasure being here
today to Mad session um without wasting
time I like us to move on um as I
introduced earlier on I will been
moderating this session and I'm honored
to have all our panelists on board and
what we will be looking at um is
bioinformatics needs and training in
Africa um as we all know bionformatics
today is shaping scientific research and
um helping us to derive more information
and knowledge about genes and their
functions and also in finding its
application to various human diseases
such as cancera diabetes um just to
mentioned a few okay um it has aided
research in evolutionary process by
align comparation of DNA sequences
sharing of data prediction of um you
know future Evolution and classification
of you know complex evolutionary
processes and so um the future also
holds a lot for bioinformatics in that
it is going to help us to obtain crucial
management decisions on drug Discovery
just like someone asked you know earlier
one of the sections okay
and um it is going to be something that
is not going to um I mean left to the
domain of biology alone but also B
informatic B informaticians and using
their B informatics tools and knowledge
would be playing a key role in this
aspect and that is why we want to in
this section discuss around
bioinformatics needs and
training um in setting all right and so
without um further ado
we want to move straight to my first
question which I would like Dr Anita to
please you know open the floor okay so
my question would be how has um
bioinformatics as a feed developed know
in Africa all right and how does it
continue to evolve and what are some of
the um major challenges you know moving
forward and especially brought about as
a result of the recent pmic all right um
Dr Anita would you open the floor with
that yeah thank you very much
um I I think that the past um 15 or so
years has seen a growing interest in
bioinformatics across Africa um I
remember around
2009 I personally was the only person
talking about bio informatics at my
institution when um I returned from
school I mean it was so farfetched but
today everybody knows the need for
bioinformatics and what comes to mind is
the H3
Africa initiative by the National
Institute of Health of the
USA that has funded um bioinformatics
support the H3 Africa is a human
heridity and health
um Grant support for human genetics in
Africa and out of this grant is the um
H3 Africa bionet and this bionet for the
past 20 years has extensively trained
Africans in bioinformatics mainly in the
southern part of Africa but countries
across Africa including Ghana Nigeria um
Tunisia Egypt southern Africa across
Africa have benefited from this training
but there is still a huge gap there
Still Remains this very huge gap in
bioinformatics training and for me the
pandemic has been a blessing in
disguise we took the silver
lining of this pandemic
and online training online training in
bioinformatics is something thing that
shot up during this pandemic and I think
that um that is what I would say to
start with thank you thank you very much
for for that thank you very much um I I
I like Dr vuki to equally I mean weigh
in on that question um you know talking
about what are some of those major
challenges brought by the pandemic of
course I'm looking at it from the
perspective of how B informatics is
actually involving in the African
continent
Dr V
please yeah thank you thank you so much
ad and um thank you for your
contribution Dr
Anita okay um yes bio informatics um
even though it's been around for quite a
while we're only beginning to
um get things going on here in Africa I
first heard about bi informatics during
my masters in the year
2003 and it's quite new to me and um and
I felt that it was something that was uh
very necessary with the kind of data
that was coming out with the from the
human uh genome Pro projects and other
uh sequencing
projects um
Coming um moving forward and um get
coming getting to do do some studies
here in Nigeria realized that um we
really didn't
have um even the plan on how we were
going to move bi informatics you know um
forward here in Nigeria and I think that
was also because um even our our
genomics hadn't even picked up because
it's very difficult to talk about bi
informatics without genomics and
understanding the basis of this
data so you would really just be you
know struggling to figure out what is
going on okay so um the challenges are
are
are are many and they're quite deep
rooted we have gaps in our our training
that is very obvious across
universities and um also gaps in having
the right people to teach so when we
don't have the right people to teach
then it is difficult to pass on the
knowledge so we still struggle a lot
with
that and so um some of the things that
um you will notice is that there' have
been quite a bit of efforts from
different groups Dr Anita has mentioned
hory Africa who have been very very very
instrumental in uh Bridging the gaps in
training we've had a couple a group
called The Nigerian bio informatics
Network I don't know if you know that so
um I've been part of them as well trying
to um increase awareness and get people
uh to realize the need and importance of
Bio informatics we held the conferences
in
2019 uh prior to this we've had um some
supports and Partnerships with global
Health Workshop uh the University of
Calgary and this has helped in firstes
of all training uh students at the
University of Lagos and uh this um other
community unities in genomics techniques
and how and also with basic
bioinformatics these gaps are still
there we find that even when we have
some of these trainings uh the students
are eager to learn and all but suddenly
once they come in um the gaps that are
there make it difficult for them to um
you know move forward and you just find
out that oh when you start a training
with about 50 to 100 people by the end
of the training of of 3 months you
probably just have maybe a handful and
you realize that they just couldn't
flow okay so we are we need to find a
way to address these challenges of
getting the younger generation or the
current generation to be um able to fit
into into these trainings or or have
that uh basic background to enable them
um get the best out of the uh trainings
that we are beginning to bring in right
now so B have moved from where we were
uh 10 years ago now we're talking about
multiomic we're looking at um variations
of data and trying to make sense of it
so it's a lot that we have to do and and
we just have to figure out how we're
going to get
our
students fully on board on what they
have to really do thank you very thank
you yes thank you very much for that
thank you very much for that um Dr vuki
mentioned about you know the aspect of
um you know um faculties to teach I mean
to train um interesting participant and
equally um you mention the aspect of um
you know the the bioinformatics in
Nigeria taken up as a result of you know
recent Grant and effort how be it many
of the participant get to drawback I
mean at the middle of the training which
points to the F of the need for Basics
well um without taking much I think I
will want to also hear from Dr Adrien to
get a perspective of what is what it is
like you know from the southern African
parts of of the continent
so um you want to see maybe in pass few
things quickly regarding what has been
some of the challenges that has been
identified okay thank you I will just
add a few because my previous um
co-hosts have already covered quite
extensively on this question um I would
say what the pandemic has brought as uh
change is it
has enabled Africans to see that we
should and we can be
autonomous uh when it comes to
Scientific development you know with the
pandemic and the borders closed and the
supply chain uh challenges that uh came
as a result of of of uh the pandemic
we've seen that we've now become a
little bit more Innovative in our
thinking um but not only that the world
has also realized that you cannot
isolate um excellence in terms of
technology so in the past it was very
skew you know the genomics technology uh
as well as the bioinformatics expertise
but now seeing that you have to I mean
should anything like this happen and
borders are closed the world has to keep
going um the pandemic the the virus had
to still keep uh uh being monitored and
surveyed in across AC across the world
to to to uh prevent variant from
emerging or at least from to to notice
when they do emerge and it has made it
such that the world is now invested in
having every other part of the world
as capacitated as any other uh we can go
into details on on this aspect but what
I'm trying to say is there's been a lot
of investment in capacity building
uh in Africa but not as an isolation
it's actually a drive to make it a
global movement so that the the genomics
revolution is not isolated in bits and P
parts of the world but it's actually uh
Global in its distribution so that that
will be what I'll add on this question
we can go into the details as we
progress okay thank you very much thank
you very much for that um I mean one one
key take away is your opening remarks
talking about how these you know
pandemic has not only as in has made us
to see why we should and can be
autonomous we can actually be autonomous
and this um you know talks or goes down
to the the need for um you know us to
develop you know B informatics and you
know all other resources to a scientific
research here in Africa okay so thank
you for that um I'd like to move to the
next question um so um what are some of
the applications of B informatics um
that is most relevant you know in Africa
today all right looking at the various
researches or the various possibilities
from from B informatics so what are
those applications um you know that are
we can readily point to that are very
relevant in Africa today I think I would
like to start from um Dr um Aden again
sorry uh permit me to start that
question um from
you okay um so I think there more
um most of the research so when we talk
about bioinformatics obviously it
doesn't stand as isolation as somebody
previously pointed out it's it's uh an
arm to the genomics uh research projects
and priorities that are currently
ongoing on the continent and um from my
perspective uh currently the interest is
uh diseases mostly infectious diseases
but also now with the um Trend and
growing uh prevailance of of uh chronic
diseases and lifestyle uh uh diseases
like cancer and diabetes there's also a
lot of research on that so um I think
anyone
considering um bioinformatics should not
only focus on infectious diseases and
pathogens but also look into um chronic
diseases so then your population
genomics comes to mind um which is
something that I I believe still has a
long way to go in on the continent but
it's it's getting there um among which
really it's currently cancer mostly um
but we also have things like
cardiovascular disease
um uh rare rare genetic conditions as
well
uh things like uh cell anemia and others
um but that that is on health uh and I
believe most people sort of gravitate
towards health because there's funding
for health there's a lot of interest in
keeping people healthy but we cannot
also neglect um the loss of
biodiversity that is currently happening
um right under our noses so Africa being
one of the most biodiverse um continents
we need to sort of invest in researching
and in following up what is happening to
our plants what is happening to our
natural resources um in the oceans um in
our forest the animals so there is there
are there are a few groups that are also
working around that um and while we are
on the subject of environment but also
sort of cross cross-section to health I
know there's also a lot of research
around um drug resistance but in the
environmental sense so lots of groups
and research uh um projects are looking
at um antimicrobial resistance genes uh
found in the environment so in water um
principally sort of to see how these are
distributed and also because those are
easy easier
uh samples to access and and study and
monitor what is actually happening at
the population level um yeah I think
those are the major ones that I can I'm
I'm sort of aware of and I'll just let
the other hosts um present their
perspective okay yes thank you very much
for for that response I think you
practically covered a lot of um you know
aspects where um you know informatics
actually applicable one key thing you
said was the fact that you know B
informatics is not cannot be isolated
it's actually um you know has a lot of
connections with all of the OM sciences
and um that is very very very um correct
and true um so Mr Hamza please um would
you um want to add to that um you think
there's anything left out from what Dr
Adin already
mentioned thank you very much Mr de I
think um she had almost read out all
those aspects that is very very gerine
in addition to what she has said I think
um one aspect we are looking at be
lifestyle
disease and and that that is just an
addition to the list of issues which has
mentioned so far and as you as you know
generally speaking we were talking about
preventive medicine now and then because
of people's people's Indulgence in a lot
of things lifestyle is is a factor that
will affect people's Health in
the so and
that with om generally we have a big
role when it comes to B informatics to
getting um things done in the best of
ways then most
importantly it has Advantage when it
comes to personalized
medicine with the just like Dr an
mentioned and Dr toi earlier in question
that you raised one of the biggest
things that happened to Africa is the
pandemic and the pandemic has opened our
eyes to see how Global the world is
being a global village particularly and
looking at how we can be able to see how
can explore this opportunities around us
so I think the biggest thing that
happened to us is all to look at Beyond
Africa how do you have access to B
informatics training knowledge and
application as much as possible and then
just in addition to what you said just
add lifestyle disease just another
addition we know about cancer which has
been ravaging African but with with this
this content a
plus all right all right thank you very
much for for that um you know
perspective um shared by you and I think
um you know just to I remember now the
American God project that has to do with
you know um sequencing the microbiomes
of you know the participants in that um
project and um I think a lot of
Lifestyle um you know um you know
perspectives was um brought into that
project and that goes to tell um about
what is actually phys when we talk about
lifestyle diseases as mentioned by Hamza
Mr Hamza all right so um I think I want
to move on quickly to the next question
and my question would be what companies
or universities or colleges hire or
conduct
researches are related to B informatics
particularly here in Africa okay we'
mentioned the H3 Bonet the H3 Africa
projects earlier on but are there
additional you know organizations that
are involved when it comes to you know
um you know hiring or conducting um
researches that are related to B
informatics I think I want to start out
with Dr
V Dr V please
yeah thank you very much okay so besides
uh H3 Africa I would mention a few that
are present here in uh
Nigeria and um starting with the
Nigerian Institute of Medical Research I
do know that they do uh um quite a bit
of um research
involving uh sequencing of uh certain
genomes especially with HIV which which
they work on a lot and now with the um
covid that has also come in they also do
a bit of quite a lot of sequencing
trying to monitor the variants that are
in circulation and I believe they have
cut a couple of Publications in that
regard our laboratory biologic is also
one of the laboratories on the
Consortium testing for covid and we work
work together with um other Laboratories
and insute of medical research uh in
monitoring the covid uh pandemic we also
have uh uh Covenant university cenet
university is um home for um some of the
B bioinformatics gurus we have in the
country uh including Dr fat sh fat who
is in the UK and then we have redemer
University again here in Nigeria that's
in in Ed where we have Professor happy
and um on the private scene we have 54 G
they're also working um on
the but on the private level and um
biologics is also working together in
ensuring that we have uh we are building
capacity in this uh space those are a
few that I can come up with at at the
moment perhaps the other uh panelists
can speak about this as well thank you
all right yes thank you very much um
thank you for that I would want to pass
it on to Dr ad now to share a
perspective and seen that she actually
covers I mean a number of countries um
you know with her um representation from
Illumina okay but I'd like to add to
that question just before you take that
okay seeing that we have a handful just
as you know Dr B already mentioned who
are in De here in Nigeria um compared to
what is um um um you know obtainable I
mean what is possible would you say we
have um a good number of you know
organizations universities and companies
actually participating in that
space Dr ad
please okay um I'll start with your last
question um yes no no we don't there is
there is still a lot to do um when it
comes comes to for
example there's a growing interest in
Africa as um a data source for the
diversity of our genome and our
biodiversity right um however when you
look at the
database where most of these uh genomic
data is being stored you you are very
disappointed when you see how many are
soured or are coming from uh
institutions in Africa or from Principal
investigators of Africa um so there is
there is still given that we sort of own
the resource in terms of if you're
looking at diversity the richness the
power of Discovery is literally in
Africa right now um the res the the the
actual work and the capacity to to get
to that those answers is is still very
much lacking so from from what from
where I stand
um in Africa I'll tell you that I I
wouldn't call specific names but I'll
tell you sort of where you should be
looking if you are a bioinformatician
trying to get a career perspective um
you should be looking currently with the
interest of making genomics part of a
public health strategy you should be
networking your Ministry of Health um
there's a lot of uh sort of projects
that are being um conducted directly by
your governments um and these are being
uh monitored or uh driven so to speak by
the ministries of Health now it trinkles
down to universities so you want to look
at consultas like um those that like the
H3 uh Africa and others that have been
mentioned you want to look at those
consortia and see what sort of projects
because they do list out the projects
that they are working on so you want to
see what sort of projects who are the
principal investigators because most of
these people they now sort of play a
dual role of doing the data um
generation
as well as the data analysis but the
ideal the ideal situation will be a
little bit of specialization so someone
people focus on the sample collection
and generating the data and then the
bioinformaticians when the skill level
is really at its prime will then mine
that data for all the discovery that we
are uh talking about here so you want to
look at research groups in in those
consortia and then you also want to look
at in the private sector um because not
all your
universities um and research groups have
the capacity to um own a a a sequencer
for for uh for their research you do
have private core
facilities that have a number of uh
sequences in and of different brands um
uh that they manage and so they generate
data for their clients and currently
most of them are not yet getting into it
but there's a big demand for these core
facilities to also assist the
researchers with their bioinformatics
analysis so that is another Avenue you
as a bioinformatician can propose your
services your skills and use it as a way
of growing your skills as well so to
assist these core facilities to sort of
implement this uh service to their
clients um and also you have um
pharmaceutical
companies um that are currently looking
at gener at um using big data for uh
identifying new drug targets and things
like that they also investing a lot in
bioinformatics currently so for example
in South Africa you have have a company
called Rush it's a multinational company
but they are also very much invested now
in doing R&D so in Africa most of your
companies are not yet uh doing a lot of
R&D but it's happening um and so you
want to keep your eyes on your ears on
the ground for that um last but not
least I would say you can become a
consultant like let's have bio
entrepreneurs that are bioinformaticians
right so you can start your own company
go to people one onone offer your
services and help out because most
people are really expert at generating a
collecting uh uh super uh uh uh premium
samples preserving it and doing the DNA
R in extractions and doing all of that
but then they cannot get to the the
discovery part of it that lies in the
power of bi informatics and also you
have your clinical side of things
there's a lot of talk now to have
Precision
medicine um and most of your clinicians
they know the concept but they can they
need someone in between the data as it
comes out of the sequencing or uh and to
come into a form of a report that they
can then translate into a decision or a
a councel to their patients so those
sort of things and um I said last but
not least but I'm also thinking about
another sector that is growing which is
smart devices um smart devices that are
making use of multi omix data to sort of
put together algorithms um to power uh
uh devices that will sort of tell you
eat this don't eat this drink this don't
drink this this medication not that one
so those startups are also coming
through I hope I haven't taken too much
time but thank you thank you
it's a bright future for bioinformatics
Africa yes I agree with you thank you
very much for that you've practically
covered lot about you know the areas of
applications and opportunities that
exist in the B informatics um you know
feed okay so now I think to to tie um to
that would be for us to quickly discuss
um you know around the educational and
training part all right and so um
quickly I think I want to start with um
those who are heavily involved with um
you know training institutions so Dr
Anita um i' like to ask um you know how
come is it that many universities are
not actually um you know invested or
participating in former bioinformatics
um training I mean they're not you know
um they are not they not offering B
informatics degree especially um you
know at the undergraduate and even at
postgraduate lab as it is currently in
Africa so why is that so yeah thank you
thank you very much
um as we've been discussing bio
informatics itself in Africa is still
very new people are aware of it but um
we haven't really integrated it into
what we do as
universities individuals um are applying
bi
informatics in various capacities you
talk to almost
every student they are analyzing some
sequence data or they've learned how to
blast data or something
but we haven't gotten to that point
where it is actually incorporated as a
course or as a program Masters or PhD
program I think that University of Ghana
the last I there were about four or five
um universities in Africa that had a
masters in bioinformatics so it is
coming up but it's catching up and the
other thing is that those who the
trainers
themselves a lot of people Africans who
have trained in bioac are still in the
diaspora because they think that there's
no market for them so that is another
problem and um some people what have
notice that people are shying away from
bioinformatics because our training does
not give the biologist especially that
mathematical that strong mathematical
background to be able to
embrace the thinking as a
bioinformatician or even applying
bioinformatics extensively so the
universities themselves must have a
change in curriculum such that anybody
taking an undergraduate program not
necessarily in
biotics but any biology based program
must have some must understand the kind
of data existing now and how you can
simply understand it that way moving on
to either the Master's level if the
university brings in a bioinformatics
prer it will be embraced by the students
yeah all right thank you very much for
that perspective um I I I I think due to
our time we might not have um time to
discuss many of these further but I
believe um you know some of the
perspectives um already shared by all
the panelist um you know all along has
um you know go along in um throwing a
lot of light into what we would actually
want to um um expose the participants of
the Symposium to when it comes to
bionformatics needs and training Africa
um there is a need for us to um you know
U Move um hand over to the US team now
to take their sessions but um I would
say in wrapping up that um you know
after this Symposium the we at om logic
Africa um would be reaching out to a
number of um institutions universities
and also welcome collaborators that we
can work together to to achieve the goal
of you know um scaling significantly the
the the training the training aspect
when it it comes to bioinformatics so we
look forward to being able to integrate
or I mean partner with a number of
Institutions universities to um leverage
our resources and tools I think one of
the challenges I mean in addition to
what Dr Anita mentioned should be
infrastructural gaps you know the
infrastructures resources needed to um
you know actually carry out informatics
analysis is um is quite demanding we in
the in Africa where internet is still a
big issue all right so as we move
forward and um you know having access to
good infrastructure that can drive B
informatics I believe we also um help a
lot of people coming into the field and
that is one thing actually we um we are
proud of at mix logic Africa right
because we have E cloud based and
infrastructure that can help
participants to be able to conduct some
of these researches right there you know
in the cloud without um having to bother
about the space or or internet and all
of
that if they were
to so on that note I want to wrap up
this section I want to um thank all our
panelists from
Dr um drer we we appreciate your time
with us this afternoon I also want to
thank Dr V to we are very much you know
I'm glad to to have you and we we thank
you for the perspective shared Mr son
Hamza we also want to thank you um you
know for those um you know um you know
perspective you shared on the discussion
today and um last but not the least um
Dr Anita gansa we want to appreciate you
also for what you um you know what
you've shared and what you are doing you
and your research team okay so thank you
very much for for that and um so without
wasting time actually like I said
earlier on we would want to hand over to
the US team now it will be um my
privilege to actually um hand over to um
IIA you know who will be telling us
about the I mean as we move into the
opening session of the opening ceremony
of this today Symposium so um Elia are
you there
please thank you so much Ed conle oh
great and thank you so much yes thank
you so much the African panelist it was
great to hear you all and uh and listen
to the Ides on the questions that were
discussed so now I would like to welcome
Mr Elia broi one of the co-founder and
CEO of pine biotech to talk about omix
logic and how can we prepare the next
generation of experts that bring deep
insights from biological data using data
science skills and also how can we
advance the experience these students
have placing them at the Forefront of
big data that continues to grow with
increased complexity and scale Mr
Brodsky has facilitated and managed
collaborations with researchers at
Stanford UCSF Louisiana State University
tulani and other academic and Pharm R&D
teams Mr bronsky oversees the research
projects and manages the development of
the Prototype preparation of the
relevant data projects and
implementation of the systems for the
needs of students and teachers that the
project is designed for now I would like
to pass on the stage to Mr Elia over to
you
Elia okay thank you very much Sona and
again thank you for everyone that was
here up until now so we're going to
transition now from the previous uh
presenters we had a great panelists and
speakers from India we had great
panelists and speakers from Africa and
so now we're going to be moving on to
the main part of the Symposium where we
will be talking to a number of experts
uh on the changing role of
bioinformatics in research industry and
education continuing with the theme of
today so uh briefly before we begin that
I wanted to uh thank all of the speakers
and we had uh great experts from um all
of these uh places it was great to hear
some of the insights that everybody
shared um so just kind of some takeaways
uh that I had from this uh we heard
about the pressing need to review
annotate and improve data quality both
the ones that are available and future
data sets that will be shared so I think
Dr ragava really highlighted the
significance of publicly available data
sets and the importance of involving
students and uh other uh kind of
stakeholders in being able to uh
contribute to that process of in
ation um we also heard about
industry-driven education in Indian
Healthcare so we talked about we heard
uh how uh industry has a great demand
for data science skills and skilled
workers in a variety of fields in India
especially this requires a collaboration
and close collaboration uh with um
industry and uh I I think it was really
interesting to hear about all of that uh
we also heard um from the Africa
team about their uh efforts uh to
address the Gap uh especially training
biologists and uh addressing some of the
pressing challenges in the African
continent including infectious diseases
cancer uh chronic and metabolic diseases
so that was really insightful and of
course we also heard from Dr Anita gansa
from uh University of Ghana speaking
about the important work that they are
doing in monitoring the diversity of the
Mia pathogen and how that affects drug
resistance including the upcoming
vaccination effort so um this was really
a Global Perspective I think on the
changing role of bioinformatics but also
on some of the uh upcoming needs in
bioinformatics training and education
and so really thank you all for sharing
all of those insights with us so briefly
I know that many of you here today are
already familiar with what we do but in
short um what we've seen up until now
are some of the people that we partner
with including expert bioinformaticians
and researchers in a variety of domains
that essentially provide us with an
opportunity to take publicly available
data sets and turn them into case
studies to allow students to explore and
understand both the challenges that they
present present and practice the
analysis path to essentially extract
meaningful insights from complex Armic
data and so the projects that we uh see
uh are examples of how anyone can start
applying bioinformatics in oncology in
infectious diseases in neuroscience and
agriculture all very pressing domains uh
not only in the west but also um in a
lot of these uh countries around the
world uh briefly I want to also
introduce that today with us we will
have an opportunity to speak uh and hear
uh from experts um the first group that
I would like to introduce are um the
tber bin formatics Research Center so uh
University of hia is where the talber
bioinformatics research center was
established essentially uh two goals
that I understand that they are pursuing
uh one is to to develop novel algorithms
for multiomics integration and number
two to really make uh bioinformatics
more accessible by making it user user
friendly by making it uh explained and
logical to use and I I think that's a
major Gap in a lot of the educational
especially educational uh activities
around the world is that um a lot of the
focus in bioinformatics education is on
Tech technical skills and unfortunately
technical skills are not the only skills
that are important it we have this kind
of uh multiple challenges emerging in
the field of bioinformatics where
there's a need for translational
research as highlighted by the pandemic
we see kind of the translation of ideas
that have emerged from experimental uh
design uh in cell lines and tissues and
animal models and now reach ing patients
kind of pressing need with patient uh
Health uh we also see the challenge in
data integration because so many omix
data types have emerged and evolved over
the recent years because the data has
become so uh cheap to generate in one
sense and in another sense it can
address so many different aspects of
molecular biology there's definitely a
need for data integration but at the
bottom level right so kind of supporting
the logic of
bioinformatics are asking the right
questions and finding answers using
appropriate methods for data analysis
and so in that domain I think it is very
important and critical uh some of the
work that the towerer bioinformatics
research center is doing and so what
they have designed is a platform called
the T bioinfo platform that combines
multiple types of userfriendly analysis
pipelines to integrate and analyze uh
visualize and interpret some of these
important data sets that are uh
typically used in the domain of
bioinformatics so one of the exciting
things that I'm looking forward to in in
a few minutes after my part of the
presentation is to really hear about
some of the new advances in the
different types of AMX technologies that
also come with the need to develop and
design new algorithms to uh process
and integrate such data and so this
includes a range of new bioinformatic
sections that are either being added or
or planed to be added uh for single cell
data analysis and integration for
analysis and uh modeling of cancer cell
mutations and uh also mathematical
modeling for host pathogen interaction
as well as exciting new applications of
mathematical modeling and simulation for
a variety of challenges in life science
research so what we have done on our
side at the pine biotech side is we have
taken a lot of these sections and tools
and methods that have been made uh in a
uh userfriendly interface and connected
logically and turn them into educational
modules that anyone can learn from both
being exposed to the topic domain to the
significance and the importance of that
domain to the pressing challenges in
that domain and with Associated case
studies and methods of analysis that
could be practiced in a logical way as
well as technical way so one of those
domains that we hear a lot about and we
heard already today is the concept of
personalized medicine so this field has
seen dramatic growth and as a result of
uh different types of molecular data
large scale repositories of patient
records and many new computational
technologies that now allow for fast
processing for easy analysis and
integration and importantly the ability
to ask very specific questions about
patient health and so while there's a
lot of potential in this field there are
also many challenges that we will hear
about today and these include challenges
to integrate multiomic data challenges
and gaps in the ability to um access
different types of data phenotypic data
that is very critical for interpretation
and many different questions about the
statistical significance and
interpretation of found signals that
cannot be exhaustively addressed using
just experimental data and so there is a
need for mathematical modeling and
simulation and so we hope that some of
the modules that we design are going to
be an opportunity for students that see
guidance and ability to enter
into a particular domain like Precision
medicine uh to be able to effectively
use bioinformatics and contribute to
such areas another area that we will
hear about today and we of course have
heard about uh for uh the duration of
the past couple of years is the emerging
awareness of bionformatics in infectious
diseases so uh that is something that
the pandemic has really brought about to
the awareness of the public the the
general public today knows what is a
mutation what is the variant of concern
uh how does the virus evolve uh as we
observe transmission right so a lot of
interesting questions that from being
kind of explored in the lab setting by
only experts now is the in the domain of
the public of the public discussion of
the mass media and so that makes it even
much more critical for anyone to
understand what goes into the data that
is being generated and analyzed and
presented what goes into the actual
interpretation of the signals found in
this data and so I think that this is an
important area for us to continue to
explore and what we have designed around
these uh areas is a whole specialization
track dedicated to infectious diseases
where we talk about the application of
bioinformatics to infectious disease
research and the understanding of host
pathogen interaction uh based on viral
infection bacterial fungi and parasites
and so a lot of the examples that we
have heard about like malaria a lot of
the ones that we will hear about today
like covid-19 and other types of
viruses another interesting domain is I
think many of the people in the kind of
medical uh domain don't really or
biomedical research domain don't
appreciate maybe as much is the area of
omics and agrobiology where there's a
lot of technology that is driving this
concept of precision aggro technology to
address the need of Global Food Supply
the changing climate uh the need for uh
more resistant crops that are um going
to be adapted to new regions and so this
area has been seeing a tremendous
interest as well and so one of the
important challenges for us is to design
modules that could address some of the
pressing challenges and opportunities in
agrobiology so uh we already have some
examples but we will continue to expand
this working with other partners uh to
kind of supplement the materials that we
already have another important area um
that I recently learned about is the
domain of
astrobiology and while astrobiology and
in general omic data and astrobiology
have been around for quite some time uh
the recent advances in space exploration
right the commercially available flights
the hype around uh maybe exploring Mars
and and sending people to Mars or
sending people to space has really I
think uh fascinated a lot of students uh
has really provide an opportunity to
talk about some of the challenges how do
we actually explore space on longer
flights what what is needed and and what
kind of studies are needed today to
understand the dangers and the methods
to kind of overcome some of those
challenges with microgravity with
radiation with all kinds of effects of
space flight that maybe um we need to
think about before we can plan out some
of these longer missions um I think it's
a very interesting domain and so today
we will hear from some of the experts
and some of the people that represent
the student community that are working
together to ask questions and use
publicly available data sets to be able
to um kind of explore this whole
topic now all of these specialization
tracks require some practical and basic
training as well and so one of our
missions as a company is to really
provide an opportunity for anyone coming
from a life science background or coming
from a uh kind of an engineering
technical background to be able to get
involved in such studies and so as a
result we've designed basic modules that
are uh specifically designed design to
introduce uh the domain of
bioinformatics or the integration
between biology and data and we have
modules on genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epig genomics and practical
uh exercises in data science skills and
so I think that what we are trying to
address uh through these modules is to
really uh kind of address the Gap that
we see in this field and one of the
things that we've learned is that
there's a gap
between the ability to generate data and
the ability to analyze and use
information that comes out from that
data and that Gap has multiple different
challenges right that we heard about
today already uh data annotation
availability of data availability of
tools so many different things but the
specific thing that we see that is of
the biggest concern is the ability to
analyze this complex data and so as a
result we are now working with universi
to really address that Gap by providing
uh the missing elements from what we see
as the missing elements in that kind of
a curriculum sorry so those missing
elements include mentorship uh from
experts in the field that are available
uh through um kind of guidance and
oversight of project development uh we
see a gap in infrastructure so that
anyone can analyze larger and more
complex data data sets independently and
of course there's a need to work
together with faculty to align such
training with the needs of different
domains and different types of
departments and so that is really what
we're working on right now and so we
haven't just started now but we've done
several different Pilots to validate
this approach and this technology we've
done a number of pilot programs with the
Louisiana biomedical research network uh
kind of hosted at the Louisiana State
University with worked with uh Geor Town
University where we've uh worked with
the systems medicine
program uh where they kind of talk about
the clinical applications of
bioinformatics and we've worked with
International universities like the am
University in uh India where they have a
number of uh programs and biotechnology
that really need the bioinformatics
training not as a core subject but
really as a subject that could be
implemented as a part of the standard
biotechnology uh training and so in
today's webinar in today's sessions and
tomorrow's sessions we will hear from a
lot of these programs about Lessons
Learned you know how does this work well
uh in in terms of where is this going
where is the need in the future for this
kind of a domain and also how can we
prepare the students not only to know
what they need to know today but also
what kinds of skills they will need in
the next five to 10 years where when
they will become the leaders uh of
bioinformatics and so um we have a lot
of interesting participating
organizations that we will hear from
today that we already heard from some of
them up until now and of course we are
looking forward to today's uh sessions
and also tomorrow to hear about not only
what you can learn from some of the
training that we provide but also to get
a degree um in this area in this field
so to summarize uh onx
logic is a program that is designed to
enable independent research Guided by
mentors and peer example and we are
excited to see that we have over 10,000
students uh learning in different
programs that we have and we expect this
number to continue to grow as the need
for bioinformatics is expanding uh we
see a need to kind of develop this
growing Community by partnering with
other or organizations and with uh kind
of establishing local chapters and so
that's why you heard today from our uh
team in India from our team in Africa
and uh we want to hear from all of you
if you are interested to expand this
network as well and our ultimate goal is
to enable students clinicians and
faculty of all backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research projects
using latest technology in life and data
Sciences so really combining them
together and and uh one of the things
that we will finish off with
today is we will speak about uh some of
the future programs that we are
designing that I think are changing the
nature of
bioinformatics uh as you probably all
know there is kind of this shift in
terminology for example up until now
bioinformatics was seen as this Niche
domain and I think that with the
advances in data science and the need
for for data skills uh in other areas
bioinformatics is now kind of being
rebranded almost as a data science for
biological data and so one of the things
that we are developing is a
comprehensive curriculum designed to
kind of address uh this change as well
where uh we have upcoming programs on
data science in uh for big data and for
uh data skills that includes statistical
analysis and machine learning um kind of
addressing the challenges in
experimental design and te technical
validation uh for data mining and and
finding meaningful patterns and
associations and complex data and to
apply this to systems biology uh studies
so the way that we typically do this um
just uh kind of to tell you about the
format is really pandemic ready right so
one of our goals is to make this as a
bridge between what people can do
asynchronous ly and what happens in a
typical University setting so we can
adapt and kind of integrate modules on
different types of omix data different
types of specialization tracks different
types of levels from very technical to
more conceptual and kind of uh provide
some interactive sessions with
experienced mentors that can guide
students to uh apply these skills in a
meaningful way and I think the biggest
validation uh that we see for this work
is in the completed projects so not only
do we think that the training the
technical skills are needed but
ultimately the proof is when somebody
can apply uh some of the skills that
they have learned to a real interesting
project and so today I am excited to see
that many of the people that have gone
through the training have submitted
their research posters uh at the end of
today's session we will be directing
everybody to take a look at this work
and I don't know if OES or sonara
somebody can also paste the link uh to
uh the posters that we already have uh
so a number of the participants that we
had uh over the summer that we had for
uh the past several months have been
able to uh finish their presentation so
uh just briefly let's take a look at
this
link thank you
jasine um so on this link uh you will
find um the poster competition uh the
poster competition includes uh projects
that have been recorded um as a video
presentation so we will not have an
interactive poster session this poster
session will be uh more of a recorded
presentation we tried to keep uh we
tried asking everybody to keep their
presentations in under 10 minutes uh and
uh they also typically will have a
poster p that you can take a look at now
after you take a look at some of these
posters we try to select the posters
that were kind of ready for review uh
from all the different uh submissions
that we had we had uh too many
submissions to ask uh our judges to
evaluate but down here at the bottom you
will see a link to the form that will
tell you how you can help us evaluate
and select the best posters from this
list
uh this will include some guidelines for
judges so we have a panel of Judges that
will be looking at all these posters uh
over the next two days but also we're
asking participants if you're just
participating in uh this uh session
today or in the next few sessions over
the next couple of days we ask you to
also provide us with feedback that we
will share with some of these
participants so you have to fill out
your name uh here you can select the
participant based on the posters that
you have seen and then in each section
you can give them a score including the
introduction uh methods and results
discussion and conclusion and
presentation quality so we're really
excited to kind of see the outcome of
that and to see how we can uh kind of
highlight some of the best posters and
some of the best teams that have
submitted uh some of these
posters
okay and so now I want to introduce you
uh to some of the speakers and some of
the panelists that we will start with uh
so again for those of you that are just
joining actually let me uh just uh
navigate away from here for those of you
that are just
joining we have here a full schedule
that you can see of all of the sessions
that have been planned so we have up
until now uh we had our teams from India
and Africa presenting uh we are starting
now kind of the ceremony for the US
topics uh and the first thing that we
will start with is a panel discussion
which after that you will hear some of
the panelists talk more in depth about
the topics that we will bring up in the
panel discussion uh but also talk about
their research projects and kind of
telling us a little bit more about some
of the things that we should consider um
as we explore bioinformatics and where
it's going uh so with that uh let us
start with um the
panel in the panel um I am excited to
see uh Dr um Gus
culus uh so uh Dr culus is the president
of the National Association of idea
principal
investigators he received his uh degree
in physics um from The Fairly Dickinson
University uh in New Jersey and his
master's degree and PhD degree from
Pennsylvania State University in
biophysics and molecular cell biology uh
he received post-doctoral training at
the University of Chicago working in
dror Bernard ryman's laboratory at the
University of California at San
Francisco with Dr Lenor Pereira where
later he was promoted to research
assistant professor he joined Louisiana
State University in Baton Rouge
Louisiana in 1988 and became professor
in
1994 he's currently professor of
virology and biotechnology at the LSU
School of veterinary medicine with
adjunct appointments at the department
of biological sciences
biotechnology uh College of basic
Sciences the department of microbiology
and Immunology at the LSU Health
Sciences Center in New Orleans and the
Health Sciences Center Stanley S Scott
Cancer Center in New Orleans he is also
an affiliate member of the tane National
Primate Research Center located in
Covington Louisiana and he's serving as
the head of the Department of
pathobiological Sciences and is the
director of the division of
biotechnology and molecular medicine at
LSU School of veterinary medicine he's
also the principal investigator of the
Louisiana biomedical research Network
funded by NIH nigms and other extramural
and intramural sources so uh Dr culas
welcome hey hello everybody uh glad to
be here uh thank you Elia I guess you're
gonna introduce all other speakers
before we can start the panel right yes
exactly thank you very much our um
second panelist is uh Dr Sona vasudan uh
so uh Dr sonov vasudan is the director
of the systems medicine
uh master's degree at Georgetown
University uh her interest Span in the
areas of structural biology structural
bioinformatics homology modeling protein
Lian and antibody antigen interactions
and RNA biology her research interests
include comparative genomics protein
classification protein homology modeling
and molecular Dynamic simulations to
look at the effect of single nucleotide
polymorphisms in breast cancer as well
as evolution analysis systems biology
and translational informatics she has
contributed to the development of
several well-known bionformatics tools
for doing sequence and structure
analysis she has developed a drug
Discovery database and her research
record includes several research papers
invited lectures and book chapters she
serves on the editorial board of and is
a reviewer for several journals she
teaches biochemistry structural biology
and several courses in informatics and
she has Mentor mentored many students
and created an mdms dual degree program
in systems medicine and a freestanding
Ms degree program in systems medicine
and uh she has received numerous
academic Awards and excellence in
teaching Awards as well so welcome Dr
vasudan thank you IAD it's my pleasure
to be here uh thank you for that
wonderful introduction looking forward
to the
panel okay great thank you very much uh
we also have here Dr Leonid
Brodsky uh who is the outgoing director
of the towerer bioinformatics research
center at the University of hyen Israel
so Dr Leon Brodsky authored a long list
of research Publications and his
background is in biostatistics
mathematics and over the past several
decades he has been working in
bioinformatics uh he has been leading
bioinformatics research computational
biology and systems biology modeling for
over 30 years his work uh is primarily
in bioinformatics algorithm development
for many years and as a result of that
work he has produced a number of new
approaches to biomedical data analysis
and integration uh So currently he is uh
working at the tower bionformatics
Research Center and being the Scientific
Advisor to many uh research projects
with collaborators of that Center as
well so welcome Dr Lena
bratsky thank you very
much and also we have today Dr rul
Andino uh Dr rul
Andino is a professor in the department
of microbiology and Immunology at the
University of California San Francisco
Dr Andino is a biologist and professor
in the department of microbiology and
Immunology at the University of
California San Francisco he is noted for
leading a team of researchers that
developed the first new oral polio
vaccine in 50 years he has been working
in biology for over 30 years and has a
broad background in RNA virus biology
with focus on molecular biology and
biochemistry viral Immunology vaccine
development and evolutionary Biology RNA
viruses are a major threat to human
health and they also provide a
fascinating window into processes that
can be harnessed to improve human life
so welcome Dr
andina thank you pleasure to be here
okay great to have you and finally we
have Dr Laura Harris so Dr Laura Harris
is a research mentor and director of
training at Michigan State University uh
Dr Harris is an educator who enjoys
developing curriculum that involves uh
involves use of computational resources
she also enjoys mentoring others in data
science and biom medical research her
projects use bioinformatics and basic
laboratory approaches to examine gen
expression changes associated with
antibiotic resistance in bacterial
species microbial induced cancer and
SARS Cove 2 Dr Harris is involved with
the American Society for microbiology
and has co-authored several educational
and scientific papers welcome Dr
Harris thank you pleasure to be here
this
morning all right great so after all of
these introductions again thank you
everyone for being here essentially what
we've done is we've compiled several
questions from all of the participants
of the Symposium that we hope that you
can help us address and so what I wanted
to start is what are some of the
changing Dynamics around omix data so
essentially what do you see from your
perspective how is this uh field of omix
data changing in terms of data
availability data quality uh data access
and I wanted to first ask uh Dr Andino
if you could um kind of uh share with us
your thoughts on that subject
yeah I mean thanks IIA I I think that um
there's obviously a very important um
important exercise that we need to do in
terms of integrating um the intuition
that many of us have in biology with the
intuition that many computational
scientists have and so um the first
thing that you really need to think
about is is how to integrate that kind
of perspective and intuition that only
comes um when a scientist is involved in
this type of work for for for years so
you know transmitting that kind of
intuition is is is critical because um
it it it really um allows you to define
the questions and of course then Define
the technical approach to uh access to
to um the
information and as you know IIA because
we've been working for many years uh
together one of the things is
fascinating to me is that every
biological uh process from an enzyme
recognizing the substrate all the way to
epidemiological process um they are
dictated by um the Dynamics of the
process um I always put this example
that if you see a picture picture of a
cat in the air you really don't know
whether the cut is falling or jumping um
and you really need a movie um you know
a series of pictures that capture the
Dynamics and then you will know the cut
is uh jumping from one place to the
other and so that the same thing
happened with with um biology and I
think the the whole thing jumps to I
mean boils to a simple matter of good
data uh perhaps tempor with certain
temporary resolution that allows to
train models um that will enable
understanding those Dynamics the higher
resolution the data is the better the
models will be but I think the models
play in very important role in defining
uh the type of experiments that one can
do if one has the opportunity to um
obtain uh data that will be more um
useful to fit this U models then um you
will be able to have this sort of
iterative uh process in which the models
gets um better defined based on the data
and the data gets better defined based
on the
models thank you thank you very much for
that um good illustration with the cab
so I really like that you really don't
know where what's going on unless you
see the
full um so so with that being said uh my
next question would be about what is
really the need for multiomic
integration with you know genomic
transcriptomic different types of omic
data um you know what is the need to be
able to integrate them and and what are
some of the ways that it could be done
and so I wanted to ask that question
from Dr Leon Brodsky if you can kind of
expand on
that yes thank you um okay uh uh first I
believe uh that um actually we have uh
some difficulties with uh many
Technologies in multiomic data and uh
the question of integration is how to
combine all these Technologies which G
gave actually are giving different
results and after that how to move from
all of that to biology second I
completely agree with rul that uh time
Dimension is in integration is extremely
important because actually it is saying
what kind of uh biology we virtually can
expect from our experiment like like uh
cell differentiation
or processes with organism like aging
and things like that and of course uh
development of virus infection so uh two
major issues I believe different how to
combine different Technologies and how
to stream all of that to time
Dimension okay great thank you very much
so you know multiomics integration I
know that you've been working on that
for a long time but essentially as also
rul mentioned this uh kind of discussion
with biologists maybe is really critical
and um I also wanted to ask about the
ways that omix data is essentially
changing research projects I we already
kind of heard about basic research but
in terms of translational research I
know that Dr vasudan you work with a lot
of clinicians you're in the medical
school you kind of prepare students for
systems medicine uh what is your take on
how omix data and and some of the things
that were mentioned by Dr Andino and Dr
bronsky how how is that changing uh
those research projects that you see
happening around you yeah thank you IIA
for that question I was hoping you would
ask me that question um and thanks to uh
Dr Andino and Dr Bry who already laid a
amazing foundation in terms of where we
are in terms of starting any research
projects so the way I look at things uh
and the changing phase of informatics is
that it's become a very
interdisciplinary field uh so we cannot
uh just each I am a physicist by
training converted myself to a biologist
and an
informatician uh but with so much of
data coming from all over the place
transcriptomics proteomics pretty much I
think there are like 238 or 40 different
omic terms and so much data out there uh
the biggest change um in designing a
research project is to have a
interdisciplinary team uh so we need a
clinician uh we need a biologist uh in
fact we even need an economist now uh to
see um the different ways to do things
so the way uh even when I teach medical
students uh so we talk about one disease
one gene so that's no longer in play
right now
uh because it's like a whole systems
approach uh different genes expressing
different organ systems different cell
types uh different things so it's a
whole systems approach so what is really
changing with all of this is of course
multiomic integration is crucial uh and
the most important is also
interdisciplinary collaborations with
different um expertise that is involved
and that's what I teach the students and
we have a team now uh with different
expertise and and I'll be talking more
about the program at Georg tomorrow but
um that's pretty much how uh we have
designed so that there is a lot of
collaboration across different uh
fields and that makes um multiomic
integration more efficient as
well okay great thank you very much for
that Insight Dr vasudan and uh you know
another thing that I know that is a
challenge in some ways with this kind of
dynamics of omx data is essentially how
is it practically used so I know that
there are hubs where you know omx data
is available and everybody seems to know
how to use it and then there are places
where there's a need for uh training
there's a need for Access and there's a
a need for kind of elevating the level
of biomedical research and I know that
Dr culas you're involved with Louisiana
biomedical research network with uh the
National Association of idea principal
investigators and so I wanted to ask you
a question about how important is
bioinformatics um in many of the
research projects that you are involved
in as I'm sure a mentor and a reviewer
um for many of these networks and and
how do you see the trajectory of kind of
data science and bioinformatics as a
critical need um in in many of the
projects that you
oversee uh yeah thanks Elia um uh Eliah
mentioned nepi the National Association
of idea principal investigators just to
give you a uh a very brief um
description this is a nonprofit 503c
corporation that represents uh 23 States
and Puerto Rico uh the program is funded
through NIH with uh over $400 million
per year in multiple centers centers for
biomedical resarch Excellence that
relates to promoting people into indep
dependent funding through the R1
mechanism uh every state has the uh
imbre programs the national uh idea um
paramedical research Excellence programs
uh to promote um paramedical research
and those in programs every state have a
priority for data science and bi
informatics and of course we have
entrepreneurship hubs and the clinical
translational centers uh that these are
the four programs that are part of nepi
over 170 programs and principal
investigators that are members of nepi
representing those 23 States in Puerto
Rico and as already alluded to uh ni8
has recognized the importance of data
science and bi informatics in fact there
is a complete division of data science
and uh the uh teaching and training and
providing support for data science by
and biomatics is now mandatory for all
the programs for those 24 States and of
course it's extremely used uh into the
clinical translational centers that are
funded by n GMS as well by other
categorical institutes and the Kobe
programs the center for biomedical
reseearch
Excellence uh the NIH recognition of
this importance is really multilevel
because now they have arranged with uh
Microsoft and Amazon and others to
really
utilize um their resources um to be able
to really do high level computation in
the cloud as opposed to locally and of
course there are um many many databases
that are Now supported by ni for
clinical translational research um the
the goal of nepi as well all the IM
other programs uh really to reach out
and
prepare uh faculty staff and students in
dealing with bioinformatics and of
course as I was alluded a couple of our
speakers I'm also a physicist that
turned into molecular biologist and my
view of the world is that really
everything that we look at in biology
which often is descriptive ultimately
has a physical explanation to it and a
defined parameter to it every process
that we do whether is receptor binding
or anything internal to the cell it's
actually described can be described by
some physical formula and ultimately uh
this physical world uh really translates
into tremendous amount of information
that cannot really be handled uh through
a
descriptive uh way of understanding what
what's happening uh within uh that cell
tissue or organism or even in population
uh as we do that and that's where we
need the computational tools and the
approach that we use is really not only
to have um uh inter discipline teams
which obviously at the level of higher
education is a is a solution but even
more importantly to really teach uh
young uh students undergraduates
graduates uh the basic tools of data
science and bioinformatics through
intensive exercise programs because I
think ultimately we need
interdisciplinary
education at all levels um because uh
the new
generations need to be trained uh to
understand and utilize these tools and
the quicker and earlier will reach out
to them the more important uh will be
for them as they pursue biomedical
research um and of course this is
extremely needed uh I think 90% or more
of every research Grant I reviewed uh
not only within the lbrm program but the
national programs which cancer research
or um infectious diseases now use
Advanced transomics RNA proteomics
integration of transcriptomics biomics
and genomics so it's a must tool now
it's a necessary tool to be able to
compete uh at a higher
level okay thank you very much Dr culas
and um my my next question is uh to Dr
Harris who I know is somewhat of a
recent convert to the domain of
bioinformatics and also comes from a
biology background and now deals with a
lot of student projects as a mentor and
uh you know runs a whole program and so
I wanted to ask Dr Harris what are some
of the ways that uh researchers and
students can prepare to deal with this
increasing volume and complexity of omx
data in research you know how did you
yourself come to uh the need for
bioinformatics and and how are you using
it
now great question um I came to need
bioinformatics mainly because I ran out
of options in a wetbench setting so wet
bench tends to be very expensive it can
be very timec consuming and it generates
a limited amount of data for usually the
that you're putting into an experiment
by using things like computational
metaanalysis approach you can then take
different experiments across different
labs and then synthesize new information
that may be missed if you're just
looking at a couple of samples or a
couple of mice in your own lab um but
that can be very overwhelming and it was
overwhelming for me when you see how big
some of these data sets can be when you
start aggregating them across different
platforms or uh knowledge bases so my
advice to new students is really be
organized and I have come to find myself
falling back on the traditional lab
notebook uh that I was trained with in
the wet bench so you know we're trained
we have a lab notebook we go into the
lab we document everything that is done
that day procedure results Corrections
thoughts on tweaking the procedure that
sort of thing the same thing applies to
bioinformatics so you have to treat it
just like you would a wet bench research
project you need to have a notebook that
says you know I tried this approach it
worked it didn't work why do I think it
didn't work what am I going to change
next time because when you start
layering all these different omix or for
me multi omix on
multi-projects it can be very confusing
and overwhelming and even intimidating
to see just the amount of data and
having that that that notebook to kind
of help you break down okay here's where
that project is here's what we did
here's why something needs to be tweaked
the way it is is helpful for my sanity
helpful for my student sanity and it's
also nice to then have a Global
Perspective across projects so if one
project encounters a problem and I
forget about it but then three weeks
later another project comes into a
similar problem I can then go back
through the notebook and say oh wait a
second yeah remember how we fix that
here now why don't we try it on this new
project and hopefully you get
lucky great thank you yes so I think
that is very useful to kind of keep
track of everything and uh you know that
that brings me uh to my next question
and this is um a question that I wanted
to start with Dr
Andino you know you've been doing
biology for you know 30 years as I've
read you know in your background it
wasn't around maybe back when you
started but uh how has the you know
types of data and the ways that this
data is being used uh you know how has
it changed in recent years for you for
the types of research that you and your
lab
do uh you're on
mute yes it's obvious that um
the process the data that we use in a
little bit what Dr Harris was saying um
you know it used to be that uh you will
run an experiment and you will have a
very a
specific um answer to a particular
process that is well defined within your
experimental
Paradigm and and this has changed
enormously because now you are uh able
to use um a lot more data points and lot
more information from the same
welldefined experimental Paradigm and
and the question is how do you interpret
that and you know we've been discussing
about this you know this ability to you
know use this data to you know try to
exract more information to this
particular um experiment but I think
what really is transformative is what um
Dr Basu
was saying at the beginning um what we
doing now is uh and we do we see this
very clearly on this process what we are
in the middle of this pandemic is that
many of the things that we need to do
now require the integration of different
experts and I just wanted to say that
the omx um this is actually an
interesting um in process because
science is a human activity and one of
the things that we encountered recently
is that the most important thing you can
do is to form a team that uh can create
its own culture so it can um sort of in
um interact in a effective way if you
need the exper of a clinician um
biologist uh computer scientist uh you
know epidemiologist and Economist then
you really need to have a Common
Language um and so in in my mind one of
the things that um is is changing now is
that uh we starting to you know generate
some sort of culture of discussion and
this um Symposium which I very excited
to participate precisely because you are
bringing young people that
recognize um the importance of this kind
of omx and
integration um but is the in my mind is
what going to be the future scientist
the scientist of the future is where you
you know really create you you create a
person that or a scientist that is not
afraid to reach out
collaborate um and um use all the
information and intuition that experts
have you develop over over years and I'm
not sure if I address the question but
to me is one of those uh you know really
important things that happened to us in
in in recent
years so thank you yeah maybe not a
direct answer to the question but a very
meaningful kind of addition I think to
uh the need uh for interaction for the
need of uh common kind of understanding
and that ability to listen to the
different sides of the story to really
uh come up with results so I think that
was very useful so thank you uh for that
um my next question is uh you know about
the necessary skills that you look for
when you are looking to add a
bioinformatician to join a project and
so I know that uh you know in many areas
bioinformatics is such a kind of a
diverse term it could mean something
very simple could mean organizing a
database it could mean uh processing
some data or maybe developing a
completely new approach and an algorithm
so it means very different things in in
different uh kind of fields so I do want
to have all of you uh you know kind of
add to uh the answers but my first
question is to Dr Bry you know you lead
a bioinformatics research center you
develop novel algorithms and you kind of
identify solutions to problems that you
see biologist struggle with what are
some of the necessary skills that are
most important in your opinion for new
bioinformaticians or new people joining
your lab or your
Center yes um okay uh actually one
cannot expect all kind of expertise from
a person so it's better to have several
people with different uh Majors so to
say so I am expecting uh good
programming skills and maybe high level
of programming uh and algorithm
development from some from one type of
people another type of people are
expertise uh which have expertise in
mathematics and statistics this is not
always
um the same the same person is a good
Pro programmer and a good
mathematician and actually some basic
knowledge of biology because in biology
we rely on our collaborators not not on
ourselves and so all together and the
good contact with with
collaborator
uh
actually this is what is needed for for
the team to to move forward as I believe
so thank you yes for that answer um so I
think kind of similar to what uh Dr
andin also mentioned is that need to
combine people from different
backgrounds and different skill sets and
enable them to work together and so in
the same uh Direction I also wanted to
ask Dr culas uh you know you uh try to
work with these different programs to
not only train and build up their
capacity but eventually also to uh kind
of solve bioinformatics challenges in a
in a research project so what are some
of the things that you look for uh when
you're hiring U you know a Bion for
aition or when you're looking to include
a Bion for aition in in the research
work that you
do yeah that's a very relevant question
Eli thank you um obviously uh you know
if you're within uh certain institutions
you may not have the capacity to build a
team of three or four or more bform
matician that represent different
aspects that are needed for
collaboration purposes so the way we um
recommend and we are using this is
really get only few people involved as
le as on to um uh resources and talent
uh on the outside so we look to hire a
bior matician that has uh obviously
Computing strengths some statistics
understands uh pipelines um we're using
a lot through our Illumina based core
biomatics for infectious diseases RNA
seek is the principal Tool uh we're not
going into metabolomics and proteomics
um data and the idea is to really have
one or two people we do have a PhD for
instance in B statistics we will be
hiring a b acian we had one we lost them
to the University of Wisconsin um but
the idea really Le on with resources and
collaborators on the outside so we have
anou with the Tober B informatics Center
in Israel with Dr Brodsky for potential
collaborative projects and of course we
we work with pine B Tech to utilize the
training uh tools and pipelines uh so um
our accommodation is really for uh high
and core facilities like ours uh that
supported a number of in8 uh projects um
to have um two or three people
internally that are broadly educated and
then link up to exteral resources
including really commercial resources
that are available um you know for a
FIFA service to provide support for that
but even beyond that I think it's
extremely important what I mentioned
earlier uh we like to push the ability
to handle data uh to the lowest possible
level so intensive training of graduate
students um you know undergraduate
students that are in computer science
that want to learn biology biologists
that want to learn data science by
informatics um part of the idea is not
to get only the pi to collaborate but
have the actual laboratory with the
people on the bench be able to use uh B
informatics tools leaz own with a more
expert person and then utilize the
external resources whether commercial
collaborative or NIH resources that
could be doing this because it would be
very difficult for us to hire a big team
of people to handle some of our
projects all right yes great thank you
very much Dr culus and uh Sona I I know
that uh you as a researcher and uh
especially as a director of a program I
know that students come to your program
from all over the world uh with all
kinds of different intentions uh and you
know your goal in just a short time to
train them for what will be expected so
I know that you're probably feeling out
there in the industry and the research
you know what are the skills that people
are looking for in a bioinformatician or
somebody that does systems medicine uh
what do you think are some of the
necessary skills that you're looking for
them to acquire and and be graduated
with to make them ready for that next
position uh thank you IIA I've actually
must confess that I've lost sleep over
this um just because it's not it's not
practical and it's not easy to uh create
a bioinformatician ideal bation who has
uh lab skill sets um statistical skill
sets and understanding data and at the
end of the day we are all trying to
solve problems which are biological in
nature um and so it's a very challenging
things and I do get students with
different backgrounds I have students
who have psychology backgrounds I in
fact had a student who had a history
background so it's a very challenging
thing but in the least what I try to do
is give them some basic foundation of
the biology and the questions that we're
trying to address um and then give them
a broad skill sets of a little bit of
Statistics um and a little bit of
programming skill sets but unfortunately
not everyone has the ammen or you know
the mindset um to grasp everything uh
but the program uh what I try to do is
just to expose them to different aspects
of informatics out there um so they
don't come out as um hardcore software
Engineers but at the same time they have
basic Foundation that they can build on
uh to develop their software skill sets
if that's what they want to pursue um or
if the students want to go and work in
the bench to you know bide then they do
have exposure to um understand how to
extract RNA and how do you prepare the
samples to send for sequencing and do a
seek analysis um and they do have an
overall um all of them actually walk out
with um with the um you know aspect that
we are all drowned in data so how do you
look at data so statistics is a big part
of it um and so they do learn they do
learn statistics um so students after
they graduate with uh skill sets in
different areas then they decide where
they want to develop more um and so you
know some of them you know take courses
and electives to uh make some of the
foundations more strong uh based on
their interest but one thing that is um
important in the program is that uh they
all do research so Capstone project is
an um you know is mandatory for them so
that's where they kind of tie in
together and become experts in one small
thing some of them are interested in
programming so we find mentors who um
you know engage them in learning
programming and some of them want to do
bench work so uh so it's all over the
place but at the end of the day they
develop little bit of wine tasting
aspects of different things uh and they
then they go ahead and develop whatever
skills that they need um of course long
story short I think I would if I were to
hire someone um of course I don't have
um you know humongous amount of money to
hire a statistician a biologist and all
of those things so uh with limited
funding we just have to pick a student
who has little bit of uh understanding
of programming and biology for sure and
then who Embraces um the use of software
tools resources um and uh you know
understands how to put together data in
the context of
biology all right great thank you for
that perspective too and um Dr Harris uh
you know the same question I wanted to
kind of rephrase for what I know about
what you do I know that many times you
deal with students that have maybe very
limited background in bioinformatics and
nevertheless you're able to integrate
them in some of the excellent projects
that you do uh providing them with a
meaningful experience and I know that
you also put out a number of uh
resources out there that you know are
facilitating that process of getting uh
people interested and so um I wonder
what is your take on you know how to
essentially get started for somebody
that wants to get involved in a
meaningful research involving
bioinformatics and how does that
experience prepare them for what real
bioinformatics needs out there uh
exist yeah I was wondering if I was
going to get a question variation simply
because my answer to the first question
would be radically different than the
other panelists um I'm one because as
you said I I don't get a lot of students
that have expertise I've never hired an
intern I've never hired a grad uate
student um for research that is I hired
them as teaching assistants and other
things like that but um for me
personally it's more about the personal
characteristics of the student are they
curious are they curious enough to go
find an answer rather than wait for me
to give it to them even if they don't
know where to look at least trying gets
you
somewhere or if they do run into a
problem are they going to shut down down
and not ask questions or are they going
to come forward immediately and start
asking questions of their fellow
researchers of me of whatever people
they run into at conferences or what
have you so a lot of those
characteristics are more along the lines
of what I look for rather than I'm
looking for someone in stats or I'm
looking for someone in comp or I'm
looking for someone in BIO because for
the students I get which can be anywhere
from basic high school all the way
through graduate level they don't
necessarily know what they want they
don't know what they're interested in
they don't know where their anxieties
are and so coming into my research lab
or my trainings frequently that's an
experience they're learning about
themselves and so I get to discover that
alongside them sometimes they get into a
bioinformatics project and they find you
know what the computer really isn't as
exciting as I thought it would be or the
lab is not as exciting as I thought it
would be um and so things like you know
flexibility uh perseverance attention to
detail cannot stress that enough um are
all very important things that I look
for rather than looking for a skill set
I can train a skill set I can train a
biologist I can train a computational
scientist but I can't train curiosity I
can't train attention to detail and
that's really where I need the students
to step up and bring those uh
characteristics to the to the
plate okay perfect so uh thank you again
H Dr Harris for your perspective and for
everybody that shared um all of this uh
wonderful information I do want to
mention that we have a link and maybe or
Sonica you can paste that link where we
have profiles of all of the panelists
and speakers uh where you can find links
to their websites to their programs you
can learn about their background and you
can uh obviously uh you know connect
with them if you would like to or they
would like to accept that request but I
hope that you know this not only
provides us with some perspectives but
also leads to other outcomes now I want
to briefly introduce another person that
wants to uh that can add an important
perspective to this
um so uh Gio or Jano Chavez uh he is a
mentor um at the summer um internship
program uh run by us UCSD but also um is
starting to Mentor some of the students
that come to our research fellowship
program and I wanted uh Gio to ask you
if you could add a little bit of your
perspective on how at the very early
stages you know how do you help students
uh you know essentially get interested
uh and do something meaningful um with
uh data uh and I know that you lead some
projects on your own but also you uh
kind of became converted to the field of
bi informatics not so long ago so maybe
you could uh give us a little
perspective from your side what what do
you think about
this yeah I was particularly interested
when Dr Laura Harris mentioned that uh
about the Curiosity of students is is
the person curious are they curious
about diseases or what what the
phenomenons that have led to a disease
in their family for instance so uh a lot
of countries have problems in allowing
access to science resources uh for
instance I come from Brazil I come from
public schools in Brazil and
uh you know uh there are lots of
limitations in the country
there uh so I came as part of an effort
that the government of the of Brazil is
is doing right now or has been doing in
the past decade or
so uh to launch science or to try to
cultivate a culture of Science in the
country so we have collaboration we have
I have been as Asia mentioned I have
been serving as a mentor for a program
called science internship program at the
University of California Santa Cruz and
the uh mission of that program is to
really
bring
uh mainly high school students but uh as
I turn it to realize it's uh expanding
from the only the uh scope of high
school students to become uh to to be in
contact with Scientists with mentors so
what sip the science internship program
does is it brings uh high school
students to follow to Shadow PhD
students uh I think that I think there
might be Master's students that uh also
serve as mentors of Sip and that really
uh makes the student think I really want
to pursue a career in science or I
definitely do not want to pursue a
career in science in science because
that's also uh important to uh have that
decision and having the resources to uh
decide on whether or not pursuing a
career in science so I think it's really
important uh to as early as possible
start to educate uh kids and young
scientists um young scientists may be
not a very good term to a good way to
put it uh because uh we just want to
make sure and guarantee that uh kids
have a chance to understand what science
is and have a feeling of what working in
a s in a in a science lab in a research
institution what it looks like and I
think it's really important uh that in
in countries that do not have a an
economic situation like the United
States or or the the so-called first
world economies uh I I think it's really
important to allow these other countries
these other regions these other
communities to build this type of uh
this type of experience for their uh for
their youth for the their young
Generations thank you Gio um so uh in
summary um I just wanted to ask uh all
of you uh all of the panelists
um to maybe if you want to add anything
to what we discussed in this panel we do
have a few questions from the audience
that I will read out in just a couple of
minutes but uh before we do that I
wanted to give you an opportunity to
just maybe say a couple more things uh
from your perspective again the the
topic of the panel is the changing uh
kind of need uh of bioinformatics uh and
the changing uh kind of Technologies in
this field we will continue to hear
about it in more indepth talks in just a
few minutes um but uh please does
anybody want to um anybody from the
panel want to add something to this
topic from what we discussed so far um
Dr Andino would you like to add anything
to
this this this been a you know
tremendous uh exciting discussion I
think we all in the panel recognize the
importance of um bringing the not like
gios saying young people everybody I
would say
newcomers to this activities I think
that uh would be uh incredibly important
if you know really this Symposium brings
uh people together to uh realize um the
power and also the challenges and this
exercise I mean I guess the only thing
that I I wanted to to say is um you know
just emphasize that um really is is a is
a human activity is bringing together
biostatisticians with um you know
empirical scientists if you will um
together to the discussions um the
Curiosity point is very well taken I
think it you know we all need to um
emphasize that you know that is
something that is essential uh to the uh
to the process um and I I I like this
idea that you create this circle
interative circle uh between you know
data analyst and experimentalist because
you know if you think about it you can
you can have a big data set and discover
something that
is um inspiring in terms of creating a
new model A New Perspective of how you
see something but you at some point you
need to validate that uh observation
ation and how do you confirm that
observation is real well you need an
experiment so I I think again this is a
team effort and and is um you know and I
my personal experience uh working with
Leon uh Broski and Ilia Broski and this
all this last 10 years or so that we've
been working together has been that I
learned a
lot um myself educate Myself by this
interaction and I think it that's very
exciting from my perspective the
possibility of continue learning um and
not being so young but a
newcomer right thank you Dr andina
that's a great perspective there and Dr
L Bry would you like to add
anything okay um B informatics is is
becoming very complex actually the
entire
science from mathematics to quantum
computers uh is involved in
bioinformatics and also bi biology
itself is is is developing very fast so
a lot of challenges and actually all
challenges should be covered by
education and uh actually the education
has to be a little bit uh
in front of challenges say and uh I I
believe that education is very
substantial part of bioinformatics in
general and by not only bioinformatics
but this this uh joint venture of
bioinformatics and
biology because without biology by
informatics is
nothing great thank you uh thank you for
that perspective and uh Dr culas would
you like to add any final words to this
discussion yeah uh obviously uh I think
we're all in agreement of the importance
of these fields and the challenges that
we face but um you know in a simple way
um you know Advanced Data science by
informatics really can find a nle in a
Hy stack but uh the way the indicated
ultimately you have to really look
whether that needle is actually doing
something so it's a unification of
really the data science platics and
ultimately experimentation that will
give you uh you know the the answers uh
to what you may need so we need both and
I can tell you because I've served as a
social president for Louisiana State
University for almost seven years and I
ended up reviewing a lot of engineering
and physics projects Astro physics fluid
dynamics mechanical engineering and I
tell you there's a lot of solutions
developed by other fields that have not
yet really fully applied in biology so I
think this merging of disciplines uh is
required and we need to educate the new
generation students uh most medical
schools and most Veterinary Schools uh
have practically very little of
Education towards this you know MDS and
dbms for genetics genomics and the the
use of this tools so we need a a
transformative steps in uh higher
education uh to be able to really um
train the new uh scientists that will be
able to use these tools uh because these
tools cannot be only at the hands of
experts extreme need that Dr Brodsky
mentioned to really educate
people all right great thank you very
much Dr vovan any final
words um yes I agree with all the
panelists and I think education is the
most important thing it's not just
educating um students but also
educating uh faculty who are in
different fields and who are still
scared to come and use data and
understand so I feel like the educate
the education should spread to a lot of
Faculty as well uh in an institution in
addition to students uh because I have
several faculty on my own um you know my
own colleagues um who who are either
scared or who don't are skeptical just
because there's no knowledge of how to
use data they all have lots of data and
now um I think everyone will agree that
this is a new language and I think this
language has to be learned by everyone
and um and I think as as Dr celis just
said we need transformative educational
programs and I think IIA Pine biotch is
actually leading in that um I really
like how we putting together and I also
agree with Dr Chavis that education
should start at the high school level um
sometimes what I teach my graduate
students I do teach high school students
I Mentor High School students and it's
amazing to find that sometimes they're
smarter uh come up with better ideas
than graduate students um so I think
that there is lots of thirst right there
and all the school systems have to
integrate informatics uh starting from
high school undergraduate Medical School
of course I'm trying my best at judg
toown as well so um I think this is a
very important uh language that everyone
should learn at whatever career paths
that they actually take things have
changed excellent thank you Dr Harris
what would you like to
add well I Echo what the other panelists
have said um about how the students uh
The Graduate students the postdocs and
even the faculty need to be trained in
interdisciplinary research and that is a
challenge particularly for us old farts
who are stuck at our ways uh with that
said it is h a challenge for students
coming up because it seems like they
need or feel the need to pick a topic
and I really just want to encourage
people to follow their interests follow
their curiosity follow what drives them
because you never know where that's
going to lead you and one day that could
be something that's specifically Biology
another day that could be something
that's more computational and then a
year later you begin to realize how they
integrate together so just don't let
yourself limit your potential and uh
just keep your head up and moving
forward in as fast of a positive
direction as you
can excellent thank you Dr Harris indeed
very inspirational to continue and uh
finally uh Gio Dr Chavis would you like
to just add a couple more words to this
just from your perspective one sec let
me unmute
you there we
go yeah uh I agree that uh science is an
activity is a human activity that we as
humans we should all be engaged in I
just I just think that um the it's a
personal uh not a personal it's it's an
effort I guess that all of the countries
and all of the societies need to do uh
in engaging their uh their populations
in this activity that can uh bring
benefits for the for the Societies in
general all right great thank you uh Gio
and thank you all the panelists I want
to mention again to everyone that we
have profiles of all of the speakers uh
right here you can find all of the
speakers and panelists with their
background um you will find if you click
on these images you will actually get
links and we will hear from them in
today's sessions and tomorrow some of
them like Dr vasudan has a whole program
that she will speak about we'll hear
about some research uh topics today from
Dr Andino and Dr bratsky Dr culus will
speak about the National Association of
idea principal investigators tomorrow uh
and uh I'm sure that you can uh also
interact with the people mentioned here
just by following those links you'll
find all of the details um so to
introduce our next speakers and again I
don't think we have enough time uh to go
through all the questions we do have you
know like tens of questions here from
the participants but we will be sure to
share those with all the panelists if
they would like to address those we will
cover them in the next um uh speaker
session that we have uh but now I would
like to introduce uh the next speaker um
Dr lenid Bry as already mentioned is the
uh director of the tower bionformatics
Research Center at University of hia um
his background is mathematics and bio
statistics but uh today he is going to
work he's going to share with us about
mathematical modeling of single stranded
RNA viruses the role of naturally
occurring defective virus genomes uh as
well as um other topics as well so Dr
Brodsky I will pass this on to
you
uh okay uh can you hear me yes we can
hear you the screen yeah uh okay uh
actually I have two topics the first one
is virology actually we did it together
with professor andina
and um uh so this is um ordinary
differential equation modeling of uh of
an interplay between some FL virus
with uh defective genomes defective
viral genomes of this virus which appear
naturally uh okay so the defective
genome here the Genome of this virus FL
virus in general uh the the majority of
defective genomes actually eliminate
this portion so uh structural proteins
and ns1 which is very important because
this is it works in TR and participate
in
replication uh uh this is just a story
about modeling like an example of
modeling so uh
the
uh um okay uh we started with two models
one model is simplified we call OD one
uh where we consider it uh just uh
generation of virus particle by C after
infection and uh the
story when the the uninfected cells are
infected by by virus particles and so on
so actually the production of virus
particle here is constant it it it not
depends on intracell story intracell
processes another model which we called
od5 uh takes into consideration this
intracellular
story and uh it generates a lot of
difference uh okay this is just uh
differential equations we you can see
that there are two models they have
shared portion uh related to cells and
individual portions generation of
particles and intracellular story here
and generation of particles will which
depends on in uh
intracellular uh story inside inside
cells so uh virus replication and uh
both V type and defective
particles
genomes okay what kind of data we have
uh in order to to fit model to the data
uh we had uh okay this uh the experiment
was done in two cell cultures uh verw
and mosquito cell cultures uh
differently uh in 12
passages and the data which we have at
the end to feed the model are virus
Tighter and
uh Next Generation sequencing data which
also was used here in order to
to feed the
model okay as to od5 model uh uh you can
see that uh
virus particles majority is wild type
are perfectly good uh fit to data here
for ver cell culture and in
um in mosquito cell culture and
uh as to Next Generation sequencing data
actually what we did is uh what is
called fil Dynamics means that we
created uh Hypes
uh so to say consensus of of clusters uh
of of genomes which appear in uh which
were assembled from from the data and
uh the the request was to to fit
coalescent based
phogy with the modeling with with with
all these processes of of creating
genomes and eliminating
genomes uh in order to get uh good
correspondence of coalescent processes
Coles philogyny and
uh tuned to to to the
model so uh basically parameters of the
model were tuned with this this type of
data virus Tighter and with this type of
data
together uh the first interesting
question is
uh both models are good for this or not
uh it appears that model the simplified
model OD the one is not good why first
uh
some important rate
sell uh uh
cell
birth uh
cell multiplication of cells
parameter was
unrealistic in od5 after tuning to the
data the model demonstrated realistics
value for this
par and uh here we can see that uh
actually completely unrealistic this
model in order to be fitted to the data
fitted to to to this type of data
uh uh was gave a huge amount of un un
uninfected cells as a
result very different from od5 model
which behavior is very good I mean that
just cells are
dying not nothing specific is happening
this with with multiplication of
cells okay so
uh obviously it is very important to
have this to to have a model of this
intell processes in order to get
reasonable
result
uh now the question is what is the
difference between this inter play of
wild type viruses and uh
defective Z defective
genomes uh what's the difference between
two cell
cultures with the sensitivity uh type of
analysis we detected
key uh key rates so to say this is
replication rates of both wild type
effective
particles uh defect
genomes uh rate of of protein
production and uh rate of production of
virus
particles so uh based on analysis of all
12 actually 11 uh 11
uh
uh 11 passages uh we found that
typically uh values of these parameters
are higher in mosquito and mosquito is
is this FL virus is is um actually is
developed mosquito and um uh cell
cell U mamalian cells are not natural
natural host for
them uh second
uh we try to answer the major question
the major question is uh what's the role
of defective particles in all of them
uh what they are doing can we say that
defective particles are therapeutic it
means that they're saving uninfected
cells or uh this is not not not related
not related to any um attenuation so to
say of of viral
infection okay here what was done is uh
a actually a jump from modeling to
biology the sort
of
uh we took uh based exclusively on on
this
model uh first we took uh uh we
performed uh variations of our
parameters of parameters of our model
and for each combination of parameters
so parameters are up and down
20%
uh we got some solution and this
solution looks like that this is time
behavior for for here for for instance
is uh for um infected
cells uh uh and this this solution like
that is
for
genomes defective genomes in in the in
cells infected by defected particles and
this solution is for
proteins so uh first uh based on these
observations uh of modeling observation
so to say so the values of these curves
we can create a relationship between
solution and the different different
combination of parameters and this
relationship based on conditional
entropy uh could be presented on the SVD
plane like uh PCA plane and uh we can
see that these points
are solution under different combination
of parameters
uh what is interesting we have some
basic
solution uh this basic solution when
parameters are most fitted the data and
uh most deviating in in two different
directions most deviating solutions so
the question is uh what actually it
means the movement in this direction and
in this direction in in understandable
terms of Behavior so for Behavior Uh
we sorry uh we see uh two components of
this Behavior the height of uh height of
the peak and pace of the process so this
process is faster than this
one so how we can interpret this
picture in these terms
and it appears we
can it appears that we can see that all
parameters related
to defective particles to processes with
defective
particles are in in terms of peak height
are lower
than
parameters associated with wild type
and more than that uh parameters uh
which rules U behavior of uninfected
cells uh are here in the group of
defective parameters so to
say and when we change the direction uh
uh so it will be are two direction here
this one and this one so in this in in
this direction its movement uh we have
uh this sort of picture and in in
opposite direction not opposite but oral
direction we have this sort
of what it means in terms of uninfected
cells we can see that uninfected cells
are jumping together with parameters
related to uninfected cells are jumping
together with
parameters associated with defected
particles uh like it's it's it's uh
depicted
here so we can say and this is actually
what we are saying in in the part in the
manuscript that uh defective particles
some somehow
attenuating behavior of uninfected cells
it means the loss of uninfected cells is
attenuated by these defective
particles this is so to say a
biological uh conclusion major
biological conclusion from the story
that we found that indeed defective
particle somehow helping not to lose too
many uh too many uninfected
cells okay and the next uh next so sorry
so here um I'm just saying that
acknowledgements that this is people
from tber Center uh Professor Andino and
our collaborator from Institute pster in
France uh okay the next story I have I I
have five minutes
yes yes you have some time yeah okay uh
this is another story uh this is story
uh about how to introduce uh time in in
an in B informatic informatics analysis
of uh omix data in particular for for
instance single cell gene expression
data or uh multiomics and physiological
features of individuals in aging and so
on uh metagenomics data so we have some
observation but can can we present it as
as a
Time Time related potential so like like
a bow on on the mountain which can go
down so where we have mountains and
where we we have um
sys okay actually it was uh it was great
publication of this sort and we um
expanded what was found in this
publication that this potential for
observation can
be
reconstructed
uh uh
using laan Matrix
uh uh and if we know for instance stages
like aging stages or uh single
cell
differentiation
differentiation stages for for cells so
preparing a graph of some sort in
multi-dimensional space uh and preparing
this Lan Matrix we can for observed
observed observed cases we we can say
what kind of potential uh Dynamic
potential force field potential we have
along these
cases uh the next stage is okay what we
can say about Point here
inside and it means that we we we uh we
would like to prepare this sface which
will show that this is a mountain and
this is some sink and uh and this
stability stability State thing uh could
be related for instance to uh old
individuals with some illness and here
with just healthy old
individuals okay we we did it with the
with the technique of partial
differential equations uh and uh based
on on uh boundary values we restored
this uh this
surface
uh and as a result with this surface and
this is a projection of this surface so
this is a mountain now for any point we
we can say what what are possible
trajectory and what what are times to go
and probabilities to go over this
projectory or over that
projectory and uh
even in the case of going from this hole
to this hole uh over the potential
barrier like like here yes and we can
estimate what what what time for
diffusion is needed in order to go here
from here to here or in opposite
direction so from
uh from data uh under condition of that
the system is stabilized we can actually
restore uh time
story and uh uh and since it can be
applied to many types of multi feature
data I believe this is this is good
perspective to uh to introduce this time
uh time
time exess in and actually real biology
it means uh to the multiomic study okay
uh this story was U
done by the team of tber informatic
Center in collaboration with Professor
gutov from Rosell Park Comprehensive
Cancer Center
Buffalo thank
you okay thank you very much uh for the
the presentation and uh you know I think
it uh follows some of the discussions
that we just had um and uh our next
speaker is going to be kind of
addressing I think some of the
biological uh parts of this story so uh
Dr Andino I wonder if you had any uh
comments on this presentation that we
just
saw hopefully he's yeah I was
taking notes is it's very interesting uh
the last topic was uh you know obviously
the first topic is something that it's
very um well we've been discussing this
for a long time with Leon um and I I
will extend a little bit more um that
but it was a great introduction to
trying to understand how this um
defective uh genomes interfere with the
w and you know can this be um an
approach for therapy so when I make my
presentation I'd like to give an update
of where we are on that uh in a
manuscript that we are preparing on that
that subject but I was very interested
on uh the second part um and I have a
question Leon so clearly the the idea of
time resolution uh of these processes
are critical and I like the idea that
you you know descend in a mountain um
from a mountain and coming down from a
mountain you can take different path I
imagine um and the question is can we
understand uh that you know you're
really going down and can you anticipate
what is this path maybe we can interrupt
this path and that's will be you know
the more practical um exercise here so
how do you train that U model what kind
of information can be used to train the
model and to Define better whether there
are common path if everybody is taking
the the uh Trail or people go down the
mountains and and and completely random
ways uh okay the only thing which you
need is some stabilized system and
measurement of this system M multi
multi-dimensional
measurements and uh uh so the first step
is to to to understand how uh how um
this Dynamic potential behave on
observations and after that the the
surface with unknown cases also could be
reconstructed and as to
trajectories uh we actually can based on
parameters on parameters of
defusion uh we can estimate
probabilities for every
trajector based on of course based on
these
parameters and maybe it will answer your
question that some trajectory will be
with low probabilities and other
projectory will be very very
problem of course in the case of Aging
aging is very probable process uh but we
have two direction to be healthy or to
be uh with some some illness and very
important question is to to what
direction we will go
starting from specific point on this
surface and second if it's possible for
instance from from illness to go back to
health very
interesting thank
you thank you very much um and uh I know
that we um are just right on schedule so
um again thank you for that presentation
Dr Lena Brodsky and I want to um
introduce our next
speaker uh so you for those of you that
have been around for the past uh hour or
so you already heard but for those that
are just joining now uh our next speaker
is Dr rul Andino uh he's a professor in
the department of microbiology and
Immunology at the University of
California San Francisco uh he's a
virologist and professor and uh he is uh
working on some similar topics um and so
we want to um in invite him to present
his perspective on omx and biology and
specifically how the pandemic has also
changed uh approaches in that field so
Dr Andino over to
you thank you Leon um IIA um let me see
can you see my
slides yes we can
see okay so this first slide is um one
of these wonderful experiments of um
particle interference in Quantum quantum
mechanics and and to me is one of those
examples is beautiful to just to see the
movie but it it it it brings two things
here is one is a Time resolution that
we've been discussing from from the very
beginning the importance of
understanding that these things are you
know really Dynamic the other thing is
that this has um you know is a very
simple observation that enables to um
develop models that tell us uh a lot
about the universe and to me it's a
fascinating uh process that we can
understand what happened in a supernova
uh why we have never been there and will
never be able to um survive
there but really what I wanted to
discuss is you know science and
technology in the time of pandemics and
this is the type of Technology people
use in the 14th century when in in
Venice uh you know the um um plague um
uh H this uh the bonic plague um and
really uh right now what's uh happening
is the technology has changed and what
we um dealing with is in the 21st
century and a new a new type of pandemic
or epidemics but now we have uh
additional tools additional information
um that can help us to perhaps
anticipate predict and uh intervene in a
more effective way
and so really the concept that we trying
to explore is how can we integrate um
the pro the the different layers um that
you will have when you are um trying to
understand virus diseases um and and
really you know it goes from the epidemi
epidemiological situation to the
individual situation to the tissue
situation um and to the Single Cell um
situation and of course at the end of
the day it's all about molecules that
somehow interact with each other and and
that determine all these levels of um
complexity and the Continuum between
these molecules and the epidemiological
effects they actually broke uh break at
some point the question is how can we
integrate how can we connect one layer
with the other it's a little bit the
same with phys particles and you know
large objects like the Apple that's
famous Apple that feels in in Newton's
head you know how do we connect what
happened in our universe with uh what
happened at the particle level and what
we trying to do in really scratching the
surface here is um both in silk culture
and in animal models we try to on the
one hand understand um the virus
population Dynamics so we're trying to
understand how the virus by sequencing
viruses um virus genomes um you know how
the viruses populations differentiate in
different organs so here we have organ a
b and c which maybe the brain and the
liver and the kidney um and this
population acquire some sort of
signatures um that we can identify and
that's the experimental data that we can
um collect by sequencing viruses
obtained from different
organs um or different conditions in
cell culture then the important thing is
the statistical learning that allows us
to uh classifi what are the changes in
the viral genome and how this um genome
is changing over time so to give us some
sort of Dynamics not only we have a
classification of the of the AL that we
see in different organs you know some
will be beneficial some will be
detrimental in the organ a but in B it
could be opposite maybe this the ones
were detrimental in a now are beneficial
in B so understanding this sort of um
you know different um changes um and in
ating that with the global gene
expression what happened to the
ecological niche um where the virus is
replicating what happened in organ a b
and c is what will give us a little bit
more understanding of what are the
forces that are um the virus is subject
to to change when it goes in a b or c
and you know one of the things that
comes very clear is that if we think
about ecology of infection in other
words the infection as an ecological
process and really the um process inside
of the infected individual as a
intrahost adaptation process really as
an evolutionary process that ecology um
has G us give us a lot of guidance of
how to analyze this kind of dynamic
process really there is a new organism
getting to the niche as is as modified
by the niche itself because it's
changing over time but it's also
Modified by other individuals in that
Niche and that's one of the things that
I wanted to discuss is you know how this
defective interfering
genomes uh can be playing a role in
changing the outcome of the infection in
individuals infected
individuals now the for all of you you
know right now that um one of the
important things in uh virus um
Evolution and
adaptation um at the small level meaning
you know the virus in a test tube or in
an organ what happen is um the virus
acquire mutations because their um uh
enzymes that duplicate or replicate The
genome they are a little sloppy and they
like to be sloppy and they introduce
mutations they make mistakes and so you
you end up with a bunch of mutations in
the genome and really this is a
population of genome that we call quasi
species um the other um important
mechanism of um during replication is
Rec combination whereas um one genome
here in red is being read by an enzyme
which is a polymerase and at some point
the polymerase decides to leave this
temp in red and jump on a blue template
and so now at the end as a consequence
of that you end up with a Rec combinant
a little bit of red a little bit of blue
so understanding the interaction between
mutations and Rec combination is
critical to understand diversity in the
virus
population and then there is selection
so Evolution works as diversity and the
product of diversity and selection and
of course many of these genomes here um
they are not viable they have Leal
mutations and um some of them gets um
selected over time using sequencing uh
you you can now start to classify
mutations That You observe in this
populations um as a Leal
delerious neutral if they don't change
the fitness or beneficial in a
particular um environment and of course
this um is um these mutations are
important to classify not only um you
cannot again is the the case of the
Dynamics of this process is very
important and the question is this
happen at a very micro evolution level
this happen at the level of the virus
the virus when replicating in a
particular cell is introducing this
mutation recombining and being selected
but how that reflect what happened in a
global pandemic is a big question and
can we use data obtain in a very well
defined experimental conditions to
understand um and predict uh how a
pandemic will um evolve how you know is
this virus going to evolve or can you
anticipate you know whether it's going
to be what will be the next pandemic
that's a big big big question and I
think the answer really is most people
would say there is so much much
stochastical stochastic tastic in this
process that the prediction will be very
hard um but I think if one can reduce
the problem to say these are the things
that cannot
happen we don't know exactly what's
going to happen but we know that the
virus cannot go in this trajectory and I
think this is an interesting challenge
for for all of
us we developed and I remember um back
in uh in uh I think was 2012 or
something that we uh sit together with
Leon it in this coffee shop in the wi
man Institute in drova and Israel and
discuss about this technology and Le it
in I think in 24 hours developed an
algorithm that allow us to move forward
much faster and more efficiently let me
just walk you through what this idea is
one of the problems in uh biology is
that we have experimental noise and
sequencing has an experimental noise
meaning that uh every time you sequence
uh the DNA the machine that is
sequencing the DNA is introducing
mutations and at the end of the day you
don't know whether these mutations were
in the vir genome or were introduced by
mistakes on during sequencing so what we
apply here is one technology that we
call circular sequencing or CC what
basically is is we circularize the viral
RNA and these circles can be used as a
template to create standing repeats when
you do your cdna synthesis which is the
first step that you need to do for
sequencing then you put this cdna that
are linked together because they've been
produced in this circular template and
now you can do consensus of you know
really consensus sequence of all these
repeats and so mutations that are in all
the
repeats um now are predicted to have
been in the original template this
reduce the the error of sequencing
because you identify mutations that were
generated there um random
and it allows it to to reduce the noise
very very much you know every time you
read this is multiply the error of
sequencing um several times so elevated
to the number of times that you read
this repeats this allows you to not only
identify many mutations that are present
at high frequency in the population but
many mutations like lethal mutations
that are um not present in the
population can be also identified and
those Leal mutations are important
because this allows you to say the
viruses will never acquire this mutation
and maybe these are regions that cannot
change there are good invariance regions
that you can Target pharmacologically
for
example so what happened with the Sals
CO2 I know that many of us all of us I
guess have been very much affected by
this pandemic and we all you know
starting to get more familiar with terms
like IM mutations and surface proteins
and the spike and antibodies and so on I
just wanted to you know bring this um uh
this things a little bit because um you
know everybody's interested and I wanted
to use it as an example of how can you
use um the bioinformatic and omics to
understand pandemic and maybe generate
effective interventions
this is the situation globally and the
US you see these Peaks that appear on
number of cases and this is consistent
with a number of deaths um and a vaccine
has been deployed as since the beginning
of
2021 and you can see that vaccines are
effective and yet um there is again a
spike and and those spikes emerge uh no
for a number of reasons one is because
not everybody gets vaccinated ated two
because the vaccines are not 100%
effective particular are not effective
at preventing
transmission um and three uh because the
virus is changing based on the on the uh
uh you
know challenge uh that the virus have in
terms of transmission replicating and
and be successful at replication uh you
know the virus is changing
and uh really the the the the the
critical thing in any of these viruses
uh transmission is the ability of the
virus to be transmitted from one
individual to other but as I said you
know the virus that you um um acquire is
different than the virus that populate
the different organs is probably uh
different than the virus that really
cause the disease uh because in in many
ways those viruses needs to adapt to a
particular organ for examp example in SE
in the case of s Corona viruses we know
is a very complex disease that not only
replicates in lungs but also replicates
and produce uh inflammatory effects in
uh in pancreas and and in the heart um
and you know so we don't really
understand many of this and in part is
because we don't we don't understand
this adaptive capacity of the virus and
the same thing with with transmission
you know what happened with the new
strains
um this is an example for example in the
UK uh where you see that there was this
strain here replicating until you know
November 20 um 20 and then there is
another strain that replac the previous
one so the question is U this strain
what is the the the why is this strain
replacing the previous one probably is
more fit and um that's logical um
conclusion uh but but really the
question is why is more fit and many
people are focusing on um this
particular interaction and in my mind
it's a little
bit a little bit minimalistic and a
little bit maybe um you know unrealistic
to just think that the only thing that
can guide the virus to be more fit is
the interaction between the
receptor called a C2 and the spike this
is the little protein that is in the
surface of the virus and many of these
mutations indeed map in this surface and
people have actually learned that um
some of these mutations increase or
improve the interaction and recognition
of of the
ac2 but really when you think about it
there is another domain in s that is
called the N terminal domain which is
very different than the one interact
with ac2 and there are many mutations
here that emerge during um this um the
emergence these new strains in the UK in
South Africa Brazil California and now
the Delta um that also contain mutations
in either of these
domains but
importantly um we know that is this
protein and this is the viral genome
here this protein is encoded here in s
and but if you look at that the vir
genome is huge compared so this guy has
about five KVs um but the V genome is
about 30 KVs and so focusing just a
small domain here in this might actually
be a mistake what else is going on um
and we know now that from 28 viral
proteins seven has been recognized to
modulate the immune immune response and
that's very important because um viruses
when it get to the next ecological niche
the critical thing is that they were
able to deal with the antiviral defense
mechanisms not only they have to
replicate but also they need to block
suppress interferon or any other type of
antiviral response so and the arm
mutations that occur occur through the
genome the question is how do we
integrate how can we can understand this
mutations so um I know that I'm probably
I'm
talking more um time that when I shoot
so let me ask how you have time you you
have another few minutes you're good how
many minut
minutes another 10 minutes okay so let
let me go very quickly because I wanted
to share with you two different things
that we've been doing uh recently and
one is uh trying to use mathematical
models that honestly I learned from um
the interaction with Leon and um Simone
biano two um people that I I I interact
over many years and what we wanted to do
and I wanted to put this is uh you know
very top of my inverted pyramid the
epidemiological aspect of this and that
is you know how is nonpharmacological
interventions can help to um provide a
solution to this epidemic and the
important thing is can we Define
parameters to drive the epidemic can we
train the model with real EMP empirical
data and then use additional data to try
to see whether it fits um
and how we can examine elements that
could change the course of the epidemic
and and in in ways that are effective to
provide this these
Solutions and so what we use here a very
simple um stastical stochastic uh model
and basically is like a playing with a
pacman uh system in which uh individ was
um they actually U move within a
restricted area um in surface and every
time they bounce against the wall they
change directions and they move that way
that's the simple um this is one
individual and then you can of course
change the number of individuals the
size of the of the um environment and so
what we are interested is understanding
uh this the dynamics of the epidemic and
what uh we um consider is that when two
individual one infected here Circle by
Red um it contact UM one individual that
is uninfected at a distance that is
lower than two radius so they are really
in contact now this guy has a
probability to be infected and over 10
days it
recovers so let me just show you the um
the key here those are susceptible
individuals and what we're going to try
to uh understand is the effect of mask
in the probability of transmission and
in the course of the epidemic um so in
green are individuals that are
susceptible with mask and then the red
circle IND indicates you know
individuals that are infected and the
probability of two one infected
individual to transmit uh the virus is
given by this Factor Alpha that uh we
calculate it's basically um a way to
determine the probability of infection
and it has a specific number that has
been uh obtained based on experimental
data now if one of the individual the
infected individual uh is using a mask
the probability of transmission is
reduced by this number here 05 and if
the mass is used by the susceptible
individual sorry um the the the mask is
used by the susceptible individual not
by the infected then there is another
factor of
0.15 that um determine or reduce the
probability of
infection the important thing is that
this type of um exercise enables to have
have a visualization of the process and
we as a primates work best at um when
you have a visualization of the process
that is what Inspire us the most to
understand a process numbers are more
difficult sometimes to to understand so
let me uh remind you we have contact
infection and recovery and um depending
if you are using mask or not you have a
probability of being infected that is
determined by this Alpha factor and so
this what you will see here is a panel
where nobody's using mask a panel where
40% of people are using mask and a panel
where 80% of people using mask and in
this kind of stochastic models of course
you can change the probability of
infection depending of many factors and
adjusting the fact the model that way
you can change the number of people
using mass and and so um and what you
see now is the people moving around and
there's individual people um infected
person and and this person move around
and see as you see you know this um um
group of people with no mask get
infected very quickly and they have this
uh blue Peak here um that is the number
of people infected per day and there a
critical parameter because um the uh
important thing is that you don't want
to overwhelm the health system the
hospitals and so the flatter this blue
curve is the better uh you can deal with
the epidemics and you can see that if
80% of people use mask that blue curve
is flatter than if nobody's using mask
now the other thing that people have
been considering is this um social
distancing and the way we uh model
social distancing is um you know two
individuals may be moving with no social
distance so they move around randomly
both of them but when there is some
social distancing some proportion of the
population does not move anymore and
that reduce the probability of encounter
you know the close encounter between
between the infected and non-infected
individual and so um this simulates what
would happen if you don't go to work you
stay home or uh you know or you you you
decide you know that you know that you
don't go to the grocery store so often
and so on and when we use this now you
will see the same parameters greens
using mask blue not using mask different
proportion of mask used here and you
will see now when I start the movie that
part of the uh population does not move
in this particular movie we're using um
40% of people people are staying home
and and what you see now is see there's
many people that are sitting in their
homes but there's other people that are
bringing the pizzas or whatever they
they are they are actually coming to
thing but you know of course um because
there is less chance that they will
encounter uh each other you see that
there is a reduction of the the number
of of infected individuals per day so
the blue curve is a little bit um uh
smaller than the ones I I showed you
before but the best effect is when you
combine both things of course mask use
of mask reduce probability of infection
and the the people stay in put um also
reduce the probability of
transmission at the at the end of the
day this is a combination of these two
studies here you have in in red is
wearing mask and blue is 40 nowh in mask
blue is 40% 80% and and here is social
distance zero this is very bad situation
because you have a peak of individuals
coming out at a particular uh day to the
hospital so you overwhelm the hospital
as you increase social disty you reduce
uh that red Peak but if you use mask
which is 80% and green basically you
know you have very little um numbers of
um individuals infected now the really
the question is um can you maintain 80%
of use of mask and 80% of distancing and
the answer is obviously uh there is no
compliance of using mask and then social
distance is being uh having an impact on
uh society and economy and so on um but
I just wanted to to bring this uh at the
end to to this to this two uh graphics
these are death per million people um
and you see that if you compare a
curve um where there's no social
distance or 80% of people um use um is
social is not going to work um the two
curb seems to respond to the use mask
this is 0 to 80% you can see that even
though nobody's stay home you know the
mask really have a strong effect on
reducing the number of death of people
but that's not the case if you invert
the situation now you're looking social
distance here and wearing mask zero or
80% here is very high but the but but
really the um the uh the social distance
if you don't wear a mask doesn't seems
to be affected as much
and also of course the best is the
combination but um the uh Mass seems to
be more effective the more people use
mask more clearly uh you change the
probability of the pandemic to to
expand well I want I wanted to you know
talk about the um the second part which
is the effective interfer particles
because this and I will try to do it in
in in in last the last four or five
minutes just touching superficially very
high on the idea of
um you know how this defective interfer
particles can um be used as a therapy
and um recombination is not a perfect
process like any biological process and
sometimes the polymerase doesn't jump
exactly to the place where uh are the
same place but in the blue genome so
sometimes it jump forward and Leon was
mentioning that often we see delions in
this viral genomes and so we wanted to
understand that and we create uh a
deletion in uh one and this is a picorna
virus um to create this um defective
interferent particle or
dip and the question was really you know
can we create um a therapy using this
thing because it this defec particle
might actually attenuate infection and
this was a collaboration between Jud
frean Stanford Leon Broski from hia um
Ro Nakamura from Alf biotechs and Simone
biano from IBM and Ilia Broski and I I
think it's interesting because here
there was three academic institutions um
interacting with uh three um companies
that provide uh different um aspects and
it was a very interesting uh not only a
mixture of expertise but also coming
from different perspectives and and
areas and basically if you um co- inject
poo viruses with this defective inter
particle you protect here is the co
infection and here is if you just infect
uh with the virus you can see that you
protect this this animal about 30 30% of
the animals do do not do not survive
just with polio but more than 0% survive
and that is because the virus cannot go
to the brain so here the brain in solid
lines you see a lot of um a lot of um
virus in the brain at day one and day
three and this is why the this animals
die because PO is a neurotropic virus
but if you co infect with the ET you see
no virus in brain and this also protect
against other viruses Kaki and
influenza and also protect against s CO2
and here you are doing an intranational
inoculation of this Steep and and then
challenge with s Co 2 and these are
highly susceptible animals uh you see
reduction of about three logs of um of
virus in the lung and in the brain and
um and you can see that the virus
replicates very well this is the amof
fluoresence using antibodies against the
spike or the or n or Spike which are
those two proteins of the virus this is
three days uh po infection this is six
days post infection and when you do the
co infection you completely protect both
the lung as well as the
brain and this uh therapy works uh not
only by uh prophylactic putting the the
the the the effective particle before
but you can also use it therapeutically
so in this case we are putting the the
etip uh 24 hours or 48 Hours be after
infection and also works in different
strains that are circulating this is the
UK strain this is the California strains
this is the initial um us
strain now this is what I really wanted
to to tell you because I think at that
this point we wanted to understand you
know what was the nature of the
protection you know why this thing
protects and it turns out that we uh did
a very initial analysis using um RNA
sick data and it's very clear in this
volcano plot that there's a bunch of
genes in red here that corresponds to
genes of type one
interfer response and we use also
animals that don't are not able to
respond to interference and in that case
um these uh animals are not protected so
the conclusion really is that this
defective interferent particles do not
work just simply by competing with uh
the WTI virus but actually create some
sort of antiviral state that um you know
help to eliminate uh the pathogenic
virus um and
basically now we've been doing some
analysis and we need to go now with
single cell analysis but this is just
flow cytometry and what we can see in
this analysis is that the virus is a is
affecting the way that imun immune
system responds to um the infection
there's some cells specific cells that
now are present in the lung during
infection that were not present or
suppressed by Sal CO2 so really what at
the end of the day what I think is uh
this type of therapies is doing is
changing the uh character of the immune
system uh from an
inflammatory condition which are
represented by this type of cells and we
know that SARS one of the reasons why
SARS cause diseases because in initiate
inflammatory response we think the E
this this effective interfer genome what
is doing is changing to an antiviral
State um and then coagulation is another
characteristics of the SARS of the the
covid-19 disease and you know we again
we think that is the balance between
this two lineages of um imuno cells that
are very important to control and um age
also when you have age is another factor
of risk and what happen is when people
get older um there's a problem at the um
stem cell level where you start getting
more meid progen progenitors rather than
lymphoid and so
again understanding this process and
this viance and this um at the level of
cell population will be very important
for this particular disease that there
are many infectious diseases uh
particular virus diseases in which the
disease
is the consequence of the an imbalanced
immunological
response um and I think I'm gonna have
to um stop here although this last part
was is very exciting and and it's
something about we are developing with
Ilia Broski but uh I'm not gonna have
enough time I I believe um so you know
I'll stop here um
in and apologize for being a little bit
longer than I was anticipating no
problem it's a very exciting talks and
thank you for covering in such detail um
some of the things that were presented
uh have Associated Publications and so
we'll try to uh get the links for those
and share them with all of you as well I
now wanted to and thank you uh Dr Andino
for sharing uh with us all I do want to
now um because we are a little bit um
behind uh introduce our next
speaker uh so our uh next speaker is
Julia panoff she's the associate
director at the tabber bionformatics
research center hi University in Israel
uh where uh she is working on Big Data
omx analysis integration and modeling
she is involved in different projects
including analysis of whole genome
sequencing single cell sequencing
proteon ICS and phosphor proteomics mass
spec data as well as others and she is
now finishing her PhD studies at uh Dr
kavan's lab in neurobiology where she
has been studying molecular mechanisms
of neurodevelopmental disorders using a
variety of bionformatics tools and so
Julia will speak to us today about
analysis of whole genome sequence data
in cancer studies as well as analysis of
single cell transcriptomic data and bulk
RNA deconvolution approach so Julia over
to
you okay can you try now yes thank you
um thank you very much for the
introduction co-host
yep thank you for the introduction and
um thank you
everybody uh so today today I want to
share with you uh a little bit of the
ongoing projects that we are doing at
the tabber uh bioinformatics Research
Center uh and that I have been involved
in um and which have become the basis of
three newly developed sections on the T
bioinfo platform uh so first uh I want
to introduce you a little bit to the
tber bioinformatics uh Research
Center
um so t b maybe I can start sharing my
uh
screen
okay so tabber bioinformatics uh
Research Center is a research center at
the University of hia in Israel uh and
we are a team of biologists
bioinformaticians and computer
scientists and our main goal U of the
center is to make bioinformatics tools
access ible to a wide range of uh
researchers uh so for this we uh are
developing and maintaining and updating
this T bioinfo platform which you can
see right now that has a wide array of
uh areas omx areas that we uh upgrade
and uh
update um the platform has a user uh
friendly interface uh for analysis of
different types of uh omx data uh so of
course having access to such a platform
might assist an analysis however uh many
times researchers coming from different
areas of expertise don't know where to
start or how best to utilize the tools
available on the platform even if the
tools are quite easy for use and don't
need uh extensive knowledge of uh
algorithms that are behind the tools so
uh we collaborate with pine biotech team
um on development of tutorials and study
materials exampler projects short
courses and
specializations um to enable research to
quickly start using the platform for
their own
research um so today I will be sharing
with you uh two main projects that uh
our team talber team has been working on
for the past year or so uh and based on
which we have developed uh three new uh
uh sections of the platform and at the
moment uh together with pine biotech
team we are working on writing up the
tutorials uh and exampler stepbystep uh
guides for running the pipelines that I
will be speaking about on the platform
and we hope that in a few months these
sections will be uh open for all the uh
tbio info platform users so um the first
project that I want to share with you uh
will be a project dedicated to analysis
of whole genome sequencing data uh that
has been uh that we have been involved
with with and in collaboration with
Professor uh gutov from uh Rosell
Comprehensive Cancer Center uh so this
section uh was tailored actually for
tumor normal pairs of samples from the
same patient however many of these tools
uh can be applied to a wide range of
biological questions so um as you
probably know uh whole genome sequencing
has become a go-to technology for cancer
research uh it allows unprecedented
understanding of genome alteration at a
single uh nucleotide level uh using home
uh genome sequencing technology we can
identify
uh genome duplications
deletions uh
inversions uh and insertions as well as
point mutations and changes from
heterozygosity to homozygosity in cancer
cells so this is the section that we
have been uh developing and working on
and and it includes pipelines that allow
to study uh all those chromosomal
alterations uh point mutations driver
genes uh using control tumor pairs of
samples so in our project uh for example
uh we found great variability in
chromosomal instability what you see
here uh on the left um right here is one
of the uh representative samples that we
have been working with uh and we saw saw
that some of the chromosomal uh regions
have up to 10 times uh amplification of
this region for example in chromosome 12
of this genome uh in another type of
cancer another representative uh sample
on the right uh you can see that uh much
less events have happened and uh the
chromosomal instability is not as
uh as overwhelming as on the left
however still here we also see some uh
duplication events and some uh deletion
events as in chromosome 3 for
example uh if we look uh more in details
to these uh structural variations in uh
types in different types of cancers uh
we found uh that different cancers have
of course different structural
variations and uh the pipelines allow us
to look at uh such variations as
deletions
duplications insertions inversions and
translocations of
genomic uh lowai with u really
nucleotide
uh
uh proficiency for example we can see
exact
uh exact uh points where the uh
duplication has happened
um the next uh the next problem that a
lot of cancer researchers uh are dealing
with are uh nucleotide uh alterations or
mutations and differences in mutation
load in normal and tumor samples and
there are basically two approaches at
looking at these uh at point mutations
we can either uh look at cumulative
distribution of uh
alterations uh compared to the reference
genome and what you see on the left is a
graph is a comparison of uh normal
tissue from the patient which is green
so uh frequencies of
mutations uh in normal tissue uh and by
mutations here I mean alterations from
the reference genome and uh alterations
from the uh reference genome in the
tumor sample which is represented by the
red line and we can see that there is
faster accumulation of low frequency
mutations in tumor and this uh of course
is in line with our understanding of
clonality of tumor uh meaning that tumor
cells do not have similar mutations in
all of the cells and we can uh compare
these distributions of cumulative uh
mutations uh with uh for example with
kagor smov statistic which will show us
the significance of difference between
uh these two
distributions on the right uh you can
see a histogram of the same actually uh
distributions and again we can see that
uh in while in uh normal samples which
are represented by the blue lines uh we
see accumulation of differences from the
reference genome at about uh 50% so
heteros
zygotic uh
um uh alternative alls uh in tumor
samples we see this accumulation at low
um at uh low frequency of mutations and
also at High frequency of mutations when
uh when
heterozygotic uh alternative LS uh are
moved to
homoy a different approach is of course
to study sematic mutations in tumors and
here the challenge is uh in uh
identifying uh tumor Purity and of
course uh when we take uh tumor samples
they are not 100% pure uh so that means
that uh a lot of uh
reads from a tumor sample are actually
coming from uh
normal uh
cells uh which u means that a lot of
times it is hard to identify whether the
particular uh alteration is actual
mutation or it can be a mistake in
sequencing or mistake in
alignment uh so there are many uh
algorithms uh that have been developed
to finding sematic mutations in tumor
using uh tumor and normal uh pairs of
samples taken from the same uh tissue uh
from the same patient sorry uh one of
the gold standards is MP 2 um approach
uh algorithm which we also have uh used
for our study and you can see that
different cancers have different uh
loads of somatic
mutations uh finally we can uh also
identify uh driver mutations or driver
genes and uh based on the uh both on the
genomic location of the mutation and the
neighboring uh sequences uh next to the
mutation we can uh discriminate between
uh driver mutations mutations that drive
the evolution of the tumor and between
uh passenger mutations that appear in
the evolution of the tumor and again uh
you can see that we found some genes
that uh putative driver uh driver uh
genes of this particular
cancer and finally all of this uh
information uh wide r of information can
be uh put together in one graphical
representation that helps put all the
information together and if we look at
two uh cancers we see that there is
uh there is a wide variety of uh signals
in two different
cancers so one particular uh interest H
or or recently it has been uh suggested
as one of the drivers of uh gen of tumor
uh
Evolution uh is the sematic Integrations
of repetitive elements in the genome
into the genome and as you might know uh
protein coding genes uh are just a very
small portion of our Genome of the human
genome and of all um Alan genome and a
big portion of the genome is actually
repetitive elements that have not been
studied widely before but that have been
a focus of many studies
recently
um and uh they uh have a specific
challenges computational challenges
because of their repetitive
uh sequence uh nature so these sequences
are actually very similar and they
appear in many many places in the genome
so a standard approaches of
aligning uh genomic reads onto those uh
onto those regions fail uh because all
of the reads uh that actually come from
different parts of the genome align to
uh just several uh parts of the genome
and of course also these regions are
very hard to assemble so many times
these uh regions are uh do not appear in
reference uh genome however uh recently
uh it has been
uh one of the main
uh repetitive element that has been
proven to be active and not only in
tumor cells uh but in other disorders as
well is line one it is capable of uh
retrotransposition when it uh when it is
translated and can be inserted into a
different uh genomic region and uh it
has been shown that usually those
repetitive elements are guarded against
by uh
methylation uh but in many disorders
such as cancer metabolic disorders
neurological disorders and other
there is hypomethylation of the genome
and these uh and these repetitive
elements uh are uh do transpose and not
only themselves but also other
repetitive elements and other uh genomic
elements so one of our
uh goals in this study was to study the
somatic integration of these repetitive
elements into the tumor uh in the
genomes of tumor
cells and we have developed this
uh pipelines that allow others also to
um study uh such sematic Integrations of
repetitive elements uh there have been
several other uh algorithms uh developed
recently that also uh try to study these
um these repetitive elements and their
integration into genome H and as I said
earlier uh it is uh computationally it
is challenging so we cannot uh
actually uh we cannot uh use uh standard
uh tools that uh are used in in for
example M uh regular uh genome uh
sequencing analysis so here for example
uh we have an approach uh where we use
uh split reads or we call them sometimes
hybrid reads when part of the read what
you see in black uh is the sequencing
pair and sequencing read and we align
the sequencing read to the uh repeat
template uh with part of the read
hanging out and then we uh continue to
um align the reads to the reference
genome and by this way we can identify
the putative uh integration sites uh
either integration sites that are not
included in the reference genome uh or
integration sites that were already in
the reference genome so using this uh
approach we found uh sematic sign
Integrations H in our two different
types of cancer and um this is sematic
integration per
cell we also had matching RNA sequencing
uh data for the matching uh samples and
so we compare to the expression of the
same sign uh repetitive elements with uh
the with the uh sematic integration into
the genome and we found that uh the
expression of this of these uh signs um
are mirrored in the sematic
Integrations uh into the
genome uh a different uh so this was our
project uh regarding the uh whole genome
um sequence Ing and Analysis of whole
genome sequencing
uh data um next project that we uh did
in collaboration with uh Professor
Moselle Levy from Georgetown University
and his uh lab uh was um analysis of
single nuclei RNA seek uh data from uh
covid-19 patients and we have developed
veled uh also we are developing uh this
uh new um T bioinfo PL uh section that
will uh be uh also available to all the
uh users I hope soon uh so H as you
probably know a single cell or single
nuclei RNA SE uh involves first of all
single cell suspension and then uh
single cell sequencing when uh cell
barcodes and um Yumi barcodes which uh
barcode uh actual mRNA uh molecules are
uh connected to this uh read and by uh
reading the cell barcodes and umumi
barcodes we can
identify uh which reads belong to which
cells and which molecules and by this
way we can get an expression m
Matrix or expression table where we have
thousands of cells from different
patients for example with of course uh
in uh with expression of thousands of uh
genes so uh we actually analyzed
uh recently um published a data set uh
from this publication from aiv uh Team
from broad Institute they have uh
published
uh data from different organs of uh SARS
uh
covid-19 um patients uh some and they
also published some information about
the patients uh so we were interested in
a kidney uh organ and so we uh analyzed
the kidney uh data from these
patients uh the first uh actually
question that we had and uh Perhaps it
is somehow related to the talk that we
heard from Professor Andino is whether
uh covid-19 actually targets uh kidney
tissue
uh directly or whether what we see uh of
kidney uh failure is not uh because of
the direct uh targeting um by the uh
SARS 2 uh virus so there is conflicting
evidence uh there are some reports that
say that uh Corona virus infection
targets uh directly the kidney and
others that uh fail to replicate or that
uh do not find this uh to be true uh we
looked uh at our data actually well not
at our data but at the data that we have
been analyzing uh and we also did not
find any evidence of uh reads that came
from SARS coov V2 um
genome uh so uh what we uh studied is a
host response uh to the infection
uh in covid-19 uh patients compared to
controls and what you see uh here on the
graph is a uh after U batch Corrections
and and after normalization of the data
uh how uh the different cells which are
presented as uh points here and pink
points are represent cells coming from
covid-19 patients and blue cells Blue
Points represent cells coming from
control uh
patients uh how uh closely uh they are
uh related and we can see that there is
uh some cells that uh appear to be
different in covid-19 patients compared
to control
patients uh now we were uh especially
interested in
covid-19 patients that have uh some uh
comorbidity uh such as uh obesity
diabetes kidney disease uh and so forth
and covid-19 critical patients that do
not have these uh comorbidities and of
course we compared them to the control
patients and what you see here is just
the same uh actually graph as you have
seen uh before just dividing into those
three types of patients uh and also uh
clustered so this clustering of cells
was done
unsupervisedly uh so that we actually
cannot tell uh at the moment which cells
uh belong which cells we are looking at
we just know that uh cells uh in cluster
one for example uh transcriptionally
they are very similar uh uh to each
other and are probably very different
from another cluster such as cluster
eight so uh in this um what right away I
think uh is uh evident from this uh
visualization is that um cells from
cluster one it seems like a control
patients almost have no cells in this
cluster one and uh if to present
a different uh cluster for example in
cluster zero we see that most of the
most that actually uh covid-19 patients
have less uh cells in cluster zero than
the control patients and it can be
argued whether uh covid-19 patients with
comor morbidity have more cells or not
and uh we are working right now on
identifying whether uh this is true true
or not however uh this does not answer
one of the most uh important questions
and that is which cells exactly are we
talking about when we talk about this
cluster one so there are uh several
approaches to uh try to annotate the uh
types of uh cells that we are looking at
and uh this is our
um uh attempt and I have to say that
this exercise did not go very well and I
will share with you in a minute why uh
but uh the uh known uh marker genes that
we have used to
identify uh the cell types for these
clusters uh seem to not work very well
for example
um some of the ptoy markers one of the
cell types in kidneys uh are those three
genes presented on the left and you can
see that here uh the poite uh cluster uh
actually is a um these G these markers
are expressed in this uh part of the uh
of the graph uh which is uh here so we
can say that actually poyes we were able
to identify which cluster belongs to the
poyes
uh and also with indoc cial uh cell
markers we were uh quite successful in
identifying this cluster as uh phocytes
however uh what we were really hoping to
see uh is a cluster of uh different
clusters of different immune cells that
would point to uh to uh immune
infiltration uh or infiltration of
immune cells into the kid kidney however
when we uh looked at the uh at the um
markers of immune cells for example
monoy markers uh we saw that there were
almost uh no uh cells that expressed
these markers and also B cell markers we
did not see any almost no cells that
expressed these markers and
um these uh failings can be uh related
to the type of data that we are
investigating which is single nuclei
data which has been shown in the past uh
to be biased against uh catching um
immune cells different types of immune
cells at least in kidney uh tissue uh so
perhaps sorry to interrupt we're a
little bit running behind on
time um so I want wonder if we can wrap
up in another minute or less yes I'm
almost finished okay thank
you so of course for each uh for each
cluster whether it will be a cell type
or uh or just a cluster without a
specific cell type we can identify the
uh molecular Pathways uh that are either
activated or suppressed in covid-19
patients compared to the controls and
also we can uh try to identify the
differences in the cell populations
between control and disease States uh
which we also try to do here um so I
want to uh finally thank uh tabber
bioinformatics team and our
collaborators at Rosell Park and at
Georgetown University and special thanks
to Professor talber uh for um for his uh
support of our activi
and uh thank you for
listening thank you so much for that
wonderful talk Dr penov it was really
amazing to listen about so many new and
exciting applications of B informatics
and also thank you so much for all the
questions in the chat we have recorded
them and we would bring up all those
questions during our panel discussion so
moving on recently enough astrobiology
has been pretty much making the
headlines and the topics like origin of
life on Earth as well as the search for
Life on Mars are some of the most
exciting topics in this domain and it
gives me immense pleasure to welcome
Professor shilad Das sha who will be
talking about us extremophiles and the
search for Life on Mars Dr Das Sharma is
a pioneering microbiologist well known
for his contributions to the genomics
molecular biology and biotechnology of
Aria especially in the field of
astrobiology he earned his PhD degree in
Biochemistry from the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology and Bs degree in
chemistry from Indiana University
Bloomington prior to taking the faculty
position he conducted numerous
researches at the Massachusetts General
Hospital Howard medical school and P
Institute pahi
before joining The Institute of Marine
and environmental technology University
of Maryland school of medicine he was a
professor at the University of
Massachusetts Amherst and the University
of Maryland biotechnology
Institute he has over 150 scientific
Publications and years of mentorship
experience he is a founder of UMB GP
genomic track and is the UMP
institutional representative for the
systemwide me graduate program he is
also an affiliate research scientist at
Blue Marble space Institute of science
so without any further Ado let me
welcome Professor shilad Das Sharma over
to you
Professor thank you thank you very much
uh can you hear
me yeah we can hear you fine okay good
uh so
uh thank you very much for that kind
introduction and and uh as mentioned
we're going to be uh moving a little bit
away from uh some of the problems we
have here on Earth such as covid and and
cancer uh I wanted to share with you uh
in this slide a picture of the Earth
taken from Voyer one 30 years ago
actually 30 year years ago from
yesterday and here's here is the Earth
it's about 4 billion year uh mil mil
away and so everything that happens here
including our uh wearing of masks or
transmission of covid is uh put into
perspective in the
universe uh so we can leave the the
planet for at least a little bit uh and
we can think a little bit about uh the
new science of
astrobiology and
astrobiology is more than a science it's
almost a philosophy in some ways and
there are some uh obvious unanswered
questions that uh humans have uh thought
about for a long time and some of these
are uh what are the limits to life and
uh how did life even evolve on Earth and
uh in fact what is
life and are we alone how can we find if
life exists elsewhere so these are all
questions that astrobiologists ask and I
think that hopefully I can can convince
you during my talk that bioinformatics
is the tool that we need to answer some
of those
questions so um it's an
interdisciplinary science of you know
biology and astronomy and astrophysics
on the left uh there's some astronomical
numbers even from the biology side so uh
scientists have estimated the number of
cells on Earth as being greater than 10
the 30th which is actually uh greater
than the number of stars estimated in
the universe and almost all of these
cells are of course
procaryotes and these procaryotic cells
uh exist from the subsurface to the
stratosphere on Earth in fact a large
majority is estimated to be in the
subsurface and many of these uh cells
are extremophiles uh they live in
extreme environments on Earth uh not at
25 degrees uh in
uh as we do and these extremophiles go
by various names like thermophiles
methanogens halophiles Etc and these
cells in addition to providing us with
insight into astrobiology they've also
been very practically helpful in finding
uh resources or being resources for
biotechnology
and uh genomics and omix methods in
general have been very useful for
developing these biotechnological
resources uh on the Astro side uh there
are an estimated billion earthlike
planets in the universe so the question
of are we alone perhaps uh can be at
least considered from that perspective
it seems pretty unlikely and in fact
astronomers have been discovering
planets outside of our solar system
outside of the nine planets in the in
our solar system and have discovered
over 4,000 including several uh dozen uh
earthlike
planets and in fact I think uh you may
have heard in the news there's a lot of
excitement about a life finding mission
that was launched last year it's going
to take 10 years but March 2020 was the
beginning of that the perseverance Rover
was launched by by NASA uh landed on
Mars and is currently taking samples uh
searching for ancient life and with uh
the ultimate plan of returning samples
back to Earth for analysis perhaps some
metagenomic
analysis uh and then finally there's
also been discussions about whether life
might actually exist on Mars today
extent life if you will and uh the idea
is that uh if it exists this it would
probably be found in
Refuge uh such as in salt in Ice Caves
or even uh the
subsurface so while we don't know
whether life exists for sure elsewhere
we do know it exists here on Earth and
uh life on Earth has certain uh features
that I just want to briefly go through
um there's both a unity and also a
diversity of Life the the unity is that
all life on Earth is composed of the
sameeh six chemicals six elements CH H N
O P and S it all occurs in a H2O medium
and the biopolymers are all the same DNA
RNA proteins polysaccharides and lipids
although there are two different types
of
lipids and the molecular biology is
amazingly unified the central
Dogma characterizes the information flow
and the universal genetic code which was
discovered uh by uh my PhD Mentor uh a
corana and others uh really underscores
the unity of all life and in fact on the
right you can see the Luca the red ball
that's the original Last Universal
common ancestor and that must have had
this genetic code because all life on
Earth contains the same essential
genetic
code also the energy currency is all the
same ATP and the cellular membrane with
a proton motive
Force however we all know that there's a
huge diversity on Earth of life and in
fact most of that diversity is in
procaryotes in archa and bacteria uh of
course viruses as well
uh allow me to add that after the last
two uh three
presentations uh so there are an
estimated 10 to the 12 species of
procaryotic
cells and the uh arrows show the three
domain view of life and so the extent
life here on Earth are either eukaryotes
or and bacteria how these formed is
still in the realm of the unknown uh
they probably evolved pretty early after
the formation of the earth maybe about
four billion years ago and we really
don't know what happened during that
first half the first two billion or so
years but we know that there must have
been a cellular form that established
itself Luca and that cellular form had
the genetic code it had CH osmotic
coupling and then soon afterwards it
must have developed a genome and
developed metabolism like
phototrophy respiration photosynthesis
synthesis
Etc so how do we address uh these kinds
of questions what happened during the
first two billion years of our planet's
uh uh of life's
Evolution uh well uh one way is to study
these diverse extremophiles and I just
listed a few of these on this slide and
uh the first is are zero files these
grow in uh very dry places like the
atakama desert uh they they use very
little they need very little water for
survival cyrile such as uh one that I'll
be talking about Halo rubben like as
profundi is from Antarctica and can grow
at subzero
temperatures and it also ends up being
also a halophile which uh are uh
tolerant of very high salinity in fact
they can survive in uh salt that's uh
250 million years old and then there are
other uh limits to life that uh people
are studying such as uh alkal alkaline
conditions
alkalophilic
[Music]
crobial so fascinating that they were uh
one of the reasons why genomic
Technologies were developed and also
genomic Technologies were developed
using some of their uh molecules and so
this is a timeline taken from an ASM
news which is a precursor to microb that
you might be familiar with American
Society for microbiology it had actually
a fold out of the cover showing a
timeline of genome sequencing so
historically the first Genome of course
was in 1995 mouthless
influenza uh however the ones that are
boxed those are all extremophiles so you
can see in the first five or so years uh
about a third of the three dozen or so
genomes that were sequenced were
extremophilic genomes and that was
because of the extreme interest in uh
early Evolution origin of
life so uh we uh started our project
immediately after the hemophilus project
and it took us about five years to
complete it uh which may surprise some
of the students in the audience that it
took five years we published it in uh
just before uh 2001 and in October of
2000 and we had about uh 50 authors and
from 12 different
institutions so the organism uh that we
sequence Halo bacterium is a halophilic
archan and it is a poly extremophile
like most of these so not only is it a
able to grow in
saturating concentrations of salt it's
also able to tolerate long periods of
desiccation uh low oxygen tension um
High solar
Radiance and uh sometimes elevated or
freezing temperatures and the genome
sequence uh genome map behind it just
shows our first fold out genome that we
published in the proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences all of
these extremes are also present on uh
Mars uh there's no Oxygen really but
otherwise it's very similar so uh there
was a lot of interest right away in
whether these halophilic ARA
could survive
on on Mars excuse
me so um this is one of the figures that
we published an integrated view of the
biology and you can see it's it's
complex uh we were able to get
essentially a bird's eye view of the
biology of the organism and I would like
to go through some of the details during
the next few
minutes so one of the most interesting
results that we found was that the
proteins predicted by The genome were um
unimodal in distribution with respect to
their Pi or electronic uh ISO electric
Point uh the red uh Peak shows that the
halobacterium proteins are essentially
all very acidic uh they have a average
Pi of under five and uh that's in
contrast to all of the other organisms
which have a bodal distribution of
proteins both acidic and basic with a
essentially neutral proteome so why is
this well um because of the high
salinity inside of the cell there's
actually a reduced concentration of
water it's about 25% salt by weight and
what that does is it results in what's
uh you may know about is salting out so
the salts dissolve the water that causes
crowding of the proteins and then the
proteins would precipitate out uh the
way in which the cells uh or the
proteins prevent themselves from uh
precipitation is through mutual
repulsion caused by the surface negative
charges or the negative charges on the
protein so here is a structure of a
protein that we've been studying for a
few years now it's a it's a family 42
beta galacti sidas and uh you can see
the red acidic and blue basic residues
and in comparison to a non-halophilic
thermos thermophilus enzyme and uh I
think you can see that there are more
red and fewer blue and in fact the
charge on the Halo archal protein is
aboutus 65 as opposed to minus 4 for the
thermos protein so this allows both
Mutual repulsion and also um uh binding
more tightly to uh the Water that's
available so if you look at the activity
of proteins like this they're of
interest from a biotechnological
perspective uh the proteins can function
usually optimally function in close to
saturated uh sodium chloride or
pottassium chloride
concentrations and as a result of their
tight binding to water they can also uh
function in organic solvents so this is
a very unusual and interesting and
potentially useful property that may be
used for uh development of new
catalysts another uh interesting result
from our first genome was that uh the
three domain view of life was
essentially confirmed so the the tree
it's an unrooted Tree of Life using uh
the small ribosomal RNA this was
pioneered by Carl W uh showed that um
the hypothesis was that uh procaryotes
are divided into two uh the ARA and the
bacteria and they are distinct from the
higher organisms that ukar on the left
on the
bottom on the left uh tree however uh we
do see the same uh three domains of life
however there's some interesting uh
differences uh the purple uh circle is
showing the halophile the halophile here
seems to be a branch of a methanogen
here however over here the halophile is
coming out much closer to the root what
would be considered the root of the tree
if you had rooted it so the Halo
bacterium actually changes its position
it's it has a dynamic philogyny if you
will and uh
the we did some additional work with
this looking at different bacteria and
uh in this case we took a cab bacterium
dakus
radiodurans and uh a uh ilus and we
found that halobacterium is this deeply
branching Halo branching archon excuse
me however if you use basilis pomonis
and eoli it actually becomes a bacterium
so why is that well it turns out that
there are a whole lot of bacterial genes
in our halobacterium genome right here
and uh more than in any of the other
ARA similarly there are some bacteria
over here which have archal genes
thermatoga is one of these so these
types of findings raise the issue that
not all genes in a particular organism
are original originally from
that lineage and some of them have been
inherited not by vertical uh
transmission but by horizontal
transmission so these are presumably
horizontally transferred genes so those
are pretty interesting uh results that
we got early on uh and I've been doing
bioinformatics for a long time so uh
this that really went back to the last
century and I had to show you this uh
these uh figure from NIH
showing uh the different generations of
uh genome sequencing there so the genome
sequencing cost has been of concern for
a long time and it's been going down
quite fast and in electronics we know of
the mores law said reduction every every
two years and that happened with uh
Sanger sequencing for a while and then
of course uh Illumina and a whole bunch
of other genome sequencing methods came
up second uh same gen and uh although
the costs dropped the quality also
wasn't quite the same as with Sanger and
then now we have the third gen and the
cost according to the
latest from is uh down to
$1,000 per human genome so of course for
a micro genome that's even much less and
here is a figure from gold showing that
there are something like 350,000
procaryotic genomes in the database at n
ncbi now so as soon as there were more
genomes available and we also
contributed some additional genomes we
started doing something that Roman
tatusov uh initiated at NH and that was
uh reciprocal blasting so this was idea
was to take one protein from a genome
and blast it against a second one and do
the reciprocal blast as well so this is
computationally intensive but it results
in some very interesting results which
is that you find what are called
reciprocal best hits and those
reciprocal best hits allow you to form
clusters of proteins or orth orthologous
groups called cogs we did this for the
Halo ARA and found that there are about
800 uh Core protein so these are
proteins that have presumably the same
function
they're orthologues in the two different
organisms and you can see that
many however there are some that are
poorly characterized or even that
they're no associated in this case no
Associated
bacterial uh clusters of orthologous
groups so these are essentially
signature genes that means these
proteins are present in all the Halo
archa but nothing
else so they are in fact a signature of
how these organisms perhaps
survive then there's the concept of the
Pang genome so there are many other
genes or proteins which are not found in
all of the genomes in fact the largest
number are unique and if you look at
that of The
4400 H archal orthologous groups uh
about 3400 or 3600 are in the pangenome
so this is the total Gene content and
that is the most interesting part
because that's in the realm of the
unknown
so uh we wanted to get or into more
detail uh analysis of the genomes of
these organisms and uh as several have
mentioned It's a combination of both
experimental and
bioinformatic I'm not going to be able
to go into the details but just give you
a couple of uh examples of what we've
done so the physiology of hilar is very
interesting from the standpoint of uh
growth in different concentrations of
oxygen and also with light they photo
phosphorate because they have these
membrane pumps that pump protons and
allow the cells to produce ATP they can
also grow uh by both aerobic and
anerobic respiration and they also have
substrate level phosphorilation so
they're able to tolerate different
concentrations of oxygen and these
properties again I won't be able to go
into in detail but they're very unique
and uh useful so for instance when
they're photo uh photo growing
phototrophically uh they produce these
intracellular nanop particles called gas
vesicles which allow them to float and
we're using these nanop particles as a
vehicle for vaccines and for drug
delivery uh then these purple membrane
patches are also being used for a
variety of other uh biotechnological
applications but with regard to
bioinformatics we initiated
transcriptomic analysis during the DNA
micro Ray uh era and we for instance
tested the uh gene expression under
anerobic respiration versus aerobic
respiration fermentation versus aerobic
respiration or anerobic respiration
versus fermentation and we saw changes
in different genes and to make a long
story short if you look on the right uh
essentially the cells are have a
hierarchy of responses from uh aerobic
respiration uh when the Redux goes down
it goes to uh vectr opsin based
phototrophy
um then at a lower Redux uh if the
there's a certain uh compounds available
for anerobic respirations like DMSO tmao
in some cases nitrate or even proc
chlorate they can uh Survive by Anor
robic respiration and if there's um if
there are no uh terminal electron
acceptors at all but there are some
substrates like Arginine they can still
survive through fermentation so they're
quite versatile organisms in this way
the other very interesting property of
Halo ARA is that um they are incredibly
radiation resistant so you can see here
the The Killing curves uh they're almost
as uh tolerant as dakus radiodurans in
terms of UV light and uh they're able to
repair EV light with the photo lias uh
and I won't go into the details in this
figure but basically they have a photo
lias that allows them to rep do direct
photo repair they also have a uvr ABC uh
to repair do dark repair of UV damage
and so here again we've mutated the uh
EVR ABC and you can see that the uh
cells are not able to survive and we
could do transcriptional or we did do
transcriptomic results and we could see
which Gene uh genes are actually
affected by UV light and you can see
it's a very small number so the S system
is very highly
developed uh in terms of being able to
uh survive UV light but um it does not
seem to resemble the bacterial SOS type
response and then uh Hill archia are
also resistant to ionizing radiation and
this was a bit of a surprise although
ionizing radiation of course results in
double stranded breaks uh and that is
something that they probably have to
deal with when they are desiccated
because desiccation also results in that
so the the uh gel on the left shows you
after ionizing radiation The genome
becomes broken into about 20 pieces and
then after one or two generations they
Stitch that back together and they're
perfectly
fine so we went through a uh experiment
where we treated with a killing dose of
uh ionizing radiation in this case we
use linac uh and then we allowed them to
recover and we did this three or four
times and then we isolated mutants and
tested their ability to tolerate
ionizing radiation and what we found is
very interesting shown here which is the
uh survival fraction increased quite
dramatically so these are the the mut
mutant that had survived these multiple
rounds of uh killing Doses and you can
see that they're actually more resistant
than dakus rated Duran so they also have
a very interesting way of uh being able
to tolerate ionizing radiation and our
transcriptomic results showed that they
upregulate only one operon and that
codes for a eukaryotic type of single
stranded DNA binding protein so we've
done some additional work on this to
show that overexpression of these
proteins actually results in increased
radiation resistance so this may be of
interest uh going forward as we consider
sending uh astronauts to
Mars so
finally uh the last thing I want to tell
you about is are some experiments to see
whether Halo ARA could actually survive
on Mars so the closest we could get to
Mars was an Earth's stratosphere and
this is basically showing uh the
atmospheric pressure ozone uh H2O and
temperature uh higher in this in the
atmosphere this a troposphere the the
stratosphere is maybe 30 kilometers up
it's very similar to Mars up there there
are to the surface of Mars uh the
temperatures are similar has similar EV
flux elevated cosmic rays electrons
protons very low pressure and it's very
dry so we did an experiment with
collaborators in
California uh where we sent cultures by
airplane to California from which uh
point that they launched them into the
stratosphere and then they recovered it
and then they sent it back to us for
analysis so uh again to make a long
story short we we tested two different
Hill Arch here uh the H laus profundi
which I mentioned before is a uh cold
adapted organism actually was isolated
from uh Antarctica and our lab strain
nrc1 and you can see that after the
balloon flight um there is survival in
both cases however if you look at the uh
the difference here uh nrc1 uh sorry uh
Halo Rubin laundi versus nrc1 you can
see that the halub lais profundi is
better able to survive uh stratospheric
condition so this one would presumably
do better on Mars and the reasons for
that are in the paper and again I'm
going to have to skip over it but I
encourage you to go and take a
look and very fun thing is that there
are a lot of perchlorate salts these
very uh oxidizing salts which are
actually used for uh oxidizer for Rocket
Fuel uh on the surface of Mars uh it's
very tox toxic of course to most living
organisms but it turns out that uh Halo
bacteria are able to surv tolerate them
pretty well and in fact with Halo ruum
they're actually able to grow using
perchlorate as the terminal electronic
sceptor so we also have transcriptomic
results from these
experiments so um finally uh I just want
to leave you with uh the picture of uh
NASA and Isa and also the Chinese uh
Space
Administration they're all going to uh
Mars uh NASA and Issa are collaborating
on this uh Mars 2020 as I mentioned uh
is currently has has delivered
perseverance Rover and Ingenuity the
helicopter to the surface of Mars you
may have seen some spectacular pictures
they're drilling samples so this is a
pretty elaborate um set of plans here's
the Earth here's
Mars so this Rover is on Mars it's
collecting samples it's going to collect
samples from several different places in
a in a a an ancient river Delta called
uh
jezero and it's going to put these
samples in in various places to be
picked up by a second Rover which is
going to deliver it to a spot from which
it will be returned back to Earth and
it's going to uh uh I believe it's going
to be analyzed in a laboratory in the US
and um so we may very well be able to
learn whether there was ever Life on
Mars uh this particular Mission which
will take as I said 10 years is going to
be uh uh for ancient life so the River
delta is a place where they would find
sediments that might have uh preserved
some uh signatures of
life however uh some of us at uh have
gone to NASA meetings where there's also
discussions about other missions to look
for extent life and uh there are four
areas where uh scientists feel that
there may in fact be extent Life on Mars
uh that includes uh ice both polar and
midlatitude ice
uh salt deposits which of course is of
of great interest to us uh and also
subsurface such as in lava tubes uh
caves and then there are a lot of people
who are very interested in the Deep
subsurface there's a lot of water in the
Deep of surface about a kilometer below
the surface of Mars and so um there may
in fact be some uh extent organisms that
might be found there of course you have
to drill down a kilometer to get to that
location and by the way if they were
there the subsurface water is also
extremely salty so um they would
probably also be
halophiles so um then I just want to
conclude by saying that uh astrobiology
is I think a very interesting new
science uh with some very good practical
applications and the need for
bioinformatics and it's informed at the
present time until we get samples from
Mars by many extremophilic forms on here
on
Earth um The genome sequencing in the
omix revolution have provided insights
into the limits of Life of these
extremophilic forms our Focus has been
the Halo
ARA uh but um these and other
extremophilic genomes have led to
Concepts like uh how proteins can
function in uh extreme conditions
horizontal Gene transfers and evolution
of life and core and Pang
genomes and then halar here adapted to
polyextremophilic conditions including
the ones that I just uh discussed about
uh low oxygen High radiation cold
temperatures and uh Pro proc chlorates
and halophiles are considered as a model
microbes uh for survival in Martian
stressors and just finally uh asob
biology is fascinating however uh we
also need to make a living here on Earth
so I just want to mention that um there
are some real Revolutions in
biotechnology including of course uh the
discovery of thermostable polymerases
which was uh probably the biggest uh
development however there are many
others such as the ones I've listed up
here
so I just want to end there and uh thank
uh the organizers and and uh the
audience for your attention and uh there
have been uh our lab has been in
operation since
1986 so we've had a lot of people who've
gone through the lab I especially want
to thank uh priia desarma who has been a
close collaborator for 30 years and uh
and uh all of the other lab members and
of course the funding has been uh
absolutely essential for our work and uh
right now we have funding from NASA and
NIH and uh in the past we've had quite a
lot of funding from NSF and if you're
interested in our genomes I encourage
you to go to our website which is halo.
umbc.edu so I'll stop there and uh I
don't know if there time for questions
but I'd be happy to answer
them thank
you thank you Dr
desarma um it was great to tour the
cosmos with you and I guess now I'll
just try to bring everyone back to Earth
so that we can address questions that
people may have and also try to uh
discuss all of the great points that our
panelists brought to us today I would
like to thank you to thank the four uh
the four speakers that uh spoke in this
session I will now start leading or
trying to uh moderate a discussion
section between among the four
panelists um so the first thing that
I'll do is I'll try to I'll do my best
to summarize the four uh the four talks
that we had uh in this
session um try to uh see what there is
in common what overlaps there are and
how we can
benefit uh the B informaticians that are
uh watching us here and how we can uh
stimulate I think a uh community
Community uh that is open to Foster
collaboration and to talk about science
and develop this field of B informatics
so in the first talk we heard about
mathematical modeling of an interplay
between uh FL Flav viruses and their
natural defective genomes the second
part uh was about reconstructing uh
Dynamic a dynamic potential for objects
with observations of multiple features
data like single cell expr
in for differentiation of cells aging of
organisms and how omic and biomedical
data is used to understand metagenomics
and uh how that can be uh also applied
for what Dr uh broadsky uh told us very
very well very interestingly the H Hypes
and uh Hypes of different um
viruses and
phenomics uh in the second talk of of Dr
R Andino we had uh mathematical modeling
for public health uh we have a very
interesting uh talk where he led us
through the the use of different btics
uh techniques and models to understand
also many aspects of uh genomic
variation in the in
the viral in the viral genetic material
particularly uh we are all interested
here in the current pandemic so the the
these mutations and
the the role the biological role that
these mutations May uh uh have in uh for
instance
um uh the spread and specificity between
the A2 receptor and the spike protein in
the first I am talking obviously about
the about the star CO2 virus and then uh
the the third in the third talk we had a
very great description of single cell
sequencing and also the application of
numerous uh B
informatics uh tools in the in the
platform that is available uh by uh Pine
biotech and that was that by do by Dr
Julia panov finally we had Dr the Sharma
uh lead us through this very interesting
Tour on extremal files and astrobiology
there there's a a a huge uh field for
disc discussion in my opinion about the
biotechnological applications of both
viruses extremal files uh uh single cell
sequencing and also the algorithms for
uh studying all of these
uh all of these
subjects so these uh these are uh we
have a common molecular biology
background in all of these fields but at
the same time we are talking about very
different fields of application
therefore uh different kinds of back of
backgrounds different kinds of people
are necessary to advance and uh Prov and
provide the benefits uh in areas such
such as medicine computer science and
communication we have seen in the in the
past year how communication information
and education Industries adopted adapted
quickly to the reality of uh distancing
that is that was imposed by the sar2
pandemic from this adapation exercise we
see that uh there needs to be uh an
effort uh due to the we see that that
clearly because of the pandemic and that
has not ended yet in many countries and
we see that we all all we all need to
have some sort of adaptation to a
technology driven word or
culture so this Dynamic imposes a need
for education and here we are uh talking
we want to talk about B informatics
education a need for collaboration and
also need for uh communication so I
wanted to uh again introduce our
speakers Dr Rahul Andino is a uh
microbiologist and immunologist at the
University of California San Francisco
uh Dr Le Leonid Brodsky is a professor
of bioinformatics and biostatistics and
the director of the talber bionformatics
research center at the University of hia
Israel Dr chilaia the Sharma is a
professor at the Institute of Marine and
environmental technology at the
University of Maryland school of
medicine and Julia Dr Julia panov is an
associate director for the tabber
bioinformatics research center in Israel
I hope that the panelists will provide
us with their perspective on how to
navigate this changing Dynamic of data
and algorithms in biological research so
uh I have some general questions here
but where is all of this data Revolution
taking us and how what have we learned
from the pandemic what have we learned
that we need to adapt to this uh to this
word that is more and more computational
driven I can start just break the eyes
here here but just say just say that um
you know I think your your question is
uh directed to an answer so I'm gonna
try to get that answer and that is you
know the pandemic demonstrated that um
is important to uh collaborate and
integrate and you can start seeing now
papers that has 30 out authors on it and
I think it that's interesting um you
know I don't know exact ly what is the
reason for this to happen but in my
personal experience pandemic has been
very disruptive but disrupted um in a
positive sense you know it make us stop
doing what we were doing and start
focusing on a different problem and
starting to interact with people that
normally don't work in
virology and that has been a tremendous
um experience for us you know at least
two or three new collaborators that I
would never thought I would collaborate
with um it was important now how this
omix um you know gets there is what
we've been discussing uh before I think
that the important thing and I think in
in part the pine biotech uh platform
help us to do that is to have a friendly
interface in which
uh
informaticians and
experimentalists can converge I think at
the end of the day you know like it
happened to me with Leon having a coffee
in a nice place uh it it has you know
tremendous um effect transformative
effect but I think having a platform an
interface that is friendly for both
experimentalism and and and um
informaticians is the next step in which
this information can be exchanged using
you know on the the situation that we
are right now that maybe we're not able
to trouble as much as we used
to yeah so the if I could jump in for
for a minute um so to me the difference
between bioinformatics and and biology
is sort of semantic because the real
difference is between data and
knowledge and um both bioinformatics and
experimental work can lead to data but
we need to transform that into our
understanding whether it be covid or the
evolution of life and so I think a
meeting like this is really very very
nice to have people looking at
everything from cancer neology obviously
we're all concerned about Co and it's
the overriding concern AC around the
world um but as I mentioned the uh Tom
Brock uh just uh do was doing Discovery
Science by going to Yellowstone and
looking at uh you know thermal ponds for
microbes and isolated thermos aquaticus
from which we purifi uh Tac plim race
and and then you know Carrie Mullis and
all
uh developed PCR and uh you know it
maybe maybe PCR is not as important for
sequencing but it has been for very long
and it's probably still going to be
critical for Diagnostics so that's where
the interdisciplinary
collaboration is so important I think
and especially going forward because
there's so much
potential can I add uh to that talk so
you mentioned T plas how it has been so
important for the development of
sequencing uh back in the day when
Sanger was more used than now um and you
can see there how uh these extremal
files are very important for other areas
and I was I also wanted to highlight for
instance the isolation of uh reever
reverse
transcriptases from viruses so uh
transforming for instance uh RNA into
cdna and being able to sequence that is
is on I'm not entirely sure if it's
correct to say that that it's only
possible because there are uh
virologists that developed the
understanding and the basic
understanding of molecular
biology uh on uh the virus and how they
use their enzymes and all of these uh
processes so this
really this is key nowadays for us to be
able to sequence RNA for us to be able
to look at uh gene expression just like
uh uh uh Julia looks at uh RNA RNA RNA
seek uh and I think many many of you
also uh do other sorts of of sequencing
as
well
right if if I can jump in again I'm
sorry uh so so in addition I think there
are technologies that maybe are are
considered old now but they were the
main state of uh molecular biology like
restriction
enzymes uh you know Nathan and Smith won
and Arbor won the Nobel Prize for that
in the 1970s and it was the reason why
we have molecular biology today it would
not have been possible and of course
more recently they they're Crispers and
all of those came about through
discoveries uh resulting from
virologists and
microbiologist interested in different
types of
microbes and uh analyzing their biology
and or in the example that you gave uh
Gio on uh the reverse transcriptases and
David Baltimore and people like that so
yeah so I think that that it's it's
really uh important to be able to do the
basic science on what is I consider a
natural resource I mean the the microbes
and the viruses that are out there I
know that some of them cause disease but
they're really a natural resource and
they have so many amazing molecules and
features that we can then utilize for
various uh useful applications if I if I
can jump as well not to um kidnap the
discussion but I want to emphasize uh
the thing because um to me it's obvious
and I think for all every scientist it's
obvious that what the reason why we are
at this stage here is because you
know has played an important role in
advancing science nobody could
anticipate that somebody study yogurt
we'll discover crisper right and um and
I think the wonderful uh ideas to look
in the
microorganism world because there's a
lot of information there in my mind the
problem in this is gets a little
political here but I think the problem
is that the people that are leaders in
science right now they are trying to
save as much money as possible and
demonstrate that the money money that is
invested in science every dollar result
in an important result in a paper and
that is completely wrong I think the
science has to be wasted the money has
to be wasted in science 95% of the money
should go doing good science but most of
these result should not result in
anything except to say my idea was wrong
that's what poer you know will say you
know you the only thing you can do is
prove yourself wrong but the 5% that
does not result in something negative
will pay for everything 10
times and I think that's is such an
important concept and we need to appeal
to the Congress appeal to the leaders
and say come on you guys invest in fages
invest in bacteria you know do that kind
of things because you don't you don't
know what's going to be the brilliant
mind coming out with a new algorithm
[Music]
so talking about uh how we have
generated so much data in the past years
I think we have developed a lot the
molecular biology and the biochemistry
and all of these what I call wet lab
experiments and now there's so much data
out there uh I think we are really at
the point and uh I think Ayah was uh
sharing earlier today how I I came to my
PhD program without B informatics
background without a programming
background um and I realized during my
studies how important it is to develop
these uh coding skills these B
informatics skills uh as a scientist as
a student so I wanted to ask uh Dr broy
uh what do you think are important
uh how do how do you think a person that
does not have necessarily a background
in mathematics or statistics or uh
programming how can how can we uh
develop
uh that that important background which
is the ability to look at data that has
already being generated that is sitting
maybe on uh databases that can be
accessed for instance now we have the G
database which has uh I think at this
point it should be like three million uh
sequencing files available for uh covid
uh SAR
cov2 and uh we have uh databases such as
tcga the gene expression onnibus and uh
there are initiatives in the United
States in Europe and in Japan that store
these data that that have been produced
along these years and uh how how can we
gain more uh experience on analyzing
this
data okay um from my perspective uh
there are two actually
major uh major directions to do
that uh one is
um New Opportunities which new
technologies computation Technologies
are giving us for instance just recently
this uh Google uh artificial
intelligence-based prediction of protein
structures generation of millions of
protein
structures this is completely new
opportunity for us and which can be used
another thing is
uh is uh interface
human friendly user interface so with
friendly user
interface uh any theoretically any
person any biologist or any student can
operate with databases and with
sophisticated algorithms in natural way
as rul
said actually this this is a way for
normal to collaborate actually to
because uh previously uh biologist is
just just asking a informatician to do
computational work uh and this is
problematic because uh the this
bioinformatician doesn't know biology or
not interested in the project and and so
on
if the biologist itself can work
themselves can work with with a platform
with some computational platform and
do his analysis computational analysis
himself it will be great and uh actually
uh the same approach in education I
think is also very
promising so this combination of New
Opportunities from computational
Technologies and uh user friendly
interface interface between computer and
and human uh are
two key features for for for Success so
say for success in education and success
in even in
research thank you uh Julia do you want
to
add something
okay I was just going to uh say Yes um
it is very important to have the coding
skills I would say to be able to analyze
and process uh sequencing data and I was
going to I also wanted to ask how how is
it I don't know if any you have uh any
experience in uh maybe Julia you have a
little bit of experience in uh providing
the the tools for the
user providing the the tool that the
user is going to run their analysis in
how is uh and I don't know if you have
uh coding
background so so my uh so maybe I'll
answer H so my background is in
neurobiology and I have been doing
bioinformatics uh work and analyzing
data uh providing tools for the user uh
uh requires I think again uh
collaboration of many parties uh
collaboration of software Engineers on
one side mathematicians who actually
come up with
algorithms uh and also uh biologists who
will be the end user of this tool and
who will uh try to use it and fail many
times before this tool becomes actually
uh usable and uh user friendly so from
our experience at least uh it takes a
while uh from the tool to become uh
actually user friendly and of course uh
another uh important aspect I think uh
is being able to communicate uh to the
end user how uh exactly this tool is
supposed to be used uh giving him enough
uh not only just information or guides
but also examples of uh uh projects and
questions that this tool or this a
number of tools um that we call pipeline
uh can answer uh in different
combinations of course uh
so from from my experience from our
experience it seems like uh it's again a
question of
collaboration uh good communication
between different uh people and with
different expertise that sometimes speak
different
languages uh so um so also uh combining
everybody together uh is is another
challenge that has to be met before The
Tool becomes really uh
usable uh and becomes uh becomes
something that other people can actually
use perfect uh I think I should uh take
I would like to add uh in relation to
education uh that actually this is
self-education is becoming
self-education this is a project this is
a flexible platform and the user which
is trying to to to solve the problem
with the platform how to make the
platform flexible and which will cover
all all possible aspects of the project
this this is a question for the
RO perfect thank you so much uh I I
generally try to make uh connections
possibly where people do not see so I I
find it really interesting that Dr
desarma uh uh works with astrobiology
and the development of Life uh on Earth
uh as a result from the the interaction
of Earth with the cosmos and I find
really interesting how uh previous
to
uh how molecules evolve to form uh form
a cell and it's really interesting that
uh Julia you work with single cell
sequencing and how that uh is
informative about the interaction of uh
of virus with uh human cells so there is
a question here about uh single cell
sequencing
what uh I think we should give some
background to uh the maybe the
comparisions of single cell and book RNA
sequencing uh someone asked uh how does
the PIP how do how do pipelines for
analysis of single cell RNA sequencing
differs from book RNA
sequencing okay so maybe uh I can take
that and so yeah the pipelines uh differ
actually quite a lot uh in bulk RNA
sequencing you're dealing usually with
uh up to hundreds of samples at one time
uh I haven't seen a lot of uh projects
that deal with thousands and when you uh
analyze the single cell or single nuclei
data uh of course each cell is
considered a um sample uh so uh you have
thousands if not tens of thousands uh of
of uh cells uh which also come in bulk
so there is a big question of
normalization of uh data and uh and um
batch correction between different
donors for example uh and different uh
preparation methods uh of the actual uh
samples uh so uh and also single cell or
single nucle um uh sequencing can be
divided into two parts the first part is
actually getting to the uh expression
table uh which is uh much more
complicated because you have uh these
barcodes and depending on the uh
technology actually used and machines
for sequencing actually used you either
have only cell barcodes or you have
barcodes um M barcodes that uh are for
cells and barcodes for um each mRNA so
this is one uh problem that or challenge
that needs to be addressed uh and then
of course uh different challenges uh
remain such as uh batch correction and
normalization of data between samples
between and when here I mean samples is
just donors or um or tissues and uh and
um and then um a big bottleneck and a
challenge is annotation of different
cell types uh or different clusters of
cell actually understanding what these
cells are uh is another uh challenge uh
that does not exist in bulk
RNA okay thank you so much another
question that I saw in the chat was for
Dr desarma uh what how can we transfer a
uh a a gene from um how can you transfer
extremophile Gene in a heterogeneous
system I guess the question is how can
we clone the gene in in malan cell for
instance right um so uh there's actually
uh that's actually fairly
straightforward because the um most of
the extremophilic uh genes don't have
introns and they're pretty
straightforward to
express um the I think uh the more
difficult thing is to set up a genetic
system in the extremophile which is what
we were able to do with the Halo archon
but um in terms of expressing proteins
in either in eoli or in Maman cells they
use the same genetic code they are uh
maybe the proteins are more
acidic I but the Pang genome provides uh
genes that are not present anywhere else
so whether you're doing
metagenomics or whether you're doing
single cell genomics or whether you're
doing uh more traditional classical
genome sequencing the genes that you
obtain are potentially valuable and um
you you you uh addressed that point a
bit earlier and I was just thinking then
that it used used to be that students it
was necessary for students to generate
data to
analyze of course I'm talking about the
last century so pardon my my age but um
you know um there are just there's just
such an avalanche of data and this is
why we're talking about
bioinformatics um what I'm afraid of is
with 10 to the 12 cells and the
continuing decrease in uh in sequencing
technology and also development of of
meta sequencing and metatranscriptomics
and so on the the uh the rate of
production of data is not going to
decline so it just becomes really
important for how we're going to uh sort
through all of this data to convert it
into useful products and into knowledge
and so one of those is to express
proteins and there have been projects
even at NIH in the
past uh of trying to identify the
functions of unknown genes by uh a
pipeline of
expression but those projects have not
uh maybe maybe uh rul might know better
about it I have not seen those types of
projects continuing and it just it
bothers me because there is just such a
resource it's a natural
resource that's out there for the taking
but we need to allow students to come in
and sort through it and pick through it
and find what's useful and express that
in a Mamon cell or Yeast or
wherever if I jump I can jump a minute
to comment on a couple things you know
one is something that um you said um
shilia
about
information um could yield very
beautiful pictures and complex pictures
that impress people but doesn't
necessarily takes you closer to
knowledge um and the connection to
knowledge is is is so important this
this exercise having a clear path and
you know to understand and um go through
this data to really learn something new
and that's something that um Julia chass
say that I I really like is um you
getting data from different Pati and you
need to normalize that right and that is
because this issue of noise is so
relevant in bioinformatics there is
millions and millions of sequence but
those sequences do not represent the
same thing because the sequence were
obtained um differently from different
patients uh with different platform the
technical noise and the biological noise
could really impede to see the signal
and I I would challenge you know all our
young audience here that I the the in
biology but in science in general in
order to see something what you need to
do is reduce the noise if you want to
see a start and a telescope you need to
polish your lens such that there is no
imperfections on the imag so you can
recognize a new start I think it's the
same thing here you need to get noise to
ratio no no noise to Signal ratios in a
way that allows you to see the things
that you want to see sometimes you need
to know what you're looking for um but
um I think this issue of noise is is
critical and I I think is part of this
exercise in BIO formatics the other
thing I wanted to just mention is that
I'm so pleased to be part of this panel
because in a way it's very different
group of people working in very
different things but there is common
things which is
um often we study viruses and we learn
something is using for used for
sequencing often we study bacteria and
we learn something else that was very
useful for something else and I think
that is a you know over theme here I
would say you know this idea of H
beneficial
microorganisms is a very fertile ground
for bioinformatics and to learn that and
the last thing I wanted to say sometimes
when I was very young I was very um
afraid of approaching people that had
been established and they you know run
centers and they handle millions of
dollars or whatever but I have a message
for the young people here don't be
afraid we are eager to contact you eager
to work with you e eager to um uh um
collaborate in a way learn together I
think that would be great if you know if
this happen in this Symposium that would
be successful right signal of
success let me add that in my from my
perspective bioinformatics is becoming
threedimensional
structural things are extremely
important for instance this blasto story
which you know presented as orol through
blast could be threedimensional blast
local similarities which may be also
very important yeah and to deal with
huge amount of threedimensional
structures which are generated by
artificial intelligence programs this is
a challenge
again okay I think we need to move on to
the next uh next SE session uh I would
like to thank so much all of our
panelists uh Dr Leonid bris Brodsky
provided us with a great understanding
of how mathematical mathematics can be
used to model uh by informatics and how
we can with that approach we can think
about decreasing the number of
experiments that we can actually that we
need to actually do to uh address bi
biological questions uh Dr Ra rul Gino
provided us with uh great information
about um uh mutations and the study of
mutations in the genomes of various
viruses and also the collection and
storage of uh sequencing data in
sequency information on these viruses Dr
Julia P panov also provided us with
great guidance on uh single cell uh
sequencing and the development of bi b
TR atics Tools to assist in the
visualization and Analysis of uh uh
several uh sequencing projects finally
Dr uh the Sharma provided us with great
information about astrobiology and how
that has guided our uh understanding or
begin to understanding the origin of
life on Earth so right now I will move
to the next session which is going to be
uh a discussion on uh some of the work
that I do as a mentor in uh in another
program that uh has some collaboration
with fine
biotech uh am I going to I need to share
my slides now right yes so I just
briefly again thank you for all the
panelists and uh this is actually going
to be a um the the final part of today
and so I do want to mention that
tomorrow we will have a chance to hear
from uh some of the next steps and and
more practical ways of how uh many of
the students that we are interacting
with can get involved in meaningful
projects using bionformatics tools
communicating with mentors uh finding
out interesting projects and and this
transition uh part of today's session is
going to kind of uh build the
expectation on how we move from just
learning about these exciting fields to
practically you know what a student or
somebody who's beginning to be involved
in this domain uh could actually do
practically so uh thank you Gio uh we'll
have just briefly I'll just uh kind of
mention what's the plan we will have uh
G Dr Gano Chavez speak about the Sip
program and the mentorship and we
have Miss urja Park uh speak about her
experience uh being mentored and
participating in astrobiology as well as
other types of research and Mr subit
perua will speak about his astrobiology
Endeavors and uh what he is up to next
and then finally I will conclude with
some perspective on uh the omx logic
research Fellowship on how you can get
involved in some of the topics that we
discuss today as a contributor as a
mentor and as someone that can help us
build out a pathway for students to get
involved in a meaningful way so please
go ahead Joo thank
you thank you
IIA do you see my
screen yes okay perfect all right so um
because of the work that the science
internship program has developed over
the years in at the University of
California I want to talk about this
issue with with
inequalities and uh I generally use it
to think about inequalities in the
context of of the own my own country
Brazil I I come from Brazil so I uh in
front of you is a picture that I I grew
up watching so in the right we see uh
few people with a lot and in the left we
see a lot with very little uh this is in
Brazil this is due to
historical for histo historical
reasons and so I think that education
represents really a way that we have to
uh counterbalance inequalities that we
have in the countries I was kind of
surprised when I realize that there are
inequalities in the United States as
well because we all here of the United
States as the number one economy and
things like that um but there are there
have to be politics to address
inequality issues in the UN in in
developed countries as well as in
developing countries so uh I have this
question of what are the boundaries
between science and education because
when I was growing up I really did not
see a clear boundary or a clear clear
limit between uh science and education
so in my mind up to a point I did not
think that there was a difference
between what is science and what is
education so I guess for the sake of
Simplicity here I am just assuming that
science and education are the same thing
maybe you do not agree with me that's
okay uh but just for the sake of
Simplicity and uh the context that I
come from uh because uh in my country uh
in many situations in many occasions you
can
pursue uh an educational career but uh
but reaching to a faculty position or
reaching to uh a position in Academia
can be something really really
challenging and as as as you may imagine
uh there have there there can be uh many
mechanisms of privilege in a situation
like Brazil so what I want to say here
is that uh this program science Without
Borders is the is a program that was
launched by the government of Brazil
about 10 years ago and the political uh
social and economic situation uh at that
moment was completely different from
what it is nowadays from what it is
today in Brazil I'm talking specifically
about
Brazil uh but what happens is that there
is a need for the countries to invest in
sciences and in genomic Sciences
specifically so what happens last what
happened last year was that the
government of Brazil has launched this
uh program called uh programma genomas
Brazil and what the goal of this program
is is to sequence uh 1,000 Brazilian
Nationals
uh Brazil has this particular particular
feature of being the result of the uh
mixing of three different three main
different populations Europeans Africans
and uh Native Americans so there is an
interest uh in understanding how that
has how that has an impact in
understanding disease uh in the country
so what uh the interest is right now in
the country is um to to uh stimulate the
sequencing of Brazilian
Nationals but this brings a problem
because uh sequencing Technologies are
really really
expensive and uh Brazil is not a rich
country it's not a developed country so
sequencing 1,000 Brazilians uh
represents a problem because there is a
chance that uh we are not going to
represent the entire population we are
not going to uh we're not going to have
uh kids or uh scientists from a disadv
economically disadvantaged background
involved in this process so uh in my
mind the problem uh that we have right
now in the country is that we need to
make science we need to make
education uh reach many of these
different uh layers of society I to
totally agree with Dr Andino when he
says that we need to make science
available for uh all of the population
both uh young scientists and scientists
that are more seniors but uh I really
think that uh what we need to do in in
Brazil for instance is a uh mindset in
the education educational uh culture we
need to uh more and more make science
projects available for students in in
Brazil and this uh this is with the hope
that it will will will end up helping
the public health system to make
education educated uh decisions based on
the genetic background of the population
of Brazil specifically so this uh in my
opinion this overlaps very well with the
mission of the University of California
Santa Cruz because in 2001 the human
genome sequence was published in part
due to the efforts of UCSC researchers
here I'm basically talking about uh Dr
David Hoster who um who is considered uh
to be to have played a very important
role in uh in in sequencing the human
genome but also the the other program
that I have also been involved with is
the science internship program this I
have been served as a mentor in this
program for six more than six years at
this point uh and it aims to Foster the
involvement of high school students in
science uh this program was funded uh
funded in 2009 by Dr Raja gatura who is
also a professor at UCSC both both of
these initiatives the genomic research
and sip grow every
year in fact we are just having a
conversation with the genomics Institute
to design a bioinformatics course for uh
for for students of under represented
background and uh as part of the effort
that I have
uh trying to do that I have been trying
to do to uh to share the education that
I have had access with my uh my uh
National peers in Brazil I was able to
help in hiring PhD students and
professors from from that from Brazil to
serve as mentors for American students
at the S science internship program and
this is uh totally in alignment with the
mission of the Sip
program as I will begin to explain to
you right now uh I consider myself very
close to the mission of Sip and and
particularly to to the uh the ideas that
are on the founding uh on the thoughts
of the founding director Dr uh Raja and
so C has this initiative of stimulating
uh critical thinking and research and
the goal is to create equity in uh in
what here we are calling Steam for
science technology engineering arts and
Mathematics
and so that part creating equity in in
Steam is the crest part so this is a
philosophy I would say that was very
present at the very start of the program
in
2009 uh right now the program has uh as
I as I said it grows every year it has
uh grown uh my understanding from this
part the St star is star night program
is uh is a program where a person that
works with
astrophysics uh Raja is a
uh a professor in the astrophysics
department at uh
UCSC what happens here is that
researchers that work uh observing the
cosmos they uh receive students not
necessarily here High School students
but students uh younger younger than
high school students and what what they
do is the is that the students talk to
the mentor for one hour about the
research that they are doing and so what
happens here is that the student has an
opportunity to stay with a mentor and
see how research is conducted and what
the mentor has to do is that he just
needs to adapt himself to the idea that
he's been uh followed by a student and
he can uh just do his uh his research
experiment and uh and at the same time
talk to the talk to the to the students
so this exposes students to the idea to
the concept of science to the concept of
getting involved in a science project
and uh it is uh this is a concept that
uh Raja brings to the mentors all the
time that a science project is very
important uh for a student to work
with uh this has led to further
developments in the CP
program so uh with these uh Python and
research tutorials uh called py uh What
uh what Raja does is he teaches students
uh
in basically an introduction to Python
and they also uh look into a research
paper sorry they look into a research
paper and the questions that are uh
being addressed in the research paper uh
are presented to the students in these
uh tutorial
sessions then uh I joined CP I believe
it was
2015 uh PR I actually don't do not know
when P started but just this year we
started teaching this other set set of
tutorials we are calling them Recon bio
for research in computational biology
and uh the idea here is to basically uh
also teach students us uh coding uh I
use R and Bash the terminal the command
line and here the idea is also present a
research uh research project and then
uh do some coding that answer the
questions that are present in the
research in the in the research article
uh particular particularly here we are
in during my PhD I was really interested
in variant uh variant uh in the genome
in the human genome but because uh the
SAR
to pandemic hit last year we switched to
studying uh mutations or variants in the
genom of SAR
cov2 uh because it is uh it is really uh
many times challenging to work in a
computer a computer server with a human
genomic sequence so because the Genome
of
virus is smaller than the uh Human
Genome I decided deed to switch to the
virus it it it it's easier to work with
viral viral sequences than uh than human
sequences so uh I told I told you
initiatives I presented to you
initiatives that uh try to stimulate a
scientific uh character in students and
I um I I told you that uh uh we try we
right now we're developing the idea of
doing this even before high school but
uh s really works with high school
students and really uh when the student
comes to an internship with a mentor
during the summer with SIP uh what we do
is we have the students uh follow us uh
in the lab uh doing uh an experiment and
also uh doing some uh
coding experiments as as I mentioned
just last year we changed a little bit
to studying the sarov genome rather than
the human genome but really here the
idea is to reinforce the need to expose
students to the concept of a scientific
project so that uh they decide or they
have the experience to uh
to uh develop a scientific project and
they can pursue a career in science
maybe in a university or maybe in
another institution that allows them to
develop uh further their scientific
career so after this all ends there are
initiatives at uh that s work with for
instance the global sphere network uh
sphere stands for stem programs for high
schoolers engaging in research uh early
and it is a combination of uh programs
that intend to uh Mentor High School
students and also uh along the years
other initiatives have um joined forces
uh with
these with step so sorry what we have
right now is the alumni buddies which is
basically uh more senior uh high school
students that have uh been uh mentored
uh years uh before the current students
they provide some advice on the research
presentation on the uh the uh many times
uh dis students are using the dorms and
the buildings at the University uh so
things like uh information about places
to eat or uh how to go for the uh for
the
the extracurricular activities that are
provided by SE are these are this this
information that is provided by alumni
the alumni bodies uh uh
initiative uh this sip is for teachers
in Sip and the idea here is
expanding expanding uh the Sip
initiative to uh sips I believe it's uh
it's teachers in in the county uh sip is
Community College uh sip the idea here
is to provide community college students
with some exposure to uh to a scientific
project to working with Mentor or
working with uh with a professional in
Academia so in conclusion uh I think I I
need to finish here uh I think that
education and science have the potential
to help in correcting histor IAL social
inequalities in in both developed and
developing
countries this maintains an ecosystem
that is necessary for the soci the
social structure in both these types of
of countries and the goal here I believe
is to provide access to education and to
medicine to all individuals in uh in
these
societies um particularly I believe in
developing countries the governments
need to have initiatives to invest in
the formation of Human
Resources uh to correct for these
historical inequalities and also to
maintain a minimum access to education
and medicine and I believe this is where
I fit because uh I don't know if I told
you but my studies were funded by the
government of Brazil and so uh I need to
work to uh allow uh education to be
available for for the Brazilian
Society so I would like to end here and
thank you so much for this
opportunity oh I I fin I just finished
my
slides
uh we we see that Pine biotech also
works to connect students to Academia
and to professionals uh to the Academia
professionals that are designing the
curriculum and the opportunities that
shape the future of
bioinformatics uh
research so so brait thank you Jano for
your presentation thank you and I do
want to mention that uh Gio is also
starting to Mentor a couple of students
uh in one of our programs which I'll
talk about in just a few more minutes
but now we want to hear from subit barua
and kind of hear about the way he got
interested and got actively involved in
bioinformatics and
astrobiology thank you so much and I
share my
screen real quick all right so first of
all I would like to thank the organizing
Committee of P biotech for providing
this opportunity and as the theme for
today was the changing role of
bionformatics I would like to talk about
how bionformatics is being used all over
the globe to leverage astrobiological
studies and the researches of
astrobiology all across the clo so
before we move on to the research of
going on the projects and what I'm doing
first of all a brief introduction of who
am I and what am I currently doing so I
began my bioinformatics journey from
find biotech itself so I am an ex
research intern it is here where I got
to learn about the various algorithms
got to learn about transcriptomics
genomics multiomics data science machine
learning and this is really the place
where I was baptized with bioinformatics
data science and its biological
applications after that I moved on for
my higher education and currently I a
master student pursuing molecular
biology and biotechnology from itmo
University St Petersburg Russia and I am
also a 100% government funded scholar
here from the Russian government which
is a big opportunity given to me for
studying higher getting higher education
and also also doing a lot of research
talking about research and I am here
enrolled in the scamed international
laboratory University and I'm a member
of the applied genomics lab and my
supervisor is Dr Alexi kamarov and under
him I am working on a couple of projects
incl involving human transomics
epigenetics and also serm
astrobiological experiments and research
projects about which I'll be talking in
just a while apart from that since I
love astrobiology so much I am a part of
an initiative uh startup in India which
is called space onova and I'm currently
the head at the department of
astrobiology at space onova we have a
vision and a mission to make India one
of those space fairing ecosystem in the
world where each and every individual
has the capability and the resources to
become a space
technologist and since I I love to
communicate and spread the word of
astrobiology everywhere I'm also an art
and scientific Communicator at Art of
inquiry and I'm working under Julia
brosi she is a CEO of art of inquiry and
also a forward NASA astronaut trainer
and here you can see some of the
examples where I have been doing this
science communication stuff basically in
the domain of
astrobiology so that's uh like a lot of
information about me but let's focus on
on what I'm going to talk about today
that is
astrobiology so if I'm asked to define
the term
astrobiology and what is it actually
well a very crisp and short answer would
be it's a very multidisciplinary domain
of science which involves a lot of you
can say subdomains or parts of science
for example origin of life on Earth
itself it's still a mystery and it's
being explored how did life originate on
Earth Earth similarly we also have this
very curious question where which we try
to find the answer of that is life there
outside anywhere of Earth is life there
in any of the other planets or
satellites or any of those discovered
exoplanets because just like in today's
talk Dr the surma pointed out that there
are so many other earthlike planets all
across the universe so who knows maybe
in one of those planets life do exist
and to understand that and to find out
if life does exist somewhere else it is
very essential to study the geology and
environmental conditions of those
planets so that can be considered as one
of the domains of astrobiology and
finally The Domain in which I am most
interested and excited about is space
Health there's a lot of risks involved
with space travel and with more and more
Focus being given on long-term missions
like a mission to moon or even to Mars
is going to take a lot of time and
exposure to certain factors for such a
long time will have an effect on the
human health and the human body so I'm
really interested to investigate and to
prepare ourselves before we embark on
such a mission so that this kind of
mission will have the least impact and
the most outcome in a positive manner so
talking about origin of life well there
has been a lot of talk going on in the
recent days that life might be there on
mars or maybe if not Mars some of the
moons of some of the icy giants like
Europa or Titan but till date with all
the scientific advancements that we have
had over the past many years our dear
planet Earth is the only place where we
know that life exists and exists in
harmony grows and prospers everywhere so
talking about the life on Earth
extremophiles just like Dr Das pointed
out are those categories of microbial
organism which really poses a question
to us how much do do we really
understand
life what is the extent of life and what
is the range in which life can survive
well for a lot of time I used to believe
that life is confined in a very short
range but how wrong was I because
talking about the extreme condition of a
volcanic eruptions very high temperature
poisonous gases lava coming out life
should not exist but we do have species
of bacteria like strepto thermophilic
which do survive in such high conditions
high temperature conditions talking
about a highly acidic or alkaline leak
life should not perform very well at
such an absurd pH condition but again we
talked about certain extremophiles for
example acido thiobacillus th oxidans
which can survive and Dr Dasa also gave
wonderful examples of so many
extremophiles with so many unique
characteristics and properties and
finally this gave me a real shock that
for many years I us to believe that life
can never survive in space out of us
atmosphere in the vacuum with so much of
radiation and plus shooting temperature
going on life should never have a chance
that's the reason why we wear space shs
but this microorganism dinus Radiance
survived for almost a year exposed
completely to the harsh environmental
conditions of space above the
International Space Station this was a
part of the tan poo mission was by jaxa
and this really opened up a New Horizon
and a new boundary of exploration and
that's how I have been so much excited
about astrobiology because this really
begs us to ask the question how much do
we really understand life what is the
extent of
life as I was saying earlier I'm really
interested about space Health about
taking care of the health of astronauts
to understand what happens when somebody
goes on a space mission there are
various factors which play a role and
one of the most exciting factor is micro
gravity because once we go
out of Earth's Gra gravity very strange
things begin to happen these are some
pictures which we are all familiar with
we have seen these sort of pictures all
across the internet but if you notice
some strange phenomenon happens once the
acceleration due to gravity which we are
all habituated to that is 9.8 m/s Square
ceases to exist for example a droplet of
water does not fall down because there's
no gravity anymore but takes this sort
of a circular droplet shape because of
the now dominating surface tension force
similarly there are are a lot of fluids
in our body for example our blood or
cupos spinal fluid so this is a question
which I always ponder about what happens
to those fluids in our body there's also
fluids inside our cells which play a
role in signaling and stuff so there's a
lot of hormones and enzymes what happens
those chemicals once a person travels to
space and lives in the condition of
microgravity so even though space travel
seems very very exciting for all of us
there's a lot of challenges which these
astronauts have to face for example
altered gravity there's both
microgravity as well as hypergravity
then there's a high dose of ionizing
radiation there's low pressure and low
oxygen which can act as stress factors
the unusual condition of isolation does
have an effect on the psychology and the
physical nature of the astronauts and
definitely there's uh really altered at
atmospheric gas concentration in
space so there has been a very good
amount of questions going on today as
well during the Symposium that there's a
lot of things going on in the space
biology domain but is the data available
for us to analyze and what how can we
actually use bioinformatics to leverage
those sort of studies so here's the
answer to that because NASA and other
space agencies have been looking at
space omix for a long long time but it
is only recently that the growing
interest of astrobiological research
among other researchers as well as
students have really forced people to
form consortiums and groups such as the
gene labs and international standard for
space omics who really take care of this
sort of data and curate them and make
them publicly available for research
this typical idea was really forced by
the twin study a unique opportunity for
mankind to study what happens to humans
once they are sent to space so they were
the Kelly brothers and they are
identical twins one of them sered as a
ground control on Earth and the other
twin went to space and spent uh some
days less than a year about the
International Space Station and once he
returned their uh DNA was taken
sequenced and the various omic domain
were investigated there was genomic
study transatomic study study of the
telome and also multiomic study and
those sort of studies really gave us the
idea that there's definitely certain
changes that can be noticed in the
person who traveled to space some of
them resolved after a span of six months
or so whereas some of them were really
permanent and there were mostly
epigenetic studies changes in the length
of telomers and stuff so with these sort
of H really crazy projects happening all
across the globe me as a Enthusiast of
astrobiologist really got interested in
space omics and currently I'm really in
the beginning of looking into this
particular domain and I am investigating
the gene expression of various model
organisms plant model organisms like
arabidopsis and as well as human cell
lines with the help of publicly
available data and I'm utilizing B
formatics and machine learning
algorithms like PCA and hierarchical
clustering to generate meaningful data
to study the differentially express
genes to study the pathways which are
altered and with
that I would like to say that that is
like the outline of my projects that I'm
currently working on I'm depending upon
the publicly available data in the
various uh consortiums and various
repositories and really comparing them
with space flight as being one of the
conditions versus the ground control and
its effect in isolated factors like
isolated microgravity or isolated
ionizing radiation there's different
organisms that I'm studying for example
model organisms like zebra fish and mice
and rosopa arabidopsis and also some
human s lines and there's a need for
this field to grow there's a lot of
opportunity and with the correct
mentorship and correct guidance I
believe more and more students all
across the globe can really learn about
astrobiology and contribute big time to
this growing field of science and me as
an Enthusiast would definitely love to
contribute and do some more research and
to understand what actually happens and
how we can address some of the problems
that originate when long-term space
flight is taken so thank you so much for
having me here and if you have any
questions or if you have any suggestions
any feedbacks definitely feel free to
reach out to
me thank you very much soit and great to
see both present presentation that you
prepared and great to interact with you
about your project um I wonder if you
could introduce Ur I'll just briefly say
from my side uh that you know Ur
represents one of those people that uh
has a lot of determination as far as I
can tell to get to where she needs to go
and as a result was able to apply
herself in many different areas only
some of them include bioinformatics from
which I know uh but I'm looking forward
to hearing about your talk please go
ahead yeah so to introduce you urja well
she is a visiting scholar at Blue marel
space Institute of Science and also a
research internet P biotech she is
really passionate about astrobiology as
well just like myself and she is doing
some really cool projects and trying to
explore more so I think it's better to
hear from urja herself so I won't spoil
anything it's over to
you thank you so much Elia and thank you
so much subit for that uh lovely
introduction I would like to begin with
sharing my
screen all right so um so RIT has given
a really nice presentation on
astrobiology and how we can apply omix
to
astrobiology and as part of uh my
project with Blue Marble space Institute
of science um I am working on Dino Focus
Radio Durance which is an extremo file
which uh sirit also mentioned and I'm
working with Dr Dimitra Atri and I have
collaborated with pine biotech to do my
project but before I start talking about
it I would like to first introduce
myself uh so I recently graduated uh in
biomedical science uh from narji
Institute of Management studies in
Mumbai
and I will now be beginning my PhD at
the German Cancer Research Center which
is in Heidelberg Germany uh I'm also as
already mentioned a visiting research
scholar with Blue Marble space and I am
working on astrobiology projects over
there so um I started my studies in
biomedical Sciences in 2016 where I
gained a lot of knowledge in very many
different areas of biology in 2018 I
worked at a lab uh in Mumbai where I was
um involved in several different
projects where I also discovered new
strains of yeast and uten them to make
them sensitive to a particular
antibiotic and I was also involved in
creating a shuttle Vector uh which was
uh expressing a type of Gene from yeast
that made it red in color um I then
worked in the field of nanotechnology
where I synthesized zinc oxide nanop
particles from a PL PL extract the plant
was osora
CIA uh in 2020 I collaborated with pine
biotech as a research fellow and with
that I had my first uh omix project ever
and uh I think that project really
boosted my career uh where I tried and
elcid certain biomarkers that are highly
expressed in gasta stem
cells uh next for my Master's thesis I
work uh worked at a hospital and I'm
also currently work working there where
I am involved in several studies uh one
wherein I am trying to establish certain
biomarkers for diseases like
intracerebral hematoma and traumatic
brain injury and I have also used
machine learning to create a diagnostic
system uh that can uh it can diagnose
the rise in serum creatinin in patients
um and now I will be starting my journey
in uh at dkfz where I'll be pursuing my
PhD in cancer biology so uh just to give
you an overview of the first toix
project that I pursued with pine biotech
uh gasta multiform is a very aggressive
type of brain cancer and a patient has a
survival period of only 15 months post
therapy what I intended to do was to try
and identify the origin of this
particular type of cancer and according
to uh current hypothesis this particular
type of cancer can originate from either
cancer stem cells or it can originate
from normal neuros stem cells that have
undergone some sort of transformation
into a cancerous phenotype so in order
to solve this question I performed RNA
sequence
analysis uh so I took a data set from
the Geo database where I took 40 samples
20 of normal neural stem cells and 20 of
Goma stem cells and performed RNA seek
analysis what I observed was these two
types of stem cells were uh genetically
different and uh that uh no there was a
particular outlier sample that had
certain similarities between normal NE
stem cells and Goma stem cells which I
believe could be an important hint as um
it could give a important clue regarding
how normally your stem cells are
transformed to Goma stem cells I was
able to obtain 192 genes that was
significantly upregulated and 156 that
was significantly down regulated in
gomas themselves from there I was also
able to identify several important
Pathways that may be driving tum Genesis
and gastas like the wind signaling
pathway GF beta pathway and the wedf
signaling pathway and apart from that I
was also able to identify several genes
that have currently no known association
with this particular type of cancer so I
was able to use omix data analysis uh to
identify several types of biomarkers
that can be potentially exploited uh in
the future as therapeutic
targets now coming to my work with
astrobiology uh with glue marble space
as I mentioned I'm working with Dy Focus
radiodurans which is an extremo file
that I'll be talking about soon uh the
reason why I have chosen uh to pursue
this particular project and to work with
Blue Marble space is because
astrobiology happens to be one of those
areas which really interest me and maybe
in the future I would like to even
pursue a career in this field and
because um the research that is
happening in this particular field is
not necessarily only related uh to space
biology but with this kind of research
we can actually help people on Earth as
well and I'll be talking about how uh
that is possible so the title of my
project is multiomic analysis of dyo
focus radiodurans uh and how we can uh
exploit its radioresistant properties
for space travel and even cancer
therapy so um space is not complete
vacuum uh I mean it is but there are
certain other things that may be
influencing the health of an astronaut
in space so um there are different types
of radiations that pose a very massive
threat to the health of astronauts when
they are in space and as we uh progress
with advances in technologies that may
bring us closer to traveling to Mars uh
the threats also remain so we need to
evade those sort of um environmental
stresses that may we may find in space
and those are uh stresses like solar
radiation Galactic radiation and even uh
radiation that may be trapped in inside
the
magnetosphere now the reason why we are
trying to evade this particular risk is
because ionizing radiation can cause
very very um uh drastic changes in the
human body uh it can lead to cancer it
can cause loss of vision it can cause um
skin burns it can cause several health
problems in astronauts and if we are
talking about long-term space travel
then uh we really need to find a way to
sustain ourselves uh through chronic
exposure of ionizing radiation
so what can we do to protect the body
from this particular ionizing radiation
now there are there's several research
that is going on where they are trying
to focus on radiation mitigation
strategies and what I am trying to focus
on is something very unconventional uh
which is I'm trying to look at dinus
radiodurans as a model organism that can
survive very high doses of ionizing
radiation so Dino focus radiodurans is
an extremophile that can survive 12,000
greater than 12,000 gr of radiation
which is several times larger than the
ionizing radiation that was created
during the uh atomic bomb droppings at
Hiroshima and Nagasaki the reason why
this particular species is uh this um
interesting is because it has several
mechanisms that help repair the DNA once
it is exposed to ionizing
radiation uh and it has several proteins
that are involved in DNA repair
mechanisms that uh give this particular
organism an edge when it comes to uh
being exposed and survival in conditions
with high ionizing radiation and it also
has certain enzymes that uh give them
this particular advantage to survive but
we currently do not know all the
mechanisms that are driving radio
resistance in Dino Focus Radio
Durance uh so up until now there have
been some studies that have focused on
omix data analysis uh in terms of Dino
Focus radiodurans but we have still not
been able to identify very important
genes that may be extremely crucial for
the process of radio
resistance and the other question that
remains is even if we do find this
particular Gene that may be driving
radio resistance can it be exploited in
humans so the aim or the rational of my
study is to identify certain conserved
genes across radioresistant species of
Dino focus and I intend to do that with
RNA analysis uh even possibly identify
Gene regulatory Pathways via chips
analysis which is um epigenetic studies
where we can see how the genetic
environment of the bacteria is modulated
uh in order to drive radio
resistance and the question that I'm
trying to solve is will we be able to
identify genes that can possibly uh not
just help us
in sort of like using it for radio
resistant mechanisms or radiation
mitigation in space but can we also
somehow exploit these particular genes
for cancer therapy because um one of the
largest threats in cancer therapy is
Radio resistance post uh radiation
therapy so is there any way we can
exploit this modal organism for that
purpose uh so uh another very uh I would
say this could be like a very ambitious
thing to look at but can we then make a
synthetic microbiome using these kind of
extremophiles and uh you know put them
in astronuts that would help them
survive in space in the long
term so there have been several studies
uh this far which I was I'll just
explain to you very briefly so um sa
have tried exposed uh dcus to very high
amounts of radiation and they saw
certain proteins were overexpressed and
they also found certain novel small rnas
that were expressed um so what they are
saying is that the small rnas would be
important in looking at Downstream
targets for identifying radio resistance
mechanisms there's another study that
has looked at methylation in the DNA of
dinoc species uh where they have looked
at how methylation can lead to up
regulation and down regulation of
several important genes driving radio
resistance and Dino Focus um we can
actually instead of just looking at
methylation we can actually do chipseek
analysis and very recently chips
analysis has been done uh for dinus
species there are other mechanisms that
have also been looked at with omix data
analysis where they have looked at this
particular um pathway which is the mass
EF pathway which is another important
driver of uh radio resistance and Dino
Focus um however the treatment that was
given in this particular study was with
mitoy and not ionizing radiation so we
currently don't know whether this could
be a good mechanism for driving radio
resistance or
not uh so this particular study um which
is conducted by Eugen at all is also
looking at uh ir and ddro which are
basically transcriptional repressors
that are regulating radio resistance in
Dino cus and this is actually the first
ever chipseek study done in Dino focus
and uh has its fprint is available on
bio
so this is also very interesting study
to look
at uh and this is the Tano study that
subit was talking about where dinus
species were exposed to uh the low or
Earth orbit on the International Space
Station and then they performed omix
data analysis with the dinus species to
identify certain genes that may be
upregulated or downregulated in Dino
Focus well so um not only Dino Focus
radiodurans but there are different
other different types of species that
are extremely resistant to ionizing
radiation that can be looked at um so
what I intend to do is uh comparative
transcriptomics where I want to identify
genes that may be conserved across
species of Dino Focus like Dino Focus
deserty metallus Banis geothermalis uh
the R1 species so what I intend to do is
take the RNA data of all of these
particular species
and then identify conserved genes uh
because these particular conserved genes
can then be common targets that we can
actually look at with confidence and say
that they may be important drivers of
radio resistance across dcal species so
uh this is just like a uh I'm currently
working on this project so it is work in
progress so I intend to uh complete the
study and find something meaningful in
the field of astrobiology and maybe
someday it can be exploited for uh human
purposes as well um so yeah I would just
like to conclude my presentation over
here since I think I've also run out of
time uh but uh I would say that uh omix
data analysis as you know uh is
something that you can apply to many
many vast areas uh in
biology uh not just uh cancer not just
astrobiology but actually any possible
Fe that you can think of uh so that is
something that I really like about this
particular area that once you have
picked up this particular skill you can
apply it to any research area of your
interest So yeah thank you so much um I
would love to take questions if you have
any and you can always contact me on my
email great thank you very much urja and
subit was very nice to hear your
presentations and we hope that we will
uh still see you soon again and uh hear
about the
progress um in conclusion of these great
presentations I want to share a little
bit more information on how any one of
you uh can actually join the research
fellowship program and participate in a
research study using computational tools
and one of these opportunities is a
research fellowship program run by Pine
biotech so uh the onx logic research
Fellowship is a program designed around
computational biology for those that are
interested not to just learn and acquire
skills but actually develop a research
study and uh the research fellowship
program is designed to provide support
and guidance uh and what I want to do in
today's uh brief description of this
program is explain how does it actually
work and how you can get
started so as as you heard today many
collaborators from today's speakers were
here to offer uh their perspective on
bioinformatics different areas of
biology and our close collaboration with
these organizations allows us to apply
uh kind of a case study design to this
program so I'm really excited about uh
kind of working with a lot of the
experts in the field and being able to
make this an opportunity that anybody
can access so in in this section what I
want to do is briefly describe what is
the research fellowship program how to
join us this fall uh how to submit a
project on the AMX logic portal and what
makes a project stand out so first of
all where are we in terms of our program
so we are working primarily in the us
but we do have a lot of collaborations
outside including India and Africa as
you have heard in the beginning of
today's program and overall we've had a
size of ible experience working with
over 15,000 participants across 162
countries so we really are agnostic
about where you live and obviously that
is because we are online and so you can
join this program virtually the program
really consists of tools for Big Data
analysis so we heard today Gio was
mentioning how they decided to work on
viruses instead of let's say human data
that is a typical challenge many studies
after they exceed a few samples and
large genomes you don't have tools you
run out of space you run out of RAM and
so we provide that infrastructure to run
your analysis on scale the second
component that we provide is mentorship
it's really more than just having
somebody to ask a question it's somebody
that can understand what are you trying
to do and guide you with not as a
teacher right not as somebody that
actually trains you but as a mentor
somebody that can oversee make
suggestions point you in the right
direction and finally we provide
training because many people see a gap
between where they are and the skills
they need to be able to meaningfully
analyze data we provide organized
scheduled training for you to go through
independently asynchronously on your own
time learn about different types of omix
data learn about different approaches
apply different types of algorithms and
therefore kind of develop your skills
and so briefly let me first talk about
some of these resources that we provide
as a part of this program and as a part
of some of the other programs that we do
as well so one of these resources is the
server T bioinfo platform and the omx
logic portal so you probably all have
already seen on the Symposium page right
on top you have a menu on that menu if
you click on the logo you will go to the
main AMX logic portal just by
registering there for free you will have
access access to a lot of free resources
that you can try out and explore some of
the other materials that we have after
24 hours of being on that portal you
will also get demo access to the TBI
info platform and as you've seen today
there are many exciting new features
that are com coming out on this platform
and we also will be showcasing them once
they are ready but already many areas of
AIC data are available for analysis on
that
platform now the portal includes a
personal profile and as somebody who
wants to do research this is the place
to start anybody who is entering this
field in bioinformatics has to build up
their profile and they have to do it by
showcasing what have you achieved so if
you ask any scientists what does that
result in Publications poster
presentations Etc we've modeled our
profile around the same idea allowing
you to see how much you have learned
what are the courses and the programs
you are involved in and build out your
profile with relevant project
presentations now if you don't know
anything at all about a particular
interest area that you have and would
like to learn we provide scheduled
programs Guided by mentors where you can
learn synchronously by joining live
sessions and also utilize online
resources so we have a lot of
asynchronous courses starting from the
very beginning and ultimately leading
you to complete sessions with practice
and so after completing a number of
those you can interact with the mentors
and you can actually complete uh those
areas of specialization and earn points
and so that's another metric that we use
to communicate with the students and
with the mentors that we have because
ultimately we have a process in mind we
want everyone who wants to be a mentored
who wants to do independent research to
be ready for that right not to come with
nothing to offer but come with some
basic skills that you can showcase and
so you can do that by building up your
profile and showing what courses you
have completed now we also provide a
number of other opportunities that I
want to talk about after this but before
I do I want to ask all of you that had
the patience to stay up until now uh to
actually uh join us and our mentors on
our social media uh platforms so we have
a group on LinkedIn where you will find
all of our mentors and all the different
connections that you've seen today we
try to invite all of them to join there
if you want to find their information
how to contact them you will find them
in this group so please join on Linkin
and on Facebook we have two places where
we have sizable groups of relevant
contacts if you want to get involved in
these kinds of opportunities so please
join those so as I mentioned uh you know
this is the place where you can build
your profile on learn and then connect
with mentors and through our program
we'll facilitate introductions and make
meaningful introductions with mentors if
you would like to
join um yes you're welcome to join the
groups the group on
LinkedIn so what is the training part of
what we do first of all we have some
basic work that you can learn about
bioinformatics and what it includes
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epig genomics and data science how to
work with data how to code an r in
Python how to run Big Data analysis
pipelines how to do data wrangling and
visualization right so all of those
things are covered in that portion as
well then we have specialized training
including Next Generation sequencing RNA
seek analysis or single cell analysis
and a lot of similar courses that you
can either take asynchronously or Guided
by a person finally we provide
introductory projects that you can take
to understand a particular domain like
the SARS Cove 2 I saw a lot of questions
today about what will be the impact of a
mutation or how will the mutation affect
transmission or things like that so we
cover a lot of those questions using
publicly available data and Publications
to try to answer those based on the data
that is available now as I mentioned a
lot of that is not possible on your own
laptop and so that's why as a part of
this program you and as a part of just
registering actually on the portal you
get access to our big data analysis
platform so there you have access to
various processing tools statistical
analysis tools different types of
machine learning models as well as more
advanced kind of sections for multiomics
integration and biological
interpretation
now after this you're ready for the
fellowship after the basic training what
is essentially the fellowship itself the
fellowship is how to go beyond that and
that's where you get an opportunity to
spend three months or six months to work
on an independent project that you
design that you essentially come up with
a topic you then find the data set
perform literature review and work with
a mentor to complete it what does it
mean to complete it completing it means
means that you present that to your
peers and experts for feedback so as you
know we kind of rely on science
published in peerreview journals well
peer review is an important part that
essentially combines working with others
and then submitting your findings for CR
critique uh questions and and feedback
and so that's essentially the outcome of
this program now many people struggle
with the first part of that path and the
first first part part is finding a topic
for your project or choosing a topic for
your project and so what we recommend is
kind of thinking about it as the
intersection of three different areas a
topic that you know and care about
something that will be interesting to an
audience and something that has
available data you can actually find
data sets that describe that and provide
you with data so after you do that you
might want to go through some examples
and we provide a number of different
practical examp examples that you can go
through such as epigenetics of asthma
modeling Precision treatment of breast
cancer deep uh Cersei sequencing of poo
virus as we heard today from Raul uh
different types of ecological projects
analysis of the changing immune
responses and cancer for immunotherapy
microbiome biomarkers from the American
gut microbiome project whole
transcriptome profiling of cancer tumors
and mouse PDX models deregulation of
subcellular networks and cancer patients
using the cancer genome Atlas different
types of
biotechnology agriculture neuroscience
virology and finally your own project so
after surveying some of the projects and
kind of understanding how they were
organized now you are ready to start
working on your own project but just
choosing a topic like oncology or
virology or even extremophiles is not
enough as you have seen in today's
presentations what makes a project stand
out part of it is what are you focusing
on and so an important part of what you
can focus on it comes from literature
comes from the body body of research
work conducted by others where you can
review available Publications and you
can understand what they cover and where
are those gaps and unanswered questions
or controversy or debates where there's
disagree agreement and gaps in current
research and that can help you make your
hypothesis more specific and essentially
Define your unique question then we have
some resources that we can help you with
to try and find data sets to try and
address that Gap or controversy with a
data set and so as you know there's
millions of data sets out there that you
can survey and identify something that
might lead you in the right
direction obviously that's not easy and
so that's why we have a slack channel
that we invited all of you to join where
you can start interacting with mentors
following a weekly regular progress
report and essentially have somebody to
give you feedback as you develop the
project and as you start working on the
analysis now again all of that is
following a process that already is
implemented on the learn portal once
your profile reaches 10,000 000 points
and you complete your profile then you
have to complete a course on how to
design and complete a b informatics
project and then you will be able to add
a project of your
own okay and so what are some of the
elements of this program number one you
do a comprehension and Analysis of
existing types of data existing types of
literature and essentially questions
that are being asked in the domain that
you find interesting you then learn how
to investigate not based on ideas and
just hypotheses that others have
proposed but think critically about the
data that you find and learn how to test
your hypotheses explore the data and
find meaningful P patterns and another
component is not just doing the analysis
but also being able to describe it and
so that's the final part where you learn
to organize your thoughts and IDE ideas
into something that is ready to be shown
and reviewed by an expert in the field
and so we've defined this as a specific
step-by-step process that we go through
in weekly meetings and ultimately help
you organize all of that information
into something that you can put together
assembling a poster presentation or
perhaps a pre-print or even a
publication submitted to a journal and
so as you have seen today many of the
people people that spoke are past
research fellows like Ora and you've
heard and she also went through the same
process developing her project
submitting a poster presentation getting
feedback and working through that
feedback and ultimately planning to
publish some of our research in
tomorrow's session you will also hear
about some of the other programs that
we've conducted where multiple students
work together on poster presentations
either together with our team or
independently what does that allow you
to do first of all it allows you to
really practice the skills that you have
learned and try to conduct independent
research but also as you will hear from
Ur and many others that you will meet
tomorrow you will see how this helps you
stand out and essentially kind of get
your attention in the field that you
want to be in whether it's
bioinformatics or a particular area of
research in a certain community and so
ultimately many of the people that we
have worked with have went on to present
receive prizes get recognition and
including recognition on our own portal
in situations like these where we bring
together others who are interested in
this field experts students and others
to really provide good feedback and help
them kind of understand what they can do
more with the type of information and
the type of research that they have done
now this applies to many different types
of students including high school
students undergraduate students as well
as graduate students and we've worked
with many graduate students PhD and
postdocs essentially helping them
transition from learning bioinformatics
to then being able to apply
bioinformatics in a meaningful way to
kind of work through their research
ideas and get meaningful insights maybe
before they generate the data or maybe
knowing what to do with the data they
generate and also we have worked with a
number of students in high schools in
the US in a lot of the programs that you
will hear about tomorrow students have
reached out to us and have utilized the
resources that we compiled to help them
work through a research project and some
of them even completed a full PhD
proposal just working on this kind of a
research Fellowship so as we conclude I
just briefly want to answer a few common
questions that students have when they
hear about this opportunity so can this
program be uh used for the requirement
of a university internship the answer is
yes what is the difference between three
and six months programs the difference
is that if you just want to apply
bioinformatic skills to your project you
only need three months if you want to
learn about bioinformatics and then do
this you might need a longer time if you
want to complete a full research study
you definitely need at least six months
how many hours commitment does the
research Fellowship require so the
answer to that varies and the answer
varies because some people come from
more of a computational background some
come from more of a biology background
after I'm done you will see some of the
posters that people submitted for the
poster competition many of them came
knowing nothing about bioinformatics but
it took them a longer time to get up to
speed some of them came with Advanced
knowledge of bioinformatics but they
learned new methods and apply them to an
interesting data set what are the
mentorship options so we do provide
several types of mentorship uh through
the program one option is just meeting
in those regular meetings with a trainer
and a mentor that can provide you with
some general guidelines another
opportunity is to work with a mentor
oneon-one on a project of your own where
a mentor essentially helps you figure
out what to do and the final option is
the other way around is to join a
project that is organized by somebody
else which means that an expert says I
want to study this question and I would
like you to help so those are the three
options that are available can you
choose any topic for your analysis the
answer is yes can you participate in
group projects again the answer is yes
we have many examples for those that
work together with their faculty for
example or with the whole class and then
finally pricing payment options in
scholarship so let me just briefly show
you where you can find all of that
information so if you're already signed
up on the learnx logic.com portal you
can quickly go and explore the courses
that I talked about but right here under
programs you will find some uh programs
that we offer and if you search here if
you don't find it right here you can
search right here and you will see
research fellowship and under the
research Fellowship you will find all of
the information that you need including
our upcoming dates that we will post by
tomorrow for when this will start
because the current batch is ending on
August 30th so I welcome all of you to
explore this and kind of understand how
it works if you have any questions feel
free to reach out to us at marketing
pine.
bio now in conclusion I just want to
mention that today was just the first
day tomorrow we have another day for the
Symposium to talk about how all of you
can get involved and make an impact this
kind of an online training is a solution
that will get you to a point where you
know whether you're interested or not
interested in bioinformatics and perhaps
complete a project on your own but if
you want to get into a program and get a
master's degree undergraduate degree or
a PhD you need some more than what we
can offer and so we will actually be
able to work with uh the people that you
will hear from tomorrow uh people from
Georgetown University uh Carnegie melon
uh from uh different uh programs here at
Louisiana State University you will hear
about a lot of opportunities on how you
can take what you already know and kind
of get a full-fledged degree in
bioinformatics and so we're very excited
for you to be able to do that so in
conclusion I want to pass this back to
Mr subit barua who will uh show you
where to find the posters uh how to
provide the feedback for the posters if
you're a judge or a participant and uh
for um the closure answer any questions
that we missed out on in today's session
thank you and over to you soet thank you
so much Alam and it was such a wonderful
day with so much information and
knowledge being shared um so what of the
most important aspect of the first day
of the Symposium is really the poster
presentation which is the result of some
great research by students in
association with many mentors so I think
this is the link I will paste it in the
chat
and
um there there are certain
judges of who will Mark the posters here
and you can if you are a participant you
can still navigate to the link that I
have shared in the chat and you can go
to this particular page here you will
find all the posters that has been
submitted by various students and
researchers all across the globe and
here if you scroll down all the way you
would see there's a button called
guidelines and scoreboard so if you
click on that you will be redirected to
a page where you would find in the top
the guidelines for judging and marking
these posters so the judging criteria
for all the posters have been divided
into four different categories the first
one is about the introduction of the
particular poster there are five five
different points that you can evaluate
from five being the best and one to
being the least good one so similarly
there's the criteria for methods and
results again from 5 to
one the discussion and conclusion and
the overall presentation quality so the
total score would be out of 20 and
that's how the student on the posters
would be marked so if you scroll down
this is a form where you can submit your
marks or the scores if you are a judge
you can click on this particular tab
here and select I'm a judge but more
importantly if you are a participant who
attended today's Symposium and you're
still with us you can also give your
opinion about all the posters and you
can click on this button as SEL that I'm
a participant you can enter your name
and your email ID and here here if you
click you will get the list of all the
participants who have submitted their
posters in this particular competition
you would select the name of the
participant and then give your scores
for all those four categories as I
mentioned earlier like introduction
methods and results discussion and the
presentation quality and simply click on
submit that would help us evaluate and
it would really help the students get a
feedack back for their poster
presentation that would help them grow
and learn more and definitely know the
areas where they can improve in the
future so let me once again show you the
page with all the posters here you would
find a video where of the presentation
of the poster where the student explains
or presents his entire research work
these are all uploaded on YouTube for
your convenience you can click here and
watch all the presentations are less
than 10 minutes in duration so they are
not very long and you can take your time
as your as for your convenience and
watch them for your
evaluation in addition to the videos we
also have the poster PDFs uploaded right
here in the website and now I will take
some time to one by one show you a
glance or a glimpse of all the
posters so the first poster
PDF is submitted
by yeah so sub submitted by suant and he
is from the University of Dhaka
Bangladesh and in association with the
mentors at Pine biotech his topic of the
poster is malaria RTS s as01 vaccines
association with controlled inflammation
and increased protection so here you can
see his wonderful poster and based upon
your experience and your analysis you
can Mark him and give him the scores
moving on the next poster is
by so the next poster is by aushi dedi
and vi vendel from the Department of
biology biotechnology and bioinformatics
School of Life Sciences University of
Hyderabad his uh I mean sorry her poster
title is identification of prognostic
genes and the associated Pathways
involved in lung cancer progression so
here is her poster feel free to go
through the poster and evaluate moving
on we have some other posters as well
which I would open up real quick so the
next one is by ad
abor and his poster title is
differential gene expression in drug
hypers sensitivity reactions molecular
basis for female
predilection and this is his poster so
feel free to Mark and give your
judgment the next poster
is
by Romy Ronnie Roy Romy Roy and he is
his poster is titled as a supervised
machine learning algorithm to predict
cyto release syndrome toxicity in car
Tel therapy which is also an interesting
domain and here is his
poster which you can definitely Mark and
evaluate
so this is how you can look through all
the posters here just click on the
poster PDF button and you can one by one
look into all the posters submitted by
all the students and give your feedback
evaluate them score them here's one more
example and this is done by Raja and her
poster title is insilico analysis of
transcriptomics profiling and affected
biological Pathways in multiple
sclerosis and here's one more this is by
kanua Sharma and her poster title is by
informatics approach to understand the
transcriptional CH changes in small cell
lung C lung cancer patients with brain
metastasis
so that's how you can go through all the
posters I believe I won't show you all
of them right now but you can definitely
take out some time and go through them
evaluate them give your feedback and
definitely give them scores on the basis
of which tomorrow tomorrow they would be
judged so talking about tomorrow and
definitely as we approach towards the
concluding hour of today's amazing
Symposium it was such a fruitful day and
a very successful first day of the
Symposium let me give you a really quick
recap of whatever we witnessed today and
whatever we learned so to begin with we
had some great keynote speeches from
some distinguished and really wellknown
professionals and scientists from all
over the all the world especially from
India Asia and Africa there was a really
great panel discussion uh in the
beginning hour of today's Symposium
where some great scientists discussed
about the future of B informatics in
India answered some of the very
prominent questions among students and
researchers and really enlightened us
with their huge Bank of knowledge then
we also had the second session of of the
second phase of today's Symposium where
we also learned about some really
interesting and advanced topics of B
informatics we learned the future in
which B formatics is heading and how we
can use B informatics to leverage the
various aspects of biological and
biomedical research we learned about the
various mathematical models we learned
about how we can Implement B formatics
to virology and to be ready for a future
pandemic we also learned about the
various upgrades and exciting new
features coming to the tbio info
platform we learned a lot about single
cell transcriptomics and finally we flew
off from Earth to explore the
possibility of Life on Mars and how is
it comparable with the extremo files or
the unique microbes which we can find on
Earth itself and how bioinformatics can
really help us to understand and to
derive meaningful conclusions from all
the data which are generated from the
space missions which like the
perseverance Mission the exomars mission
which is going to come up next year so
thank you so much for to all the keynote
speakers and panelists for their vital
contributions to today's
Symposium there was also another great
panel discussion which was on the topic
of omix advancements and it was so
enlightening to listen to them to get
all our questions answered to really get
a head start and a focus on how we can
Implement B informatics to our research
and what are the areas where there would
be huge progress in the days to come so
to summarize whatever we heard and to
summarize all the questions that we had
from the listeners from the people who
attended today's Symposium we can get
this summary that most of the people are
interested in knowing where we can find
data for our own projects so everybody
is interested to do a project of their
own be it and undergraduate or a post
talk people are looking for getting a
hand over publicly generated data
because to generate data is not always
feasible and also entails a lot of cost
so publicly available data is a great
way to do some really nice B informatics
projects so these questions were really
answered in all the panel discussions
and also in the last few hours the CEO
of fine biotech IIA brosi had really
emphasized on all the publicly available
data the repositories and the databases
where people can get hold of those data
for their projects there was one
question which popped up a lot of times
and and this was mainly from the
students who are in their undergraduate
or post-graduate degrees and also some
PhD students that what are some
opportunities and some early career
opportunities to get a flavor of the
real world experiments and real world uh
projects going on around the world how
to get a head start start we know that
it's really difficult to get a job in
today's market and to be ready to get
the perfect skill set to be the first
choice in any of those opportun unties
we definitely need to train ourselves
and to get a good experience level and
what are the opportunities that which
can really help us in that particular
aspect and this question was really well
answered by Mr IIA Bry and other
panelists in today's Symposium we got to
know about all the upcoming
opportunities at fine biotech itself
there has been a lot
of there has been a lot of opportunity
there has been a lot of programs run by
Pine biotic all across the globe and
there are many more opportunities coming
up be it a research fellowship program
or a program in association with a
university so there are some of the
opportunities where you can Kickstart
your journey in the domain of
bioinformatics and finally there was
another very prominent question which
was how can we collaborate with industry
and other big research organizations
because we do notice there's a gap
between what are The Cutting Edge
research going on in a in an industry
for example developing a new drug or
maybe doing some really unique projects
and how can we actually get to those and
experience them ourselves so our panel
panelists today also gave us wonderful
examples of how industry as well as
other research organizations provide
opportunities internships and
fellowships and some co-op s and some GL
Global training ships all across the
world where students can participate
there are also some scholarship
opportunities for some students which
definitely you can check out you can
look for them just feel free to apply
and also there are some great mentors
all across even in Pine biotic and all
across the world who are always ready to
help you so feel free to reach us to
reach out to us if you still have some
question if you still want to know more
about the opportunities to learn more
about what are the upcoming
opportunities where you can enroll what
are the benefits that you would get out
of those programs and that's how you
would definitely join a global community
of btic B informaticians and btic
enthusiasts and learn a lot that's how
we all learn so collaboration is the key
term and the key takeaway from today's
Symposium now looking at at tomorrow's
plans and tomorrow's agenda tomorrow is
going to be another very important day
for the Symposium as we now transcend
from the role of bioinformatics in
research to how can we actually get
involved so that's like a more elaborate
answer to all the questions and the main
questions that we had today that how can
young scientists and early career
students get an opportunity in Academia
as well as indust
so we will be having some really great
you know speeches from some very eminent
researchers all across the globe there
would be some talk where there would be
discussions about the upcoming programs
at am university geown university n and
other universities across the globe so
definitely make sure to join tomorrow
and listen to all these opportunities
because these are the places where you
can really get an experience a very
important and vital experience for your
career so you definitely would not like
to miss it there would be some great
panel discussions tomorrow as well apart
from the keynote speakers where
eminent uh people eminent personalities
from the industry for example the
companies which you hear nowadays A Lot
Like astroica and eagle genomics and
these are those people who would be
talking about the internship and job
opportunities what are the skill sets
that are required to crack these jobs
how can again young students get
opportunities to learn and to practice
their skill sets so this is also going
to be a very enlightening and Rich
experience for all of us where we would
get to know and learn about these
opportunities learn about the
requirements and that's definitely going
to help us in our career so tomorrow is
the day for dedicated to us you can say
the young professional so definitely do
not miss this one as we would explore
and dive deeper into the opportunities
and internships topic finally we would
have the results of the poster
presentation we I just showed you some
while ago the all the brilliant posters
submitted by some students who have been
working really hard for the last couple
of months or maybe some people have been
working for years and finally their hard
work has off they have published a
poster and now our eminent judges the
great judge panel will be judging them
and you as a participant can also judge
and let us know how you feel about those
posters and tomorrow we would have the
results declared for all those posters
and the winners of the poster
presentation competition would take away
some great prizes which even I don't
know what is it so it's going to be a
real big surprise for every everybody to
see what are the prizes that the winners
of the poster presentation would win
tomorrow and it's really going to be
very exciting I'm really excited for
this session the entire plan for
tomorrow and I hope that you are equally
excited as well so that's uh like the
conclusion part that I have now I would
like to hand over the virtual Podium to
Mr IIA brotsky and uh if you have
something to add on to today's session
maybe you would add on
otherwise it's farewell from us so the
on the final note tomorrow the sessions
begin at 7:45 a.m. Central Standard Time
which is 12:45 p.m. green wi mean time
and 6:15 p.m. in Indian Standard Time so
tomorrow's day is dedicated to data and
life science get getting involved
internship opportunities job
opportunities and making an impact in
the world of bical Sciences so if you
guys still have any question feel free
to post them in the chat we would be
definitely recording it and we would be
addressing All Those Questions either by
emails or tomorrow's in tomorrow's
session we would also be recording all
these sessions which you can find in our
YouTube channel and also in our our
social media platforms so do not forget
to follow us and to join our community
which keeps growing always and that's it
from Pine biotech team and finally I
would like to thank all the participants
those who joined us and stayed with us
for the entire day thank you to all the
keynote speakers thank you to all the
panelists thank you to the entire team
of pine biotic who have been working
really hard behind the scenes whom we
cannot see in the screen but it is just
because of them that this entire day has
been a real big success so definitely uh
we cannot forget them it has been
amazing to have you all guys it's such a
brilliant team effort that has paid off
so well and I wish you all the best for
tomorrow and I'm glad and I'm definitely
sure that tomorrow is going to be an
equal success so thank you so much to
everyone
and I wish you good night to the people
from that part of the world where it's
night and a good evening and a good day
to the others
so that's it from Bine biotics omix
racist Symposium day one we will again
see you tomorrow on day two with some
more exciting topics and more
exciting people to interact with take
care and have a nice
day y thank you thank you SRA thank you
everyone for joining uh we'll meet you
all again tomorrow so have a nice day
and have a good
night